[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
savard est très bien et surtout quand on
est en version claude évident là on est
on est en banlieue et quand on est un
bonus pour toujours au titre de ton
livre qui s'appelait enfants des lieux
banny d'un magnifique titre mais j'ai
appris que lé du banni bastais la
banlieue absolument c'est ça c'est
l'étymologie du mot banlieue est
d'ailleurs chant cloud est un endroit
symbolique à ce niveau par rapport à son
architecture et sa construction donc moi
je me récemment replonge effectivement
dans dans le bouquin mais le bouquin
effet même si c'est une autobiographie à
une dimension sociologique est donc
aujourd'hui on va un peu de découvrir
aussi d'autres parcours
ici
il ya du mahdi puis il ya ce que tu as
fait avec banlieues actives qui a un
travail formidable déjà deux des
banlieues c'est pour ça que tu es
heureux que ce soit là parce que ça
apporte beaucoup à cette éviction
tribune et justement avec avec banlieues
actives vous venez de faire un film qui
a été fait écrit par des jeunes enfants
s'appellent la promesse alors justement
oui j'avais faim précédents courts
métrages qui s'appelle cuir au paradis
que j'ai fait avec mon co auteur et co
real tomac muriaux et on avait fait un
concours pour que ce soit les jeunes eux
mêmes qu'ils imaginent soit une suite
soins avant au film et france télé est
tombé sous le charme de ce projet et
donc ils ont voulu être partenaire
dessus et donc qu'on a fait le concours
ensemble et là on le scénario gagnant
c'est celui qu'on vient d'adapter en
court métrage à nouveau et qui s'appelle
la promène en provence tgv est qui est
absolument
fantastique alors on va on va parler de
chanteloup-les-vignes puisqu'on est là
devant l'espace jean louis borloo c'est
par hasard et on dit que c'est ici que
jean louis borloo a découvert au fond ce
que pouvait être la politique de la
ville alors on va regarder des choses
notamment des choses positives qui se
font ici en matière d'éducation en
matière de formation en matière d'emploi
on parlait aussi un peu d'histoire avec
le maire emblématique que tu connais
bien de cette ville qui est elle au
serveur qui est pierre cardo absolument
que j'ai rencontrés j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer
lorsque je co présidait la commission
carrez quartiers populaires pour la
fondation terra nova et on l'avait reçue
et les solutions qu'il apportait la
maîtrise du sujet et la manière dont ils
lui voyait ses quartiers et est ce qu'il
fallait faire pour sortir de cette
espèce de sclérose
il avait impressionné plus
qu'impressionnant plus qu'impressionnant
alors un jour à vue l'on retrouve et on
va les retrouver retrouver pierre cardo
et brad may c'est bien auparavant on a
rencontré rafael vidic était préfet à
l'égalité des chances et je lui
demandais qu'est ce que c'est la
politique de la ville qu'est ce que
c'est les quartiers de la politique de
la ville
[Musique]
comment on définit un quartier en
politique de la ville si on fait un
quartier urbain qui concentrent les
populations les plus pauvres de la
société française ça se calcule en
fonction du revenu par ménage est donc
une politique de la ville c'est les
politiques complémentaires qui vont
venir en plus des politiques de droit
commun aider spécifiquement ces
quartiers pauvres ces quartiers qui
abrite une population pauvre et il ya
deux types de grands deux grands types
de politique de la ville il ya les
politiques dites de rénovation urbaine
on va essayer de reconstruire le
quartier pour éviter que il y est 100%
d'habitat social et essayer de faire du
la mixité sociale dans le quartier et
puis à l'extérieur on va essayer de
construire des logements sociaux hors
des quartiers politique de la ville et
donc ça c'est la première premier aspect
la politique de rénovation urbaine et
deuxième aspect toutes les politiques
dead aux associations aux acteurs de
terrain à l'éducation nationale aux
missions locales à pôle emploi pour
aider plus spécifiquement les les
habitants de ces quartiers
ma conviction c'est que la politique de
la ville ça marche ça marche et là où on
a eu des résultats assez probant que ces
dernières années je crois que c'est en
matière d'éducation on le verra dans les
années qui viennent évidemment c'est
toujours compliqué mais entre le
dédoublement des classes qui a été
vraiment pour les élèves de maternelle
dernières années maternelle cp ce1 la
constitution des sites et éducative on a
vraiment là une série de mesures qui
font qu'on prend l'éducation des des
enfants notamment des jeunes enfants
dans les quartiers pour leur transmettre
les savoirs de base on prend le problème
à la racine et on avait essayé d'y
apporter des réponses je pense que ça
portera ses fruits et je pense qu'on en
voit déjà les résultats là où on doit
encore progresser sans doute c'est sur
l'insertion des jeunes c'est sur
l'emploi où là encore le lien entre
l'éducation à la fin de la scolarité
avec tout ce problème du décrochage
scolaire et l'accès au monde du travail
est encore à parfaire on a fait des
progrès on a fait des progrès notamment
via l'apprentissage qui fonctionne bien
dans les quartiers en politique de la
ville mais on a encore à progresser on
aura demain le contrat d'engagement
jeunes qui sera effectif au est effectif
depuis le 1er mars et qui sera une
mesure qui permettra à tous les jeunes
notamment des quartiers d'accéder
pendant un an un revenu un peu
équivalent au rsa et d'avoir des mesures
pour pouvoir s'intégrer dans l'emploi
dans la société française
[Musique]
c'est une ville qui a été assez
singulière dans l'est dans le paysage
des quartiers en politique de la ville
parce que c'est une ville assez petit
dix mille habitants à peu près mais dans
le quartier en politique de la ville
quartier de la noé représente à peu près
la moitié de la population ce qui est
beaucoup pour une pour une ville comme
chanteloup c'est une ville qui a
bénéficié de l'effort de rénovation
urbaine important et qu'il continue et
c'est une ville qui a toujours été sous
l'impulsion de sa mère et je veux la
saluer je veux saluer son investissement
remarquable et de son prédécesseur
d'ailleurs pierre cardo a toujours été à
la pointe des dispositifs pour essayer
d'en sortir pour essayer de tirer tous
les jeunes vers le haut avec une
attention particulière mis sur
l'éducation et c'est moi je suis très
heureux je les visite et il ya quelques
semaines de la cité éducative de
chanteloup les vignes qui est une
parfaite réussite
[Musique]
rost on va on va raconter l'histoire un
de chanteloup absolument pas je suis
ravie d'ailleurs
de partager cet instant là avec avec
deux personnages que vous connaissez
bien sûr leur juan massenya vous êtes
journaliste vous êtes auteur vous êtes
un grand spécialiste de musique 1
notamment en plus oui de plus y compris
en plus oui oui même et grandi à
chanteloup et j'ai grandi à chanteloup
et c'est à chanteloup que j'ai en partie
compris que la musique ce serait
certainement une passerelle pour pour
aller voir ailleurs si j'y étais et donc
en mélodies
cette petite ligne de train qui faisait
mantes la jolie saint lazare nous a
permis comme ça d'aller découvrir le
reste de l'ile-de-france qui était déjà
énorme à l'époque l'homme et rose
quelqu'un que tu connais bien acté que
j'aime beaucoup et que tout bon alors
ici c'est une star absolue évidemment ça
vous le disiez déjà dans un documentaire
dans vos joueurs des extraits qui
s'appelait banlieusards c'est pierre
cardo père cardoze a été le maire
emblématique de chanteau des vignes vous
avez été député
vous êtes arrivé ici en 75 on va en
reparler
on va regarder peut-être d'abord grâce à
un extrait de votre documentaire qui est
qui et à quoi une dizaine d'années qui
un oui un peu plus d'une tisséo
billysienne d'année absolument qu est
intemporel tiens mais qui est intemporel
qui s'appelle banlieusards et vous
raconter d'histoires de chanteau on va
voir un premier accès qui nous rappelle
parce que c'était chanteloup avant que
ce ne soit ce que c'est aujourd'hui
jusque dans les années 60 chantre où
c'était un petit village bien
franchouillard peuplé depuis la nuit des
temps de familles d'agriculteurs des
maraîchers des paysans quoi
tout va changer tout va basculer dans
les années soixante dix à chanteloup
parce que l'état va décider de
construire un quartier tout neuf au
milieu des champs vous cité hlm de 8000
habitants beau milieu de nulle part
voilà c'était au milieu de nulle part
bah oui justement et vous juan alias
juanito pour les intimes oui
vous avez grandi ici à chanteloup et
vous parliez de ces tombions ce qui
était extrêmement joyeuse et festive
est-ce que c'est toujours le cas
je pense que chanteloup n'échappait pas
à l'air du temps c'est à dire qu'on est
dans des années 70
grande partie de la population sort de
la ruralité accède à la modernité
d'autres viennent de pays où quand on
parle de l'agriculture et du monde rural
là on est carrément dans une autre
époque et ici c'est l arche de noé donc
toutes ces populations avaient le
sentiment de
d'avoir la vie devant soi en fait
d'avoir le monde à portée de doigts et
effectivement ça rendait heureux et puis
s'il ya un élément qui avec le temps
maintenant revient me revient en mémoire
c'est que les parents étaient jeunes que
les enfants étaient petits et que le
pays était encore prometteur de beaucoup
de choses on est au milieu de début des
années 70 ce milieu des années 70 donc
on est dans une sorte d'insouciance et
n'a pas encore ce terme les trente
glorieuses où la fin des trente
glorieuses à l'oreille mais chanteloup
va être impactée et par un partenariat
depuis des années 70 absolument pierre
cardo alors vous arrivez dans les 75
à chanteloup
vous étiez chez chrysler à poissy voilà
vous optez un peu
parce que j'ai lu votre votre livre
l'espoir n'est pas un luxe ou vous
raconter tout ce cirque un livre
formidable parce que ça raconte et votre
histoire est l'histoire de chanteloup et
vous venez habiter ici je cherchais un
appartement j'avais atterri d'abord dans
un foyer sonacotra au grésillons
carrières sous poissy parce que je
pensais que c'était jeunes travailleurs
donc c'est pour moi enfin je me suis
rendu compte que ce n'était pas tout à
fait l'ambiance de la cité u
et donc dont j'avais entre temps on
avait un première l'aîné de notre
famille qui était né donc il fallait un
appartement plus grand et on a trouvé au
béguinage des appartements superbe à des
prix très raisonnables
c'était ce qu'on appelle les irm à
l'époque et donc j'ai habité plusieurs
années dans dans cet appartement mais en
attendant ce qu'on n'a pas la cité de la
noé ça brise ça donc j'ai créé la
première association de locataires sur
le secteur et j'ai découvert une cité
mais lunaire pour moi gross était alors
la vie ici c'est d'abord
il n'y avait rien dans la cité rien
n'avait été prévu en fait le conflit qui
avait eu lieu entre la commune et l'état
sur cette construction qui n'était pas
souhaitée par les habitants ça s'était
traduit par un procès
qui avait été gagné par les associations
de change joue contre l'état et qui
avaient donc le tribunal a considéré que
le permis quand ce n'étaient pas
valables à partir de là l'état a
abandonné la ville donc pas de commerce
on savait même pas où passer les réseaux
c'est abandonner complètement quoi ah
oui il y avait une zone industrielle qui
étaient promises il y avait la gare qui
était toujours pas là enfin il ré rien
et donc pour faire ses courses il
fallait monter au village pour acheter
le minimum certains traverser la pièce
la plaine avec des caddies pour aller
faire les courses chez leclerc à
carrières sous poissy enfin voila
c'était tout et n'importe quoi on avait
des câbles téléphoniques qui passaient
électrique est passé d'une fenêtre à
l'autre d'une tour à l'autre dans le
béguinage voilà et et en plus après va y
avoir la sphère aranda avec l'histoire
oui alors ça c'est affaire de corruption
là oui mais ça va rien arranger qui ne
va rien arranger ça va se passer très
mal donc l'état abandonne la ville à son
triste sort et comme en même temps il ya
nanterre dont on est en train de raser
les bidonvilles barbès pigalle dont on
est en train de restructurer les
quartiers tous ces populations dont
paris se débarrasse et expédient
champions où il ya de la place 1 au
départ c'était prévu pour les ouvriers
de l'industrie automobile au départ
c'est ça va guérir ion gros mais elle
veut jo et crysler vous à poissy yahia
renault flins au et au bol est en fait
il rien 1900 patronale donc c'est pas
des ouvriers qu'on va récupérer mais des
chômeurs et c'est ça qui est en grande
difficulté
mélangé à des cadres qui sont venus pour
un cadre de vie qui avait l'air assez
agréable donc évidemment au fur et à
mesure pas de service des populations
qui n'ont pas tout à fait l'habitude de
cohabiter ça va se traduire par il ya
plusieurs communautés différentes envahi
à combien 63 63 communauté on va passer
deux mille habitants à 11000 en peu de
temps et on va avoir une naissance par
jour oui c'est incroyable donc on est un
pays en voie de développement et
peut-être on n'a pas d'argent peut-être
qu'on peut rêver d un petit peu on n'a
rien sur la conception même de 7 2 7 6
t2 et un grand architecte les milieux 1
qui voit là qu'équipe missionné par
l'état et il ya un petit nez un extrait
dans votre documentaire roanne qui est
absolument saisissant sdiri raconte ce
qu'il a fait il ya un côté mégalomane
incroyable où on regarde mon action est
une action intérieure
la forme de l'affectivité des gens c'est
donc un changement dans voile derrière
lui d'en construire sans logement
des hlm n'a pas grand intérêt en
construire 3000 deviennent d'un univers
que l'on manipulé l'enfant de ce fait sa
une toute autre dimension
ça devient une façon de manipuler un
devenir ça incroyable mais vous parlez
mais là vous parlez de côté mais
mégalomane mais je trouve que ce qu'il
exprime justement est intéressante donc
dans tout ce débat conquis qui existent
sur la question des banlieues la manière
dont ça a été fait ça a été pensé
justement et vous qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire aujourd'hui vous qui avait été
maire de cette ville pendant pendant
longtemps
le discours de l'architecte ah oui parce
que j'ai je pense que il enfin il c'est
une idée un peu trop forte sur le rôle
que va jouer le l'urbanisme sur le
comportement des gens le problème c'est
à vous gagnez vous pouvez vous
conception vaincu de st alors lui il est
convaincu qui va jouer un rôle important
sur la façon dont ça va se passer moi je
partage son avis et bien moi je pense
qu'il faut arrêter de responsabiliser
systématiquement les architectes sur ce
qui se passe bien sûr il ya des erreurs
de conception notamment fermé les places
là j'ai une place permet un glacier
ouais ça fait qu'il ya un isolement de
la place qui fait que les gamins ne
savent même pas ce que c'est que la plus
grosse est une société dont on ne sont
pas l'inde entend par sa nature et quand
on va nous proposer quand borloo va
proposer le grand projet de ville et
qu'on va enfin pouvoir modifier
l'architecturé
après avoir entendu ce que disaient les
habitants et les différents acteurs la
police et on va restructurer et on va
ouvrir les places on va ouvrir la
circuit on va éviter cet effet
d'enfermement c'est ce que demandent les
habitants et toute la restructuration va
être basés là si on va pas détruire pour
détruire et pour réduire le nom de
mensonges sociaux ont détruit pour
ouvrir et aérée et c'est ce qu'on va
faire donc moi quand on explique que
c'est l'urbanisme qui responsables non
la façon dont on a projeté cette
population la façon dont on a pas autour
de l'urbanisme prévu comment on allait
se comporter sur le plan humain
qu'est-ce qu'on allait avoir comme
activité quels étaient les moyens du
fonctionnement là ça a été la
catastrophe quand je suis arrivé j'avais
aucun pouvoir tout était décidé à me
place le budget les gens que la ville
n'avait plus le droit de décider de son
budget de dépenses
voilà donc on avait plus de pouvoir
c'est la chambre régionale des comptes
qui décidez et donc il fallait reprendre
le pouvoir pour essayer d'imprimer une
volonté locale pour transformer les
choses je ne veux pas qu'on accuse
uniquement les architectes ils ont au
nom sabilité je trouve berlin milan mais
quand même changer la vie des gens et
moi je me méfie toujours des gens qui
bien sûr quand on a amélioré chanteloup
au niveau de l'organisme on a un mot
n'aurait l'image on a amélioré le
fonctionnement en améliorer le quotidien
des gens par un urbaniste qui était une
carte de visite présentée sur
l'extérieur notamment qu' elle est
revalorisée donc c'est important
l'environnement la façon dont on est
perçu en tant que ville bon mais en même
temps on peut pas se contenter de
réhabiliter le béton pour dire ça va
aller mieux l'humain c'est l'essentiel
si ça s'est dégradé en moins de dix ans
il a fallu commencer les premières
réhabilitations champions rendez compte
au bout de huit ans on me propose une
réhabilitation moi ça faisait je venais
d'être élu j'ai dit mais c'est pas
possible on enfin
ça s'est pas dégradée tout seul c'est
bien que bien qu'ils porteront des
habitants c'est bien parce qu'il ya un
malaise qu'il faut qu'on traite c'est
pas uniquement en traitant le béton
qu'on va régler le problème il faut donc
s'occuper de l'humain il faut redonner
une âme à cette ville il faut redonner
de l'espoir il faut donner des repères
aux gamins fin voilà c'est là dessus
c'est la politique de la ville c'est
vrai vous en apercevez de ce malaise que
vous avez grandi ici
non pas du tout parce que
on vient d'aborder la notion d' espace
et en fonction des âges les le même
espace ne n'impacte pas votre quotidien
de la même façon star et quand vous êtes
gamin que vous allez de l'école primaire
chez vous dans l'absolu les distances
elles sont réduites à l'est maximum 1 km
c'est vrai qu'au fur et à mesure
que le temps passe et
on a commencé à ressentir cet effet
d'enfermement n'ont pas de notre fait
mais du regard des autres est ce que
disait pierre cardo est tout à fait
juste c'est à dire que le regard sur les
habitants étaient pratiquement
inexistant voire même les desiderata les
origines les parcours les histoires de
ses habitants étaient des paramètres qui
était très peu pris en compte et il a
fallu un moment qu'on humanis et
quartier parce que le problème du bâti
c'est que s'il n'est pas humaniser ça
devient uniquement de l'asphalt du béton
et des parpaings et une ville quand on a
la prétention parce qu'une ville c'est
un magma social c'est un magma humain
avec des histoires des parcours quand on
a la prétention de vouloir faire vivre
60 plus de 60 ethnies différentes
ensemble la priorité c'est l'humain et
emile aillaud ce qu'il dit et je suis
tout à fait d'accord il
faut faire très attention procès
d'intention ce qui concerne ceux en
responsabilité du bâti parce que ça a
été la politique de notre pays pendant
les trente glorieuses et on a oublié que
bayal et des gens qui allaient habiter
avec des algorithmes humains organiques
etc et si on ne trouvait pas la note
juste pour les faire vivre ensemble peu
importe le bâti en fait on s'est rendu
compte à champions on a très vite
compris que la question du bâtiment
c'était secondaire n'était pas là ce
quand bien même c'est ce que disait
souvent pierre canton je me suis là même
borloo disait saint quand on aime quand
on n'aime pas sa ville quand on n'aime
pas son pays quand on n'aime pas sa rue
son bâtiment on ne s'aime pas et alors
là tous les problèmes commencent et
c'est là qu'on a vu moi j'ai vu au fur
et à mesure parce que je venais en plus
d'une d'une cité d'emmaüs donc là on est
dans des cités construites après guerre
quand on est arrivé à chanteloup pour
nous c'était l'avenir c'était ma main
était la promesse était magnifique à
voir une gare au pied avoir des des
commerces avoir cette espèce d'arche de
noé
il y avait quelque chose d'idyllique là
dedans malheureusement le projet s'est
arrêtée à mi chemin et surtout c'est
qu'on n'a pas
pris le temps d'essayer d'écouter les
gens qui venaient des quatre coins du
monde et qui habitait dans cette arche
de noé donc c'était ça le vrai problème
c'est pas les pour moi c'est pas les
architectes pierre cardo vous avez donc
vous habitez lavaud président et des
associations dont on l'avait quinzaine
d'associations pro éducative et puis on
vous demande de vous prononcer sur une
liste et puis je vous devenez mais
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé quand même à
devenir moi c'est toujours une question
que je me pose parce que il ya un tel
boulot à faire
j'ai peut-être peut-être de des moments
de désespoir fort qu'est ce qui pousse
quelqu'un vous lui à se dire baverez j'y
vais c'est à dire que d'abord j'ai vécu
mai 68 en arrivant d'algérie surtout à
lakanal pendant deux ans lycées occupés
je comprenais rien à ce qui se passe et
moi j'arrivais de mars ces gamins qui
connaissait pas la société qui voulait
la réforme et je me disais mais qu'est
ce qui se passe je ne comprends pas
comment on peut réformer une société
quand on ne la connaît pas et donc je
suis persuadé après 70 je suis pas fait
pour la politique c'est vrai maintenant
un monde qui m'échappe il ya des gens
qui ont des convictions enfin ce que je
prends pour des convictions en réalité
ce sont des idéologies et je me dis non
c'est pas pour moi et puis le monde
associatif à chanteloup je vais
m'impliquer très vite et il ya des
pouvoirs le terrain de foot où il ya des
gens qui sont entraînés il ya une
personne avec des bottes une femme qui
les entraîne légale un an blues enfin
voilà il n'y a pas de moyen de transport
aérien je vais faire du foot j'ai jamais
joué au foot pratiquement moi je faisais
que de l'athlétisme et des sports de
combat donc je vais leur faire faire du
sport je vais m'en occuper je me
retrouvais président des locataires je
vais régler les problèmes de chauffage
enfin bon et tout ça petit à petit je me
retrouve président d'une association de
gauche alors qu'en réalité je suis à
gauche
chaque joueur savait rien fait et et il
me demande de me présenter contre leurs
propres amis au conseil municipal en
plus ou d'un moment donc si vous voulez
c'est le paradoxe entre louvain et c'est
que ici là l'implantation locale elle
est essentielle et donc sans fait je
vais être poussés par les gens pour me
présenter alors j'ai pas envie je refuse
même au départ
dominé et au bout d'un moment tous les
billets à la rue mais pour y aller ça y
est les rapaces et toi qui sera
responsable de ce qui se passera
mais association j'ai pas envie que ça
disparaisse dans un truc plus ou moins
mal mal et voilà et j'y vais mais je
pense que je vais perdre parce que la
gauche vient de gagner à plus de 60%
même moins d'un an avant donc voilà pour
déjà pour trouver des candidats
s'étaient tous n'hésitez pas facile oui
je vous constituer la liste là le
dernier j'ai fait signer dans sa
baignoire quelques heures avant la fin
de la lola
et et on gagne et là je me dis mais vous
c'est que je suis encore allumé ce que
j'ai fait quand je prends l'association
déjà il ya des briques de dettes le
comptable foot et les factures à la
poubelle depuis six mois je me retrouve
avec les huissiers mois enfin voilà
chaque fois j'ai pris un truc il s'est
passé des choses
extraordinaires bon là
j'ai été chargé d'une mission je peux
pas y échapper donc j'ai la population
qui m'a fait confiance je suis obligé
d'aller au turbin c'est tout et en même
temps pas de question et c'est de
l'inconscience peut-être je sais pas ce
qui m'attend mais je m'en fous il faut
que je fasse à donner une responsabilité
vous y allez quoi et comment je vais
faire j'en sais rien et vous avez fait
justement beaucoup beaucoup de choses et
on al'impression d'ailleurs que vous
vous arrêtez jamais et mais quand vous
mettez une rustine par là on a
l'impression que ça fuit pas par ici oui
s'il n'avait pas eu des moments de
désespoir vous aviez lu on vit tout
lâcher les moments de colère des moments
de oui mais il ya cette injustice si
vous voulez pour moi changent tous été
victimes d'une injustice et donc le fait
que cette ville soit victime d'une
injustice et que sa population subit ses
conséquences pour moi c'est essentiel
c'est ce qui va me permettre de dépasser
ces moments de désespoir parce que tu en
entends j'ai envie de balancer tout le
monde par la fenêtre les dossiers enfin
bon mais on se reprend très vite parce
que a patiemment où vous avez
l'impression vous avez une mission par
rapport à une forme d'injustice ça vous
donne des fleurs c'est incroyable c'est
peut-être un peu d'inconscience ne sait
pas toujours du courage faut pas croire
mais on sait pas ce qui nous attend
heureusement il faut jamais essayé de
savoir l'avenir donc vous foncez vous
posez pas de questions et vous faites et
à partir du moment où vous avez comme ça
a été mais la chance que j'ai eue vous
êtes soutenus par la population par le
tissu associatif que vous avez réussi à
réunir des tendances qui n'était pas
fait pour son temps
vous êtes porté par une force qui va
vous faire
au bout d'un moment vous allez surmonter
tous les obstacles alors effectivement
ça peut être régulièrement mais eu des
émeutes oui mais comment on fait là peut
être porté que dans la population vous y
allez vous avez fait vous l'avez dit
vous ai fait des sports de combat ce
nom
vous apprenez à vous maîtriser et moi je
parlais pas assez du essentiel c'est que
le respect ça se mérite ça prend du
temps mais à un moment donné à force de
respecter les gens et de leur montrer le
respect que vous finissez par leur
inspiré du respect et sa fille ivre il
ya toujours une minorité qui une
minorité qui ne répondent pas cela mais
la très grande majorité va vous soutenir
et dans tous les problèmes qu'on a eus
c'est toujours la population et les
associations qui m'ont permis de
surmonter les obstacles et ça ça vaut
tous les encouragements il ya une chose
ailleurs qui est en fin de compte on
compte au lit votre livre peu quand on
regarde ce que vous avez fait ici
parliez tout à l'heure d'idéologie en
disant moi j'étais pas un idéologue ce
qui est frappant c'est justement votre
empirisme se dire que vous regardez pas
les gens parce qu'ils viennent disent
ils viennent de là vous regardez leur
situation moi j'ai une formation gestion
et puis des tendances à la psi je suis
très fin instinctivement je suis très
porté sur la psychologie j'ai eu des
formations dans ce domaine aussi mais je
parle du principe que on ne sait pas
quelle est la réponse tous les tous les
rapports des différentes inspections
générales de l'administration qui a été
lancée sur chanteloup disait cette ville
elle est ingérable et il faudra au moins
25 ans pour ce que ça en sortent et ses
patients
donc à partir de là vous savez que les
réponses traditionnelles ne vont pas
fonctionné
j'avais une force qui étaient liées au
terrain donc j'ai utilisé à fond cette
richesse de la population alors j'avais
des projets sans arrêt des fois il y en
a qu'on capoter mais je veux dire il
faut laisser l'initiative aux gens le
vrai partenariat la vraie
co-construction c'est pas
un truc très structuré il faut laisser
l'imagination au pouvoir et il faut
accompagner les différents projets des
populations on en a eu des projets mamy
blue babilou enfin chantelauze est enfin
c'est parti dans tous les sens
c'était le bazar de l'hôtel de ville
comme lille mais ça fonctionne et ça
fonctionne parce qu'il y avait de
l'émulation donc les gens étaient
motivés des projets dont il y avait un
projet collectif où il y avait ce
sentiment d'appartenance à une
communauté qui déchantent où il sentait
pas tous français sentait pas tous pour
être bu qu'un sentaient peut-être pas
tous sais pas quoi il s'était
chantelouve et un point d'ailleurs que
les bagarres entre les villes j'étais un
peu emmerdé je me disais j'ai
développé un peu trop l'esprit de
clocher sont en train de se sur
la figure pour défendre le territoire
mais bon voilà c'est c'est cette force
de terrain je pense qu'aujourd'hui et je
regrette un peu la façon dont la société
s'est structuré depuis quelques années
avec de très grosses intercommunalités
en reléguant un peu le maire au second
plan alors que le maire est un maillon
essentiel pour le fonctionnement humain
de cette société on a besoin d'humanité
qui mieux que le maire peut le faire et
moi je n'ai jamais considéré que le
maire chef de la police municipale bien
armés c'est le rôle qui doit tenir non
moi c'est le principal acteur le seul
qui peut maintenir le dialogue et quelle
que soit la situation c'est son devoir
et c'est ça sa noble mission il va
falloir qu'on y revienne un jour sinon
ça va aller très mal dans notre société
parce qu'on va avoir des antagonismes
ceux des grandes villes qui nous
expliquent qu'ils sont très contents
d'avoir une police municipale armée pour
moi en france il doit y avoir une police
nationale avec le maire qui a un pouvoir
de coordination des différents acteurs
sur le terrain c'est comme ça que ça
devrait fonctionner non pas
l'organisation un peu hirsute qu'on
observait de vie si le maire a
l'impression que c'est lui qui se fait
engueuler mais c'est pas lui quel
pouvoir ça ça va pas donc je pour moi le
maître lemaire chef d'orchestre n'est
pas patron de tout le monde mais qui
essaye de mettre les gens en relation
parce que vous avez beaucoup de gens sur
le terrain à chanteloup qui connaissent
pas les autres acteurs le policier ne
sais pas ce que fait l'éducateur
l'enseignant ne sais pas quel des
éducateurs spécialisés la pjj n'informe
pas les gens des mesures qu'elle prend
et donc à un moment donné faut une
coordination et si lui c'est le maire
qui est le mieux placé au milieu de tous
ces acteurs qui a une connaissance
multiples des choses et j'ai eu cette
chance de pouvoir jouer ce rôle et
heureusement d'ailleurs par rapport à ce
que mon voisin me chambrent un peu sur
l'urbanisme parce que j y crois pas mais
je trouve c'est trop facile de
responsabiliser je comprends louis de
dial a juste fait un rôle à jouer la
juve quand on a réhabilité changer
l'image avec ce qui se fait aujourd'hui
aussi mais heureusement que j'ai confié
catherine arnoux mais revenons à
l'actuel même
mois l'urbanisme j'avais pas une opinion
très positive et donc heureusement que
c'est elle qui a pris en main et parce
qu'on a détruit 10 le band à
reconstruire mais vous savez très bien
que quand même le le le
l'environnement un envoi énorme dans la
psychologie des gens vous avez tant la
non leur manière d'évoluer ce n'est
qu'en dorlot m'a données
gps quoi c'est un projet de vie
j'ai les moyens de faire un truc énorme
pour chanteloup et en fait j'y crois pas
trop à l'urbanisme donc comment je vais
faire donc j'ai cherché la ligne rouge
qu'est-ce qu'elle file j'allais le fil
rouge que j'allais sur et c'était
l'aération de la cité parce que là il y
avait un enjeu on s'est basé là dessus
et puis bon heureusement qu'à d'autres
gens il n'ya pas que moi qui décide en
mairie je pense qu'elle a les adjoints
heureusement qu'ils jouent et à l'époque
on a à la fois misé sur cette
revalorisation de l'habitat qui
revaloriser l'image que les invités de
avait de même et qui à revaloriser
l'image de chantoux vis-à-vis des
communes autour ce qui a permis
l'intercommunalité que sinon le petit
mouton noir ne serait jamais mariée avec
personne et puis il ya tout ce qu'a fait
borloo en créant la réussite éducative
etc où on a appuyé à fond là dessus on a
créé des structures pour permettre aux
gamins d'avoir ses repères dont ils
avaient besoin pour se comporter un peu
mieux dans cette île et puis de l'espoir
voilà et l'humain c'est important parce
que si on ne reste pas c'est là dessus
que vous avez beaucoup beaucoup de jouer
j'ai l'impression que quand on vous et
c'est
parce que sinon comme disait one ils
vont détruire leur environnement si leur
plaît pas un don quand cela vous avez
raison mais moi quand on dit et
architectes
et l'humain hocine qui sont responsables
et ou non c'est trop facile pour les
politiques de se dégager de sa vie du
chinon ron un bon bah c'est le ciment
zilina tout vous vous disiez à un moment
je passais plus de temps enterré des
potes qui étaient morts d'accidents de
voiture d'ouvrir 12 que de codalet des
fêtes de mariage ya eu un moment quand
même un peu dû aux années de sorties
vous grâce à la musique notamment
il ya eu un moment des moments durs
quand même alors il ya eu des moments
qui était en écho avec ce qui se passe
est un petit peu partout dans ces grands
ensembles c'est à dire que il ya une
génération qui s'est retrouvé un peu
c'est ce que disait pierre
pas face à face à la réalité et personne
n'était préparé c'est à dire que quand
vous avez des populations qui viennent
des quatre coins du monde le rapport à
la drogue le rapport au chômage ce sont
des notions qui sont nouvelles ce que
quand on vient du fin fond du kurdistan
ou du de la casamance ou convient de de
la ruralité d'outre-mer ou ou du vietnam
du cambodge enfin toutes ces populations
c'était des populations qui n'avait pas
pour habitude de gérer ce type de
problème puisque bas au pays on vit
autrement au pays.le la famille le
village surveille les petits là on était
totalement libre oui les enfants
totalement c'était moi les souvenirs que
j'en ai ren tant qu'enfant bien
évidemment en plus on est dans une
période historique de transition c'est
un sentiment de liberté totale qui
venait bien évidemment de de la
construction parler du sud 2 de
l'environnement la ville la façon dont
elles étaient construits et du nombre
d'enfants si le rapport enfants adultes
c'est à dire qu'il y avait un rapport de
jean marie petitclerc je crois qu'il
disait qu' il y avait à peu près 7 à
8000 enfants de moins de 10 ans quelque
chose comme ça enfin y avait une
quantité de gamin donc pour moi je
voyais dans mon quotidien je ne voyais
que des enfants j'étais très rarement
contact avec des adultes puisqu'il
partait le matin bossé est rentré le
soin et on avait cette ville pour nous
la ville nous appartient d'apporter la
journée donc oui c'est vrai que arrivé
au milieu des années 80 donc on a une
période quand même qui est impactée un
petit peu tous les grands ensembles qui
était la période de la drogue dure plus
l'émergence comme ça de de cette 1ère
pandémie pour ma génération qui était le
sida plus la double peine ce qu'on
appelle la double peine chez nous c'est
à dire que battu fait deux trois bêtises
en bloc au pays ce qui fait qu'à chaque
rentrée scolaire bail avait il manquait
un pote pas ce qui est le père pendant
les vacances avaient pris le passeport
et avait pris l'avion parce qu'il
faisait trop de bêtises ici elle avait
confié à des oncles ou parce qu'on
arrivait 1 h 14 ans où je fais de la
moto sans casque ont fait un petit tour
de bagnols donc voila c'était une
période assez accident accidentogènes
mais pour autant avec le recul je dirais
que on pensait que c'était normal oui
pensais que c'était normal tout ça on
pensait que ça faisait partie de la vie
on se rendait pas vraiment compte que ce
nom c'est pas normal aujourd'hui on peut
se peut le dire mais faty meziane michel
hôte michelle voilà il ya toute une
liste d'ailleurs le cimetière ne le
rappelle régulièrement à ses bons
souvenirs il ya toute une liste alors il
était un peu plus âgés que moi il avait
trois quatre ans de plus que moi mais on
l'a appuyé en entendez sans murs on
entend déjà à poissy on attendait ça
invente donc ce n'était pas quelque
chose qui était propre à un socle
chanteloup c'était générationnel on a
pris conscience d'ailleurs il suffit de
voir les images d'archivés qui à un
moment
on est un peu à 8 10 ans être livré à
soi-même il ya un sentiment de liberté
entre 14 et 18 il ya le monde de
langoiran qui nous tend pas la main faut
aller à l'armée aussi cette question là
enfin bref on a été impacté très
rapidement par des questions un petit
peu trop sérieuse pour nous qu'on
n'était pas à même de pouvoir
résoudre voire même comprendre et là
justement vous avez souligné quelque
chose thaler vous parliez de de cet
environnement que dans lequel vous vivez
on
par les lags la question de l'image des
quartiers et quand on vient de
chanteloup et quand on évolue dans
d'autres environnements est ce que c'est
une image qui nous colle à la peau ou
pas
je te dirais que c'est à double
tranchant c'est à dire ça dépend où on
se place si c'est une rivalité entre
villes de chanteloup ça sert
ah oui parce que ça dépend du degré d'
analyse mme anne-marie
environnement a trouvé du boulot dans
notre environnement proche c'était
compliqué puisque les deux perspectives
d'avenir c'était peugeot à poissy où
renault à flins aux mureaux donc dans
notre esprit même il ya un truc qui moi
me
m'interpelle c'est que même la question
de l'emploi on ne se la posait pas
qu'est ce qu'on va devenir parce que le
système éducatif de l'époque l'école ben
il y avait un petit fascicule avec tous
les métiers proposés et puis de la page
4 à la page 6 c'était ce qu'on nous
propose et fallait pas aller au-delà
donc
architectes médecins etc ça c'était
vraiment les plus opiniâtres et ceux qui
avaient un environnement familial ont
leur jay tiens tu pourrais faire
sciences po les mains moi j'ai découvert
ces mots là j'avais 20 ans ouais donc un
peu tard c'est un peu tard donc c'est
vrai que être de chanteloup certaine
fierté parce que pierre avait tout fait
pour justement qu'ils soient fiers de
notre île oui mais quand on est
d'ailleurs quand tu vois là mais quand
on arrive ailleurs alors il ya des
subterfuges gens ont dit que on vient
d'andrésy ans vient de poids si on vient
de triel on vient des rares étaient ceux
qui passaient d'un monde à un autre on
étaient quelques-uns et par contre
chanteloup permettait une chose c'est
que très rapidement quant à lier tu
savais qu'il fallait être capable de
parler toutes les langues être capable
d'analyser les très très rapidement
parce qu'on passait régulièrement en
quelques minutes de cars ou en deux
stations et de m'aider terrain on passer
d'un monde à un autre donc on avait
cette capacité
certains d'entre nous voilà
l'adaptabilité c'est l'application à
champions cet avantage des quartiers
absolument lass est capable on connaît
les autres chez les autres ne nous
connaissent pas alors est d'après vous
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait justement faire
pour que pour changer cette image et
cette perception que les autres peuvent
avoir justement des gens qui viennent de
ces environnements
très sincèrement je pense que ce sont
des des combats perdus d'avancé dans le
sens où ça prend énormément d'énergie et
ça génère le tout ce qu'il faut
c'est la perception que j'ai il faut
faire les choses il faut que l'on parle
de ce qui se fait et donnons pas de qui
les filets fait irruption il faut qu'on
parle de arrêté de douala d'où venaient
seulement je suis parti dernièrement ce
n'est pas réduit à ce à quoi exactement
j'étais en seine-saint-denis j'habitais
un porte de pantin et un jour je vais
aux impôts et je vois les tâches
d'en-dessous crèche baby loup
et je me suis dit voilà c'est un ces
championnats ça c'est la crèche baby
loup de chanteloup à la avoir réussi
comme ça à travers un laboratoire social
des expérimentations parce que ben
pierre tu t'es souvent casser la gueule
et puis tu as souvent réussi on ne se
souvient que les réussites toujours
relevé volé il ya un élément sur lequel
je voudrais revenir qui est très
important c'est ce dynamisme entre la
population et les élus parce qu a pas
d'enjeux de pouvoir un champ clos
donc quand les élus alors il ya toujours
une petite minorité évidemment qu'ils
voient les choses à travers des lunettes
pas très valeureux valorisante mais le
fait qu'un élu fasse partie de la
population ouais et que la population
ait son mot à dire ça change tout ça
change tout c'est à dire qu'il ya plus
dangereuse c'est ce qu'avait bien
regardez là on relève le maire quand il
tombe et quand tu tombes le maire relève
parce que c'est la même bande ce que
vous parliez de baby loup c'est vrai que
c'est devenu la crèche baby loup c'est
devenu une star regardez tout le monde
on va regarder un extrait cité d'ango
religieuse à temps un extrait de
l'émission de drucker même drucker et
quelqu'un d'autre on parle cette crèche
chapelle la crèche baby loup c'est une
crèche modèle c'est une crèche
associative pas une crèche publique
c'est une crèche pas comme les autres
celle est ouverte sept jours sur sept 24
ans nuit et jour
et cette tâche est dévolue par pierre
cardo député maire de gentioux jean paul
devine qui possèdent cette foi en lui
elle vous adore 1
j'ai découvert ça à ce moment là oui
mais non en fait il veut d'abord anne
aymone giscard d'estaing que vous adorez
oui parce que je me suis occupé de
privations j'ai envoyé jusqu'à 250
enfants vous été formulée parce qu'il
veut des enfants qui voulez vous pouvez
nous envoyer des enfants un peu plus
canal
est formidable pierre cardo il est il
une député iba michel rocard il arrive à
l'assemblée il dit quoi le premier truc
et hautbois peut-être baissé nos
traitements qu'ils ont regardé
c'est ce que j'ai fait en arrivant à la
mairie quand je serai pas d'argent mais
vous êtes commence par nous parce que
sinon on va se faire tuer c'est il faut
savoir que si on le chef c'est lui qui
est devant mais qui montrent l'exemple
c'est pas celui qui est derrière est
donc si vous montrez l'exemple ça passe
mieux que si vous expliquer aux autres
ce qu'ils doivent faire les devoirs
c'est pour vous les droits c'est pour ça
va pas pourquoi vous n'avez pas pourquoi
vous n'avez pas voulu aller plus loin
plus loin que quoi honni au niveau
national au niveau politique m'engage à
ce que moi j'ai pas fait porte lorsque
qu on la première fois qu'on s'est
rencontrés c'est lorsque je co présidait
la commission quartiers populaires pour
la fondation terra nova à l'époque et on
a été impressionnés mais impressionné et
d'ailleurs
j'étais ravi que vous soyez venu parce
que ça faisait quelques temps je me
battais avec jacques donzelot pour lui
faire comprendre ce qui se passe
réellement sur le kart sur le terrain et
je me suis dit on a besoin de personnes
comme ça pour pour pour aller plus loin
en politique ça soit ministrable premier
ministrable et voire même présent la
république pourquoi vous n'avez pas
voulu plus vous vous engagez en fait je
n'aime pas les partis politiques j'ai
toujours eu du mal à me faire je n'ai
jamais trop fréquenter les instances
même si j'en ai été souvent très proches
je pense que je ne suis pas fait pour ça
ou alors
enfin ça aurait tellement décoiffé je
suis pas sûr que j'ai
l'énergie soit peut fermer sa gueule
je pense que si on m'avait j'ai pensé
oui du temps simone veil penser
effectivement il faut que voilà si
balladur avait gagné j'étais ministre et
puis après coup je me suis dit mais
finalement est ce que réellement
je peux tenir longtemps dans un
gouvernement non parce que je ne
pourrais pas fermer ma gueule à un
moment donné je vais pas être d'accord
et je vais le dire donc je vais faire
trois mois et puis je vais me faire
virer où je vais démissionner donc si
c'est pour faire ça c'est pas la peine
j'ai eu beaucoup de discussions avec des
collègues de ma famille politique ou
autre qui avait été ministre ou qui
était ministre ce qu'on leur impose ça
ne
valait pas avec moi à un moment donné je
vais sortir une grosse connerie parce
que je pense que j'ai raison et et j'ai
tort de le faire en tant que ministre
mais ça ferme sa gueule comme disait
chevènement
ou sa détention ça démissionne parce que
j'aurais eu de très bonnes idées parce
que ce les méthodes que je j'ai utilisé
à chanteloup pour essayer de réussir ce
pari qu'il y avait je suis pas persuadé
qu'au niveau national
je préférais donner des conseils à des
gens qui ont envie de mettre en place
des politiques de la ville et les
conseiller sur ce qu'il faut faire ou
pas faire les accompagner essayer de
faire en sorte que que les gens
comprennent un peu c'est quoi l'esprit
l'a prédit la ville mais être ministre
non quand je vois la façon dont les
débats zappé attention à la sambre et
comment les ministres perdent leur temps
à des débats sempiternel selon les
procédures je me dis non mais j'ai pas
que ça à faire quoi gcc épouvantable
d'être ministre un mot pour terminer
parce que élèves locaux ce qui devait
l'être mais quand vous regardez
chanteloup aujourd'hui vous revenez
pour vous reconnaissez chanteloup
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire encore
quoi
sabouk changer quand même il n'y a
qu'une chose qu'il faut faire c'est il
faut toujours qu'il se passe quelque
chose sur un quartier c'est quand il ne
se passe rien que ça devient très
dangereux donc il faut de la vie il faut
des animations faut que les gens
s'amusent c'est beaucoup plus important
qu'on ne le pense bien sûr il faut des
réussites dans le domaine de l'
architecture du développement économique
mais il faut le lien social il faut que
les gens s'aiment entre eux il faut
qu'ils apprennent à vivre ensemble à
vivre des événements semble donc ça
passe par des petites choses et le café
que j'ai pris ce matin avec les dames du
centre social avec les équipes etc mais
ce sont des moments importants ces
moments de convivialité mais on
n'imagine pas à quel point c'est
essentiel dans une société qui sait
déshumanisé comment est ce que vous
pouvez penser vous appartenez à ce pays
et à cette république et la respecter si
vous avez l'impression d'être mis à
l'écart parce que les services publics
sont plus là thibault ici on en a
maintenu catherine s'est battu pour
avoir un certain nombre de choses mais
c'est vrai que ça c'est déshumanisé avec
en plus la fracture numérique mais vous
imaginez isolement des gens c'est
épouvantable le maire en plus il ya de
moins en moins de pouvoir sur le
territoire donc que l'on s'adresse à lui
mais c'est pas lui qui peut régler le
problème ça fait beaucoup de choses et
donc
le il faut continuer à faire des choses
il faut surprendre il faut pas hésiter à
prendre des risques et le problème du
politique aujourd'hui et notamment à un
haut niveau c'est que la bête politique
c'est une bête frileuse mais qui peut
être dangereuse aussi donc mais elle est
d'abord frileuse elle un plat prendre
des risques est par contre si on se pose
à elle et que ça se passe pas bien
elle peut être méchante donc faut le
savoir et la politique c'est un combat
permanent combat pour les autres et
qu'on bat aussi pour sa survie
juan un mot et surtout quand vous
revenez comme ça bah
concernant chanthu c'est un petit peu la
règle
comtois on devrais je ne sais pas en
tout cas je ne sais pas ce qu'il faut
faire mais je sais ce qu'il ne faut pas
fini et ce qu'il ne faut pas faire c'est
en tout cas ce qu'il faut éviter c'est
d'arriver à une conclusion très simple
on est nombreux mais seul
l'un vit dualisme l'individualisme est
ce qui a tenu cette ville justement
c'est le fait que les pillards cardo et
toute son équipe et le tissu associatif
est passé son temps à faire en sorte que
les les traits d'union entre les
communautés les traits d'union entre les
générations
soit possible et visible c'est à dire il
ya eu il ya le le bien faire et bien
bien montré et ici ce qui nous a un
moment sauver c'est ce sentiment que
quelles que soient nos origines quelles
que soient nos communautés nos
générations on était chantelouve et et
ça nous a sauvé parce que dans un pays
où être français c'est très compliqué
c'est très dur d'être français gens
disent oui il faut s'intégrer mais ça ne
dépend pas uniquement de vous ça dépend
aussi de votre de l'environnement de ce
qui vous regarde et en moins
si on avait du mal à avoir ce sentiment
d'être français à part entière on savait
qu'on était chantelouve est à 200% et ça
ça nous a ça a permis de combler un vide
seulement voilà merci infiniment
merci à
vous merci merci merci pour ce moment
comme dirait le
essentiel évidemment c'est l'éducation
c'est absolument le fondement de tout
vrai qu'avec les sites éducative l'ailé
les expériences qui sourit des choses
absolument formidable qu'il faut que des
écolos rabais qu'on a ici
très bien enfin on a perdu quand même de
nombreuses années au niveau national
pour en arriver à défendre ce principe
de cité éducative c'est lourd c'est des
principes à une époque voilà on en
parlait déjà il ya 25 ans il aura fallu
tout ce temps là pour commencer à
arriver à mettre en place le processus
merci école ne peut quasi seul et regret
pas de l'éducation elle toute seule
c'est sûr qu'ils le confier une mission
précise merci beaucoup merci merci ce
bien
[Musique]
recette on va parler d'éducation de
formation c'est vrai est très très
importante saisie d'une question c'est
la base alors on va parler de la cité
éducative avec qu'était la bouille et
puis on va parler des hubs de la
réussite avec vous benjamin skoun alors
yahia vos organisations qui se préoccupe
de cette formation payé aussi des
associations qui font un travail
formidable je pense en particulier une
association qui s'appelle la la fraise
fraternité pour l'égalité des chances
créé à mina satouri amina satory elle
est mère de trois enfants qu'elle
élevait seule l ebit dans ce quartier
quel quartier de delanoë et elle a créé
une association qui regroupe aujourd'hui
plus de 70 enfants alors il ya plusieurs
activités évidemment le soutien scolaire
et mais aussi le sport et la voilà une
idée formidable c'est que de dire mais
il peut faire du sport mais peuvent
faire d'autres sports que ce qu'on leur
propose d'habitude c'est aller faire du
golfe allaient faire du cheval et c'est
ce qu'elle a lancé c'est cette
formidable petite association qui
s'appelle l'afrique d'amina satory on
était voir comment se passe ça se
passait avec justement deux jeunes
golfeurs
green caddie club ces mots n'ont plus de
secrets pour daoud et mohamed une fois
par semaine depuis plus de trois ans ces
deux garçons de 16 ans se rendent au
club de golf de villennes sur seine pour
apprendre la discipline j'adore golfe
surtout le practice et
toute la semaine j'y pense quand j'en
fais encore j'en fais pas comme tu tape
la balle au practice ça détend coaching
proche de là où tu crois tu vois la
balle partir loin après même le jeu sur
le parcours ça me plaît
ah oui elle est belle celle là
130 cent vingt 120 les sports qui sont
connus sur le quartier on va pas se
mentir c'est plus voilà le
foot la boxe tout au début c'était très
très difficile de le faire accepter sur
le quartier parce qu'ils n'étaient pas
connus et inconnus c'est plus pour les
pour les gens aisés pour les gens qui
sont en lice une chance qui leur a été
donné par l'association freq qui allie
sport et aide à la scolarité elle est
accompagnée par la fondation winehouse
qui permet aux enfants défavorisés de
pouvoir accéder à des activités
extrascolaires ça coûte cher et après
moi vu qu'on ait beaucoup chez moi on
n'aurait pas à ma mère elle aurait pu
payer faire un sport pour moi cher et
des sports pour les autres os mais
comment avais pas du golfe comme ça et
monde y est ce un sport cher magie mais
j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir un mine a du coup que grâce à
cette occasion j'ai pu en faire des
séances veut je serai pas là et je tiens
à les en remercier venir aussi jouer au
golf 6 aussi
l'accompagnement à ce sport
être respectueux travail et la rigueur
dont tu as well
as an
parce que corps je la sens pas la balle
c'est un kiff c'est trop bien
on le voit avec ce nouveau gène
maintenant les golfeurs qu'on a c'est de
ne pas leur fermer les portes qu'il faut
qu'ils essayent ce sport et qui soit
ouverte pour eux c'est vrai que sans la
formation les parents ne pourront pas
payer la totalité de ce sport avec comme
exemple les célèbres bobby jones tiger
woods ou encore qu'albert tchaï daoud et
mohamed ne compte pas s'arrêter là
j'avais des trop pro et si possible au
dessus c'est d'aller le plus loin
possible peut-être devenir on un jour
c'est une fierté d'avoir deux
d'avoir mettre des jeunes qui sont là
depuis trois ans et demi dans le golfe
et il les accompagne et si une fierté
porno une quinzaine d'enfants sont aidés
par l'association sur la discipline du
golfe l'association ferait qu envisage
d'organiser plus de court par la suite
pour que les enfants puissent passer
leurs drapeaux équivalent du flocon pour
le ski et participer à des compétitions
dans les yvelines donc on va parler de
d'éducation de formation cathy la
bouille vous êtes la chef de projet de
la cité éducative alors là on est à
l'espace borloo dans la cité de la noé
hills elle sera dans quelques temps tout
près d'ici dans une école alors l'alcool
oui la cité ducati simone veil sera
implanté effectivement dans loin d'ici à
là en lieu et place actuellement de
l'école dans genèse l'espace victor hugo
avec aussi le collège casas en partie
rénové et benjamin lecomte bonjour
bonjour vous êtes conseiller régional
d'île de france et vous êtes le
président des meubles de la réussite
faudra qu'on précise que célèbre de la
réussite c'est un peu un nom générique
qui regroupe à la fois l'école de la
deuxième chance et aussi ce qu'on
appelle les smart universités ce qui
nous permet de te faire venir les
enseignements de l'université ici plus
d'eau que les étudiants d'état se
déplacer quand ya pas de vivacité un
côté de leur vie aux habitants c'est ça
c'est ça on fait qu'on club de réussite
c'est un écosystème autour de plusieurs
métiers et dans cet écosystème il ya
plusieurs dispositifs dont des écoles
deuxième chance donc dans les yvelines
en seine et marne dans le val d'oise
et des partenaires cités se sont
détériorées en supérieur ont fait venir
l'université dans le territoire et nous
on part d'un principe c'est que dans nos
territoires soir dans les quartiers prix
hauteurs de la ville sur la ruralité ya
les talents qui s'ignorent qui sont
passés au travers du système éducatif
parce que pour plein de raisons
de parcours de vie qui n'ont pas trouvé
leur voie et nous notre métier en fin de
compte c'est de faire éclore et clore
ses talents et ses sacs ça qui c'est le
métier dur de la réussite et on entend
adresser c'est la preuve qu'il y a des
talents dans un quartier des beaux c'est
une richesse bien plus sérieuse sur six
bandits qui sont dans les quartiers
c'est nos ressources humaines qui pour
le pays sont mal exploitées si on peut
utiliser ce terme là et qui serait une
qui sont une richesse formidable pour
notre nation alors on va parler de de la
cité éducative on est allé vous voir
arriver une réunion avec lui il ya eu
qui est la déléguée du préfet karine
bouchard akela mon principal du collège
rené cassin c'était un matin vous étiez
là on regarde et puis on en reparle tout
de suite après
dispositif lancé en juillet 2018 les
sites et éducatives ont pour objectif
d'intensifier la prise en charge des
enfants de leur naissance à leurs 25 ans
situé dans le nord des yvelines
chanteloup-les-vignes fait partie des 80
ville lauréate du label cité éducative
décernée par l'état le but suivre les
jeunes chantelouve et et chante l'ouvèze
à travers tout leur parcours scolaire
mais aussi les ouvrir aux nombreuses
opportunités qui s'offrent à eux et pour
mettre en place ce projet trois co
pilote lydia hugues délégué du préfet en
charge de la ville de chanteloup les
vignes pour représenter l'état
ça va apporter aussi aux acteurs de ce
territoire une façon différente de
travailler
karine bouchard un principal du collège
rené cassin à chanteloup les vignes pour
représenter l'éducation nationale nous
confrontons les solutions que nous
avions déjà et nous les enrichissent
rond et qu'at-il à mouiller adjointe en
charge de la jeunesse et de l'éducation
à la mairie de chanteloup les vignes
pour représenter la ville tout le monde
est impliqué dans cette dynamique
éducative
ses trois co pilote ont pour objectif
commun de créer des conditions
éducatives optimale pour les jeunes
chantelouve et pourrait parvenir elle
doit faire travailler ensemble tous les
acteurs qui participent à l'éducation et
l'épanouissement de l'enfant l'idée
c'est de réunir tous les acteurs que ce
soit la ville l'éducation nationale les
associations les parents pour faire
alliance autour d'un projet pour les
enfants et les jeunes d'un territoire
c'est l'esprit même de la cité éducative
le fait de rassembler autour de l'enfant
les différents acteurs sur les
différents temps de l'enfant et avec une
cohérence et la même volonté de faire
réussir la cité éducative bénéficie
principalement aux habitants du quartier
de la noé qui représente plus de la
moitié de la population de
chanteloup-les-vignes ce quartier
connaît un taux de pauvreté de 37% ces
deux fois supérieur à la moyenne
nationale et seulement 57% des 16 25 ans
sont scolarisés
la plupart des disciplines font appel à
la lecture et on voit à quel point c'est
un frein parce que c'est quelque chose
qu'on travaille en collaboration avec le
premier degré et sur le second degré et
on voit que ces sources
vraiment de décrochage de
voilà d'un certain nombre d'élèves parce
que l'accès à la lecture et à la langue
française beaucoup de nos élèves ne
parlent pas forcément le français
à la maison pour faire face à ces
difficultés la cité éducative a permis
de créer des postes inédits comme celui
de référence suivi parcours lycéens pour
accompagner les jeunes de chanteloup
après le collège on n'a pas de blessés à
chanteloup les vignes mais elle a repéré
27 lycées différents sur lesquels soit
répartie nos jeunes une fois au lycée
donc c'est quand même assez important
avec des risques de décrochage scolaire
est donc là tout le travail tout savoir
faire de notre professionnel c'est
précisément d'accompagner les enfants
les jeunes sur les difficultés ce projet
de cité éducative s'inscrit également
dans un plan local d'urbanisation c'est
complémentaire avec un gros projet de
rénovation urbaine qui va s'appeler la
cité simone veil en coeur de quartier
cette nouvelle cité verra le jour en
2024 2025 et sera entièrement dévoué à
l'éducation et à la culture
elle comprendra notamment la démolition
et la rénovation d'une école maternelle
primaire mais aussi d'un collège on va
déjà avoir effectivement la destruction
de l'école dorgelès les enfants de
l'école dorgelès vont être accueillis
dans une cité qui est en train de se
construire la cité champeau qui a un
accueil temporaire pour les élèves du
premier degré le projet prévoit aussi la
construction d'une médiathèque et d'une
ludothèque l'intérêt d'une médiathèque
lui les deux textes c'est vraiment la
possibilité pour les jeunes du
territoire d'avoir accès aux livres à la
culture cinématographique
voilà aux jeux de société bien entendu
et ce qui est intéressant dans ce type
de structure c'est le côté familial ce
nouveau quartier devrait également
accueillir une maison des parents un
espace multimédia et plusieurs pôles
santé formation ambition réussite
citoyenneté pour réussir à coordonner
tout ça les trois co pilote et les
acteurs du territoire se réunissent pour
travailler autour de quatre axes la cité
une ducati elle s'articule autour de
quatre axes un axe sur la parentalité un
axe sur le bien-être la santé un axe sur
la communication le langage l'accès au
numérique et puis un dernier axe sur
réussir réussir s'ouvrir au monde donc
les actions elles sont réparties par axe
l'idée c'est de les découvrir il y en a
beaucoup qui sont renouvelés par rapport
à l'année dernière chacune des
propositions et retranscrite sur une
fiche détaillée en fonction de
l'objectif visé du public visé des
résultats attendus et du budget alloué
puisqu'il sera capitalisé sur ses fiches
d'actions la cité éducative de
chanteloup comprend 28 porteurs
d'actions il s'agit d'associations de
parents d'institutions qui souhaitent
apporter leurs idées hélas ce matin on
est en comité technique avec différents
interlocuteur pour
étudier les différentes demandes voir si
ça correspond aux critères
échanger les uns et les autres sur des
réorientations
des points forts mais encore à
travailler la transversalité du
partenariat construit voilà pour ses
tubes job c'est d'abord une réunion de
pré arbitrage on va dire pour construire
la programmation 2022 de la cité du cac
tiré au total le budget de la cité
éducative représente un peu plus d'un
million d'euros répartis sur trois ans
les financements seront assurés jusqu'en
la cites éducative et justement aînés du
plan borloo
la première a été
expérimentée à grigny justement est la
particularité de chant tout c'est quand
même
le projet urbain au service du sud du
projet éducatif en fait c'est le projet
éducatif qui préfigure le projet urbain
qui lui même est au service de la
réussite du projet éducatif
ce qui commence ce sont les acteurs
éducatifs
de la ville est en fête oui la ville
travaille depuis 2016 un projet de
rénovation urbaine en coeur de quartier
qui regroupe une école un accueil de
loisirs et pour l'ado et un collège avec
l'idée de reconstruire et de créer
l'école de demain avec une ambition
autour de la continuité éducative de la
coopération entre les acteurs éducatifs
travailler sur les atouts aussi des
élèves qui sont les langues les arts la
culture travailler sur le numérique et
l'inclusion numérique et faire une cité
rayonnante c'est à dire ouverte sur le
quartier ont il s'agit pas de construire
une école avec quatre murs et un toit
mais vraiment l'école de demain avec des
fonctions nouvelles comme une
bibliothèque ludothèque une maison des
familles un pôle santé un espace
multimédia etc c'est à dire des
fonctions qui seront tous sur le même
établissement dans en fait c'est un peu
conçu comme un campus
éducatif
c'est à dire qu'il est prévu que ça
puisse ouvrir en dehors du temps
scolaire sur le quartier les autres
écoles les autres les autres les deux
collèges mais aussi sur les habitants
hors temps scolaire pour que ça puisse
être accessible à tous et que ce soient
des lieux ressources
culturels éducatifs
de loisirs numériques et s'est ouvert à
l'ensemble de la ville la conception ça
a été fait en unissant tout le monde
alors oui on a travaillé dès le début
c'était vraiment une volonté très forte
de notre maire de travailler avec
l'ensemble des acteurs éducatifs sur une
concertation donc on a co construit un
projet éducatif avec des grands
principes comme la coopération entre les
acteurs le bien-être de tous avec des
espaces verts est une cité rayonnante de
l'adaptabilité donc avec la conception
de bâtiments
modulables et adaptables et puis aussi
l'ouverture sur le monde l'ouverture sur
l'extérieur pas seulement le reste de la
ville mais aussi
le monde c'est une manière en fait d'eux
des sanctuary zélés l'école au fait
alors que beaucoup de monde depuis très
longtemps alors oui on c'est une
conception de nouvelles de l'éducation
en fait on fait éducation ensemble et
grâce à ce projet innovant on a obtenu
la ville de chanteloup a été une des
premières à obtenir le label cité
éducative en septembre 2010 est donc
vous ne ferez que 2010 9,1 sur aussi du
plan borloo issus de tout le travail de
la ville autour de la politique
éducative puisque là c'est quand même
particulier qu'une ville se saisissent à
ce point là d'une politique éducatif
donc c'est une conception nouvelle de
l'éducation dans le sens où ces trois
pilotes saros après sa pause ça se pose
sur la politique éducative de la ville
de l'éducation nationale et de l'état
donc on est trois co pilote comme vous
le disiez d'élus patrice sur cette cité
éducative et on construit
autour de quatre axes sur la parentalité
la coopération le bien-être et le
travail
intercatégorielle on va dire le travail
en coopération
sur la partie langage langues cultures
et numériques mais aussi ouvrir les
jeunes ouvert le champ des possibles
c'est dans les grands objectifs de
l'état sur les sites éducatifs
montrer aux jeunes qu'ils peuvent avoir
de l'ambition leur donner des repères
leur donner un réseau pour qu'ils
puissent aller plus loin dans leur dans
leurs ambitions et puis on est là pour
construire le parcours éducatif des
enfants et des jeunes de 0 à 25 ans
c'est ma mission c'est une expérience
kid qui est né de la propre imagination
de notre propre imagination française où
il ya des exemples à l'étranger qui est
qui ressemble hershey qui ont marché
alors justement la cité éducative c'est
justement la possibilité de faire de
l'innovation éducative et
d'expérimentation donc bien évidemment
on travaille avec l'éducation nationale
les associations s'étaient querellés
le principe des services de la ville les
parents surtout au niveau des acteurs
éducatifs les parents sont essentiels
donc on travaille à des expérimentations
nouvelles on met en place par exemple
des espaces snow hélène sur la gestion
des émotions pour les enfants etc on
travaille sur les neurosciences de
classe qui a très intéressant c'est que
l'éducation nationale elle même et dans
cette ex volonté d'expérimentation est
donc là on construit une culture
éducatif commune chacun ne reste pas sur
sa culture institutionnelle on va dire
est professionnel on construit une
culture commune c'est vraiment un des
enjeux forts de cette cité ducale iv de
ces sites éducatifs fisc y en a quand
même un certain nombre en france a fait
école pour le k s qui a des passerelles
qui sont prévues justement entre les
différentes structures sachant que
aujourd'hui c'est on a quand même la
question de l'enfermement
souvent les gens tout est fait pour que
les gens restent dans leur environnement
et n'en sortent pas et comment à travers
un projet comme ça il pourrait on
pourrait pousser les jeunes justement à
sortir de leur environnement à les voir
autre chose alors justement au lieu de
travailler comme ça en silo les
formations interprofessionnelle déjà
nous apprennent et nous permettent de
travailler tous ensemble les acteurs de
l'éducation on a un axe très fort au
niveau de ma tite éducatif c'est la
réussite
et les parcours éducatif des jeunes de
16 à 25 ans et là on a une charge et
d'éducation enfin changer de parcours
éducatif des lycéens puisqu'on n'a pas
de lycéens chanteloup donc ça a permis
d'étendre le territoire éducatif de la
ville à 27 lycées différents vous rendez
compte sur lesquels seraient partis nos
jeunes de la seconde à la terminale donc
ça nous on a déjà étendu notre
territoire éducatif au delà de la ville
et en plus on donne une vraie
attractivité à ce territoire on
travaille avec l'essec le centre égalité
des chances
avec sur sur une pourquoi pas pour
excellence il ya une grande école
pourquoi pas moi tout un programme et
trouve sa voix aussi sur l'orientation
pour pour donner de l'ambition aux
jeunes leur faire qu'on travaille aussi
sur l'estimé de soi sur l'ouverture
culturelle sur les ans à l'oral enfin
voilà toutes ses dimensions là qui sont
essentiels à la fois dans l'éducation
dans le monde du travail dans la forme
et dans la formation et que ce que
disaient aussi pour le monde du travail
j'ai une question
c'est où vous une révolution dans la
manière de concevoir l'éducation mais
comme le sont les écoles de la deuxième
chose sous les ors de la réussite est-ce
que c'est facile à apporter ce qu'il y a
pas de résistance il ya des gens qui
vous disent on attendait de l'école
c'est fait pour donner un enseignement
qui soit le même partout et et on change
rien quoi quel que soit le lieu il ya
beaucoup on entend beaucoup ça des
enseignants qui peuvent dire le travail
et des parents c'est pas facile ou avec
sk des résistances ou est ce que
finalement balaie les résultats que vous
obtenez finissent par vaincre ces
résistances alors on a vraiment l'appui
au niveau national de l'éducation
nationale qui est des résistances dans
de toutes parts jeunes services de la
ville voilà
là là c'est vraiment l'idée c'est
vraiment de travailler tous ensemble et
on a des équipes qui sont là depuis
longtemps on a très peu de turnover sur
la ville de chanteloup on a des gens
impliqués l'éducation nationale fait
déjà un travail exceptionnel avec en
plus tout le réseau d'éducation
prioritaire a déjà habitué à ce travail
transversal donc en fait on a il faut
avoir un maire qui a une vraie vision
pour sa ville une équipe municipale qui
a une vraie vision et qui s appuie aussi
sur cette même dynamique éducation
nationale est un
réponse alors
dix ans mist peut-être
parce que vous êtes hockey aussi d'une
expérience jeudi une vente si tout était
parfait on n'existerait pas simplement
les jeunes qui viennent dans les écoles
de chant salaces partenaires cités ou ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui avec avid sur le
les cours du soir et le soutien scolaire
ont fait ça aussi parce que le système
d'éducation en soit c'est un système de
masse qui gère la masse et nous on gère
des individus qui ont des parcours de
vie quand ils se défient culte et et on
les gère individuellement c'est la
particularité des dispositifs durable de
la réussite c'est qu'on a des parcours
individualisés
est souvent le premier acte de ce
parcours ce que vous dites est à l'heure
c'est estime de soi c'est à dire tu es
capable 2
pas tu en échec tu appelles ton brevet
tard doublé tuait un décrocheur donc les
aspects négatifs que parfois renvoi
l'éducation nationale parce que si ça me
fait comme ça mais c'est vrai que le
système de masse et que ben
il ya eu l'échec c'est parce que les non
c'est vrai pas de quoi faire contre quoi
faire enfin je laisse partenaires cités
j'allais dire elles se remplissent
grasset à cause d'une sombre de parcours
sup des jeunes qui sont exclues par par
coursier qui a un bts qui a envie de
faire un bts dans les yvelines et dans
la rue alors dit ben non pas possible le
peuple-classe ton dossier pas c'est bon
tu rentreras pas mais qui ont envie de
faire leur bts il arrive chez nous nous
les gros des cohortes arrive après les
voeux ambitions de post bac parce que
ben ils ont pas de choix alors
déjà de trouver de trouver un début de
solution c'est déjà résoudre le problème
c'est dire qu'il ya un problème c'est
pas très grave qui est un problème à
faire rien n'est parfait dans la vie et
je vous rejoins si le up s'est implanté
dans le champ clou c'est que un jour le
maire de chanteloup est venu me voir à
argenteuil pour travailler sur
l'économie change dans les yvelines et
l'implantation à chanteloup et on ne
peut rien faire si apple a volé la
volonté politique d'une commune d'une
agglomération d'un département parce que
c'est tous les acteurs ça négocie
s'achète et aux services un des jeunes
leur pour citer jean louis borloo qui
disait souvent c'est tout un village qui
éduque un enfant
c'est tout le monde qu'il fait tout le
monde à son niveau cette voie qui
devrait en afrique et toute la ville
dont les faire réussir la vie pour le
faire réussir voir je suis un bébé
borloo gg ge devrait à ses côtés pendant
quelques années donc c'est pour ça aussi
que je me suis retrouvé dans l'est dans
ces écoles là et dans ces dispositifs la
met
oui rien n'est parfait cms du défenseur
résout pas tous les problèmes et c'est
pas grave ce qui est grave ce serait de
dire c'est tant pis on laisse dans
l'échec non il ya là j'ai à dire la
bienveillance de la république à trouver
des sites et des systèmes parallèles
pour pouvoir les accompagner c'est ça
qui est important
tout à l'heure vous parlais justement de
là qu'il ya quelque chose qui m'a
remarqué vous parlez de rendre les
enfants aussi auteur de la production de
la connaissance
ça me rappelle d'ailleurs une méthode
montessori et la méthode freinet
est ce que à terme
l'éducation nationale doit sortir
justement de deux de ces règles les
habituels pourra pour arriver à ça
alors on est justement quand on parle
d'expérimentation
éducative c'est vraiment main dans la
main avec l'éducation nationale ronald
d'un groupe thématique par exemple de
réflexion sur le travail personnel de
l'élève avec quatre sous-groupes donc là
c'est complètement intercatégorielle
avec des parents aussi qui sont
impliqués et on a la chance d'avoir des
principal de collège et l'inspectrice
aussi éducation nationale complètement
impliqué dans cette innovation
pédagogique là pour le coup
avec du mobilier innovants on a par
exemple des des collèges équipés en pour
les enfants en euros atypique avec des
tables en hauteur et un vélo voyez un
pédalier pour permettre de décharger
l'énergie
on travaille comme personne et dans le
cadre de la cité
mai à décembre
les enfants cap rémy en marchant par
exemple alors qu'on leur demande de
rester assis donc on est on est on va
prendre vraiment le pari de cette
expérimentation là et dans le cadre du
grand chantier cité simone veil il se
trouve que pendant deux ans le temps du
chantier les classes est déjà commencée
voilà c'est déjà le dans la sillage et
donc la cité champeau c'est un lieu
d'incubateur de projet qui va permettre
dit de lancer des innovations exemple
vous fait des expérimentations
l'expérimentation mais sans pour autant
car faut vraiment aller dans le sens
année dans l'inconnu complet non non ça
c'est ça avec toujours toujours le
respect de principes et puis surtout de
l'enfant et de la rue pour la réussite
de l'enfant un exemple d'expérimentation
par exemple à la demande des parents la
création d'un pédibus réussir à vous
voyez on est vraiment sur un autre champ
que ce bouquet le rôle du baroque au but
quand ils sont dans l'eau ce projet ces
intervenants ils ont alors il serait je
voudrais que mon fils ou ma fille fasse
ça où ils sont plus collectif alors il
il aimerait bien que les enfants
réussissent ils ont peur que ce soit un
dispositif de plus or c'est vraiment une
nouvelle façon de penser l'éducation ils
veulent pas qu'on se serve de leurs
enfants pour faire de l'expérimentation
mode cobayes c'est pas c'est pas ça non
plus donc on les associe complètement et
ils sont très impliqués dans la réussite
de leurs enfants vraiment dans la dans
la après il faut qu'on les conforte
aussi dans leur rôle de parents c'est un
c'est un travail de confiance et qu'ils
comprennent peu différente des
enseignants le droit d'un job qu il
travaille avec le centre social on se
rend compte et donc les pas beaucoup de
parents que des quelques fois ils
n'osent pas poser des questions aux
enseignants parce que ils ont
l'impression que c'est un manque de
confiance or là on les confond alors on
travaille beaucoup avec eux par exemple
on va créer un film
qu'on va traduire en plusieurs langues
sur être enfant à chanteloup de petits
jusqu'à 25 ans qu'elles sont qu'est ce
que ce territoire rapporte associations
services de la ville le département
également
pour pour les parents pour pour les
enfants et donc est traduit en plusieurs
langues donc là on a pris en compte
cette dimension vraiment grande
interculturalité et de moi je pense
comme une richesse de ce territoire
voilà et c'est les habitants eux mêmes
et les professionnels qui vont alors non
pas traduire parce qu'on a un
interprétariat mais qui vont dire qu'ils
vont qui vont ils vont avoir leur voix
enregistrée sur le film donc on a
vraiment une participation active des
parents et en plus l'origine de ce
projet c'est donc on a lancé un appel à
initiatives éducatives tous acteurs de
l'éducation pour que les parents
puissent les parents les jeunes les
professionnels faire proposer des
innovations éducatives qui sont validées
par un jury on a fait ça de façon très
rigoureuse et très sérieuse avec un
grand respect et donc cette ce projet a
été
validé non là on a l'impression d'être
sur une autre planète au fait on n'est
pas sur la planète france non non il a
changé c'est ça justement on est on est
ravi d'être là parce que ça permet de
mettre en lumière tout ça et des belges
initiative et cette idée justement parce
qu'on tente pendant très longtemps on a
reproché aux eaux à l'école d'être fermé
et on a des aussi beaucoup se sont
déchargées sur l'école en disant que
c'était à l'école d'éduquer les enfants
et tout ce travail permet justement
d'associer les parents à l'éducation
alors est ce qu'il faudrait pas d'après
vous faire ce travail que certains
demandent depuis un certain temps c'est
à dire de changer le nom de l'éducation
nationale et de l'appeler désormais
l'instruction nationale
ça s'appelait l'instruction publique
est-ce qu'il faut pas revenir à ça parce
que les cantons vie éducation nationale
les gens pensent que c'est l'éducation
oui alors il faut pas juste arrêté à une
appellation
que ça dessine sur les gens appelant sa
cité éducative
non mais vraiment vraiment on est dans
l'alliance éduqué je vous rejoins
complètement sur comment penser
autrement on est dedans et
les enseignants eux mêmes ont déjà
beaucoup évolué dans leur façon de
concevoir
leur métier et leur rôle
il ya des cafés des parents qui
fleurissent dans les écoles il ya ouvrir
l'école aux parents pour la réussite des
enfants c'est un dispositif éducation
nationale pour permettre aux parents
allophones primoarrivants de mieux
maîtriser le français donc il ya déjà
beaucoup de
d'ouverture et dans les réseaux
d'éducation prioritaire il ya des il ya
des parcours comme le parcours santé le
parcours citoyenneté le parcours il ya
des ya déjà des choses
sa facilité beaucoup le travail et les
missions de l'est qui sont les miennes
mais l'émission l'action de la ville
haut niveau alors je présente un super
idéal parce que c'est oui bien sûr
les difficultés des reçus chez des rats
la mesure du parking mais on y croit un
truc qui change un peu et c'est vrai
aussi pour les hommes de la réussite
c'est à dire que
vous le regardez comment veut mettre fin
dans les quartiers dits de la politique
de la ville généralement les écoles
qu'on avait c'était quand même pas les
meilleurs
d'europe et vous avez aimé mais
mais là on est en train de changer de
perspective parce qu'on a l'impression
que c'est l'excellence qui vient non
dans ces quartiers d'ailleurs eu
d'ailleurs peut-être bien si ça marche
toujours pas pourquoi s'adresserait dans
le quartier de l'ami le 10-city
éducative pourquoi ils n'auraient pas
dans le 16e arrondissement
non mais j'ai dit oui il renvoie
l'arrière
tout à fait à ceci près que comme les
écoles de la deuxième chance non les
écoles chance ça concerne pas que
moi je tairai les noms de mécénat et que
des enfants de rangs patronaux
parlementaires et c'est m'appelle pour
me dire mon enfant à décrocher j'arrive
plus à le remettre dans le système
d'éducation je sais pas ce qu'il veut
faire il sent pas bien à l'école est-ce
qui peut venir chez toi en haut de ces
pour qu'on puisse avoir un parcours
d'insertion avec lui parce que on sent
qu'il veut travailler mais c'est pas où
mais il veut travailler nous avons eu de
la réussite ont fait pas l'insertion
sociale enfin ce sont économiques notre
but c'est d'en parler bourse de l'armée
jeunes puissent s'insérer économiquement
parce que pour nous la réussite enfin
compte aussi par le travail
non je crois qu'on en reparle encore
parlé dans quelques instants non mais
c'est vrai que d'une certaine façon
c'est l'excellence qui inquiet qu'il a
quoi oui oui et oui la longue ovation
d'un retrait dans ya les ouïes la
ressource humaine et ressources humaines
et puis on essaie des choses banales
apolline volonté politique et volonté
politique ça c'est fondamental et et
vous disiez ça pour exister dans le
xvième oui à ceci près que nos jeunes
ici manque quand même de réseaux manque
de perspective si on les accompagne pas
si on leur montre pas ne serait-ce que
la diversité des métiers qui existent
sachant que les métiers de demain
n'existe pas encore donc on construit
aussi avec eux le monde de demain et
donc
on est aussi en train de rééquilibrer
des inégalités de territoire aussi sur
des villes en quartiers de la ville
quand je veux dire ça pour être aussi
parce que par ses expérimentations une
piste pour l'éducation nationale d'une
façon générale
on a déjà rencontré en fin de rencontre
à plusieurs reprises le jazz n donc le
directeur d'académie service éducation
nationale qui est très intéressé par
justement l'expérimentation le fait
qu'on construise pour maintenant l'école
de demain on va dire avec cette
dimension est là on revient sur la
partie cité simone veil dès que
l'évolution des besoins c'est à dire que
pour dans 30 ans
les besoins seront encore évoluer et
donc la conception même en revient au
projet architectural conception même des
débats team débattent du bâtiment c'est
que ce soit en plateau modulable voilà
dans dans cette dimension là
le cabinet d'architectes voilà travaille
dessus et on a avec le cabinet
indivisible qui est un cabinet
assistance à maîtrise d'ouvragé qui nous
a accompagnés dans toute la démarche de
concertation avec les habitants les
parents les professionnels
on a créé un plan des usages voilà plan
des usages des différentes fonctions
voilà et à la face qu on y attend ce
qu'on veut il et puis comme on veut à
travailler ensemble alors pour l'aider
des hubs delà de la réussite auparavant
le disais il ya aussi des associations
qui s'occupent de de ses talents parce
que l'élève de la réussite repose sur
l'idée qu'il ya beaucoup de talent dans
ces quartiers et je propose de voir le
portrait de joan rivers joachim c'est un
stage de garçons qui étaient tellement
émotif que
les des médecins médias c'est à sa mère
il faut lui il faut le mettre dans un
hôpital psychiatrique est rude le met
dans un hôpital psychiatrique
elle a inscrit dans cette compagnie que
vous connaissez bien crédit a moqué la
compagnie des contraires qui a été créée
par noah tomasi une trentaine d'années
qu'est la voix cirque une école de
théâtre et et joachim il est devenu la
vedette d'un film qui était consacrée
cette compagnie des contraire ce film
s'appelle de repères des contraires et
les deux de l'oea rinaldi il était
présenté au festival de cannes l'année
dernière je vous propose de voir le
portrait de joachim est donnée de sa
maman d'ailleurs c'est un portrait signé
bixente meriem santesteban
[Musique]
arrêté
aujourd'hui une passion le théâtre était
au début un échappatoire pour joachim
enfants il avait des difficultés à gérer
ses émotions chalet au théâtre et
vraiment trouvé un truc super quoi de
permettre de
jouer un rôle
d'exprimer des émotions et puis ces
tests elle éclate quoi et puis d'un seul
coup il était valorisé aussi il était
mis en lumière alors que jusqu alors
des instituteurs c'est plus trop comment
faire avec lui quand c'était un enfant
qui était tellement dévoré par ses
émotions qu'il était incapable de
produire quoi que ce soit à l'écrit
c'était des crises de laon sous sa
chaise des fois j'étais obligé de venir
le chercher le calme et à la maison
il y avait toute une prise en charge
aussi par un psychologue si c'était très
compliqué je comprends qu'à l'école
c'était pour les profs aussi très très
compliqué mais c'est ça ça lui a permis
ça le théâtre de pouvoir s'exprimer
[Musique]
il a vécu aussi du harcèlement forcément
quand on montre une différence et c'est
ça qui est formidable c'est ce qu'il a
pu dire aussi c'est que à un moment
donné tu avais exprimé un truc comme ça
la prof tu avais dit mais comment quand
les autres rigolent de toi comment ça ne
touche pas et tu as dit
je veux même pas rien
que ouais c'est mental quoi il dit et ça
j'ai vu et c'était ça le théâtre aussi
c'est ça commence à ed ou gelée déjà vu
jouer au chapiteau ou sari dont la passe
des fois ya les centres de loisirs ça
rigole tout mais malgré tout faut dire
son texte au dessus de tout ça et c'est
ce qui l'a aidé
joachim rend souvent visite à son
professeur et aux enfants de la
compagnie des contraires comme il a
appris la pratique théâtrale sous ce
chapiteau à chanteloup-les-vignes plus
du théâtre général ou à gg des facilités
à apprendre le texte est et après quand
on a le texte il ya
par exemple la satq et que mon
professeur de théâtre
qui m'apprend le
comment comment je vais jouer ce texte
qu'elle pose aussi parce que par exemple
un silence c'est vraiment le dans la
seine et c'est ce qu'il faut intégrer
dans la seine pour c'est un peu comme la
musique faut que ce soit vraiment tout
harmonieux et ça permet vraiment de
faire un
belle pièce on a estimé depuis l'année
dernière que il est prêt pour poursuivre
le travail tout seul maintenant qu'elle
est au décès dont qu'il aimerait bien
faire un bac 4 et est allé plus loin
pourquoi pas faire des études
supérieures et devenir comédien des
enseignements de la sade qui servent au
quotidien aux jeunes acteurs maintenant
ça se passe très bien
première fois je gêne et encouragements
sur mon bulletin c'est un
piège je progresse et puis bien sûr le
comportement
il est beaucoup mieux quoi ne serait ce
que pour ton brevet il avait une chose
alors à la présenter il l'a fait devant
moi il reste debout judy venons tu dois
à soi mais dit non moi j'ai appris comme
ça parce que l'ancrage il est comme ça
si je reste debout monte je vais te dire
autrement et effectivement au final
d'une bonne note pour l'oral
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
une pièce de théâtre de monsieur
moi d'ailleurs je peux en faire mais ce
que bon me semble ne serais-tu points un
homme à les faire courir le bruit que
j'ai chez moi de l'argent caché
[Musique]
créé en 1991 par nez aux à une femme
tout juste arrivé du brésil la compagnie
des contraire est une association de
chanteloup-les-vignes sa vocation
travailler sur l'inclusion et
l'insertion par l'art c'est bien sûr le
cas de joachim un jour il est arrivé ici
j'ai compris tout de suite que joaquin
et les il avait une sensibilité est
spéciale et qu'il au théâtre pourrait
être pour lui vraiment le chemin de la
lumière elle tenait toujours le rôle
principal alors il était vraiment il est
toujours en moteur de toute la troupe de
théâtre qui s'appelle sentinelles des
contraires il a évolué beaucoup joaquin
le continue à évoluer c'était très
compliqué pour moi de gérer cette
situation
et en même temps la première fois que je
les ai vus jouer au théâtre
c'est à dire qu'on vous fait voir une
autre facette aussi de votre enfant est
ce qu'il est capable de faire c'est pas
uniquement ce que vous renvoie à l'école
d'un enfant compliqué qu'il a pas sa
place ici enfin c'était c'était violent
mais vous à elle a rien voulu savoir de
mon histoire personnelle de son histoire
personnelle elle a pris comme ça et elle
a sorti ce qui était bon de lui alors
vraiment on peut dire que merci quoi
elle me pousse vers le haut toujours
mais elle pousse pas que moi mais
vraiment tout le monde et elle cherche
le meilleur d'eux
de tourcoing c'est avec une rigueur
attention - ont fait pas n'importe quoi
c'est parce que derrière il ya aussi
toute une démarche éducative et quand on
le questionne à propos de son avenir
c'est un peu compliqué parce que je ne
suis pas devin mais bon moi ce que
j'aimerais ce que j'aimerais faire c'est
c'est vraiment comédien après il ya un
comédien on peut il ya plein de choses
qu'on peut faire il ya on peut passer à
la radio va passer à la télé
être acteur dans les cinémas dans le
théâtre et moi serait plus là pour
l'instant de théâtre et je veux voir si
toutes choses qui me plaisent les
doubleurs aussi il ya plein de choses
joachim joue également le premier rôle
du film documentaire sur la compagnie
intitulé le repère des contraire de
l'oea rinaldi un rôle comme un symbole
pour lui qui a fait du chapiteau son
repère même si à 15 ans aujourd'hui la
compagnie ne fait plus partie de son
quotidien
[Musique]
on va parler de
la réussite élèves de la réussite il
faut dire qu'on l'a dit un petit peu
pour le rappeler c'est à la fois l'école
de la deuxième chance et c'est à la fois
les smart universités alors l'adversité
comme vous l'a dit c'est un écosystème
donc on a plusieurs métiers s'est révélé
fort mais accéléré on part du principe
que dans nos quartiers dans la réalité
il ya des talents qu'on est là pour
faire éclore ces talents et si vous
reprendre
une métaphore qu'on utilise souvent et
que je trouve inapproprié on a par son
ascension sociale new wave dont on parle
tout d'un escalier le jeune qui arrive
chez nous il va faire des efforts montée
des marches nous on est la rampe qui va
l'aider à monter des différentes étapes
quelquefois il va la marche sera haute
on pourra lui prêter notre époque mais
c'est lui de faire l'effort
de se former d'être assidus dans ces
stages en entreprise de réviser ces
partielles pour son bts de réviser ses
cours de bachoter quand il vient chez
nous en cours du soir mais c'est sa
volonté qui est la clé de sa réussite et
nous on le réveille au départ qui
veulent une volonté ont créé des
conditions pour qu'ils se rendent compte
qu'il a les capacités soit on lui a dit
alan par l'éducation nationale on a
souvent on lui a souvent dit ou sous en
fait comprendre ce qui est pire qu'il
n'avait pas les capacités pour réussir
chez nous on va lui expliquer qu'il a
les capacités pour réussir et qu'on va
l'accompagner à cette réussite c'est la
philosophie justement et c'est quelle
est votre public cible à la base alors
suivant dispositif à des publics cibles
différents les écoles deuxième chance et
les jeunes entre 16 et 25 ans qui sont
ni diplôme et d'y former ses des fameux
décrocheurs long en fin de compte ce qu
ont arrêté leur cursus lycéen en bac
ou juste après qu'ils ont longtemps hein
pas été formé
qui sont ces jeunes qui sont restés trop
longtemps dans un canapé en train
attendre qu'un espace qui nous sont
envoyées par les missions locales et par
le réseau ville comme comme chanteloup
vous avez un vrai talent d'acteur on
parlait alors des clubs de sport et le
sport sont les très bons prescripteurs
de jeunes puisque les entraîneurs ils
connaissent bien les jeunes ils savent
qui est plus scolarisée qui pourrait
réussir ensemble on s'emploie pas assez
hachey ce réseau là
de d'entraîneur de sport qui connaissent
bien ces jeunes dans l'est dans les
quartiers et on vous en envoie aussi
ça la vie de chanteloup je
pense que catherine nous à titre
personnel nous envoie des gens des gens
déjeunent tous les jours
en doute pas 30 secondes donc voilà pour
les écoles à une chance pour les jeunes
hans martin r c'est donc en clair le
lancement supérieur c'est déjà une
grande bac ou le niveau bac qui n'ont
pas réussi à s'inscrire dans un bts ou à
faire une formation
universitaire qui veulent reprendre des
études enfin les parfois des gens qui a
été écarté par le parcours 6 passes a
réussi à avoir leurs voeux parcours sud
ça c'est une partie importante de jeunes
aussi et qui viennent s'inscrire chez
nous il devient étudiant ils vont
s'inscrire à un bts ils vont passer
leurs examens ils vont passer leur bac
aussi vial des aïeux
et vont reprendre ainsi que dans ceux
non supérieure à chanteloup donc on a
créé une université à chanteloup un
champ tout une ville universitaire
mais on aura tout à l'heure d'été
bonnaire de
suivi ceea ça vous qui parle le mieux de
nos jeunes et nos formateurs mais ça
veut dire quoi 0 on a les meilleurs
cours universitaires ils sont à
chanteloup en fin de compte ils ont ils
vont s'inscrire en bts via le cned
- de formation à distance via le cned
comme tout un chacun et nous la
particularité si vous allez voir un
coach qui va l'accompagner tout au long
de sa scolarité il se soigne et des
sédiments
individualisés où nous a fait il va
l'accompagner pour voir si il a bien
rendu c'est de voir s'il ya des
difficultés à comprendre il voit aussi
l'accompagner pour qu'il ait sa bourse
aux crous qui les étudiants pour qu'il
est peut-être une aide avec la mission
locale tous les freins ce qui peut avoir
dans son parcours d'étudiant on va
l'aider à les lever avec lui et on va le
motiver le suivre verifix a réussi ce
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui dans les
étudiants du cned on a de meilleures
réussites dans le nez ce parti diversité
du hub que au cned en moyenne sachant
que le tienne vous avez qu à une grande
partie qui sont des expats qui vivent et
rio un niveau socioculturel sans doute
un peu plus élevé que nos jeunes de nos
quartiers - compagnie mais ils sont
moins accompagnés - coach est donc c'est
vraiment le travail du coach et des
coach et ça se félicite parce qu'ils hp
va faire comme on dit et ils passent un
temps de dingue pour les faire réussir
c'est l'objectif est géniale sur la voie
routière non ça coûte cher oui
comment vous êtes lido c'est perdre on
est financée je pense que vous voyez pas
la télé mais à catherine hardwicke et
dans mon ongle donc quand je dis coûte
cher elle a peur que je demande de
subvention est un département au
département pas la ville je te promets
alors le laas partenaires cités est
labellisé campus connectés donc elle est
financée par l'état sur un appel à
projets et puis financement aussi
d'autres collectivités il ya la mise à
disposition des locaux par par laly de
chanteloup et sur l'école des hemmes
chance c'est l'état la région et les
collectivités qui abondent le budget
mais comme tout à l'heure vous disiez
c'est la volonté des élus locaux de
porter ces projets là sur leur
territoire et le pousser pour que
l'ensemble des collectivités puissent
financer ces projets là c'est vraiment
est ce que vraiment
on a des dix personnalités on en allant
93 ans on a un peu partout en ile de
france c'est souvent des mères qui
viennent le chercher quand je veux et on
va se débrouiller au départ on part avec
une veille blanche on sait pas si on
aura l'argent pour ouvrir ou pas mais
les maires se débrouille d'aller trouver
les appels à projets les subventions etc
c'est vraiment cette volonté de faire
réussir sa jeunesse qui est le moteur
enfin compte des ouvertures des smart
quartier des docks de la réussite est
donc et sur le territoire les lobes de
la réussite c'est depuis 2010 9 je crois
c'est d'accord c'est le premier qu'on
ait ouvert en ile de france d'accord
j'ai une certaine pression pour l'ouvrir
en premier si j'étais rire à personne
qui m'a mis la pression
qu'ils aient un local alors un
une histoire de local
des locaux il fallait aménager il faut
être les livres
on va se débrouiller et ça te fait très
rapidement je pense qu'en moins de six
mois on a ouvert un dispositif
aujourd'hui on a vécu plus 90 gilles
jeunes en école d une chance par an ici
à chanteloup
près de sept sur dix ont une sortie
possible circle soit il trouve un emploi
une formation ce qui est une belle
réussite
sur les sur les bts alors je je je crois
que sur les bacs on est à près de 100%
de réussite et sur les bts on doit être
à 7 sur 10 d'obtention du bts ski je
regarde ma robe de la smart hier c'était
qu'il contrechamp là bas mais qui me
fait des
piqûres alors je sais pas si je suis
entouré ou en cercle et je pense que je
suis entouré et devrait tenir un tour et
voilà je suis bien entouré mais basque
parce que enfin compte la russie de ces
jeunes là parce que il ya des
professionnels qui chaque jour
dépense une énergie
considérable mais parce que si vous avez
cette émission là on est tous fascinés
par les désosser à la chesnaie vous ment
le de tous ces gens qui travaillent
parce que alors en temps vous parlez des
locaux ça nous ça nous était important
important pour nous on en a beaucoup
parlé avec catherine que les locaux ils
ressemblent pas
à ce qu'on pouvait entendre de locaux de
centres de formation ou de maisons de
quartier comme on pourrait faire des
années 90 c'est à dire un truc un peu
d'humour nous nous efforçons colorés
sont pratiques on pourrait en rire quand
on rentre on pense plutôt à un tiers
lieu
de deux start-up ou de houe de
d'incubateur d'entreprises parce que
c'est important aussi que dans la
démarche d'insertion on les respecte
aussi par locaux que les locaux puissent
aussi respirer la réussite pour pas que
ce soit du low cost on est en train de
mettre en place ces cours du soir entre
entre 18h et 20h on a fait plus de 800
heures de cours du soir depuis novembre
avec les lycéens de chanteloup ça va les
accompagner sur leurs devoirs un peu
méthodologie c'est 36 lycéens qu'on a on
accompagne ces petits projets là qui
font qu'un territoire réussit enfin
qu'on sait c'est pas les gros projets
qui viennent d'en haut qui tombe c'est
des projets qui sont qui sont faits en
construction avec les acteurs du
territoire c'est ça qui est intéressant
et qui répondent complètement besoins du
territoire c'est ça qui c'est ça qui est
bien qu'ils émanent en fait et on avec
l'impulsion de catherine arenou on
travaille de façon vraiment privilégié
avec les acteurs locaux on a aussi des
des experts on va dire des associations
et cabinet qui viennent extérieur mais
la première volonté c'est de travailler
avec les acteurs locaux qui ont une
vraie compétence un vrai savoir faire et
un contact direct avec la population ce
qui est important c'est donc jeudi
étaient là ont fait l'insertion
économique sévère que on n'est pas fair
insertion sociale en f1 c'est un comique
ça veut dire quoi dire que tous les
parcours qu'on fait pour nos jeunes la
finalité c'est l'emploi c'est le placer
l'emploi parce qu'on pense que la
l'épanouissement et la réussite
personnelle elle passe par pouvoir avoir
un emploi on est aussi un acteur
développement économique le quand vous
arrivez à former sur internet sur un
bassin d'emploi quoi soit bassin de vie
aussi un bassin d'emploi que les jeunes
qu'on accompagne si on puisse les mettre
en stage dans les entreprises du
territoire
complices et des entreprises et aura
recruté sur le sur le territoire on
contribue aussi à la création richesse
humaine mais aussi économiques c'est
important d'avoir cette finalité là
l'occupation c'est la réussite c'est ce
que vous exprimez d'ailleurs dans lors
de l'inauguration lorsque vous parlez de
vous disiez que le hub de la réussite
c'est une solution offerte à chaque
jeune c'est cette idée que vous vouliez
véhicule est justement que vouloir
proposer quelque chose du début jusqu'à
la fin et à la sortie ils ont ils ont
quelque chose alors vous parliez de 7
jeunes sur dix alors lé 3 restants et 3
ce qu'on en fait alors les 3 restants
vous c'est assez c'est assez varié
les fonctionnement des écoles ma chance
c'est comme une entreprise vous avez
période d'essai vous avez un stage
obligatoire et après vous êtes en
alternance il ya des jeunes qui ont
parfois sont pas encore prêts à avoir ce
rythme là ce cycle là et donc l d'échec
et donc oui cet échec de 3 sur 10 qui
est diverse et variée il ya des jeunes
qui après à faire des c c'est nous qui
mettait enfin parce qu'on considère
qu'ils ont pas encore la maturité du
projet ou où les retire les clés de la
réussite
une part de leur volonté il faut qu'il
monte l'escalier s'ils veulent pas on
peut pas le faire alors et donc oui il
ya une partie qui ne réussit pas comme
comme tout comme quand vous avez un
employé et vous mettez femme perd décès
mais ce que voulaient diriger vers
d'autres structures oui on va là on va
travailler avec les missions locales
les opérateurs du territoire pour
parfois les mettre en panne le disent
ils ont besoin d'avoir d'être sorti
sortie du territoire mais s'ils ont
besoin de bouger il y en a qui vont
partir sur ce qu'ils trouvent pas leur
voile à repartir sur d'autres formations
mais on va pas or un parcours avec eux
parce que c'est qu'elle sait des jeunes
on va apprendre qu'ils vont être pendant
huit mois chez nous à 35 heures ont
commencé à 8h30 ce matin
ça peut un peu vous lars eller quotidien
qu'ils avaient jusqu'à présent donc il
faut quand même une certaine maturité
leur parcours pour qui ce pouvoir
subir j'allais dire ce parcours là pour
compléter il ya un vrai réseau jeunesse
sur le territoire avec un bureau
information jeunesse
le effectivement pôle emploi mission
locale mais aussi air peu à eux que
rencontrent pour l'égalité d'accès à
l'emploi c'est à dire qu'il ya une
multitude de
dispositifs possibles qui peuvent encore
relancé à d'autres le projet du jeune
ouais il ya aussi les coachs de
développement par le sport voilà il ya
un coach sportif il ya beaucoup de
choses
vraiment un jeune à chanteloup peut être
soutenu si voilà j'ai envie de dire
il faut le vouloir voulez vous le voir
là cités et simone règle elle sera elle
sera ouverte qu'en lien d'elena alors
oui il a d'elle il est prévu
qu'elle use prévue à la rentrée à la
rentrée 2024 d'accord avec avec toutes
ces difficultés de travail est tellement
en amont avec les enfants les parents
que on n'est pas dans la même
temporalité et que les habitants donc on
était très on est sur le fil 1 en fait
mais on travaille quand même avec les
habitants ça à savoir que quand on a
commencé
qu'on se concerter avec des enfants en
2024 et seront même plus scolarisés dans
l'équipement et dans les écoles sont les
avec lesquels on travaille et voilà mais
c'est ça c'est ça la politique de la
mise et ce à tous les projets de
rénovation urbaine ça prend du temps il
faut on est vraiment en fait de l'ordre
de la dentelle et la communication c'est
important et les missions aux joueurs
que ce père relève le chauffeur je vois
que l'école sur laquelle ça doit être
construit elle est toujours là donc oui
il est prévu être fade et encore des
enfants même de dieu non j'ai pas dire
tout de suite
nathan que ces prix ça sonne fin d'année
vous voyez c'est quand même pas si
lointain donc à l'automne 2022 ok cas là
on va poursuivre après cette
conversation justement avec des des
jeunes qui ont bénéficié soit de la
partie diversité soit l'école de la
deuxième chance et puis et puis après on
parlera aussi de formation et
d'insertion quelqu'un un dossier
évidemment
essentiel merci beaucoup car
[Musique]
on va enregistrer ce dont on vient de
parler avec benjamin crohn avec avec 3 3
chaînes qui sont la formidable vous
aller témoigner vous allez de raconter
votre parcours
commencez par vous
sarrazy main c'est ça et vous êtes vous
avez fait l'école de la deuxième chance
à chanteloup oui et ça vous a permis de
trouver un emploi parce que je crois que
vous êtes à la mission locale
intercommunale pas si conflent
bah en fait grâce à l'école de la
deuxième chance j'ai eu l'opportunité de
faire un stage de deux mois on a mission
locale intercommunale possible conflent
et après ce stage j'ai signé un contrat
cdd un nom et ont même temps j'ai
préparé mon diplôme s'ils avaient eu
pour
pour un poste d'agent d'accueil et
agents administratifs
et
moi j'ai fait un an j'ai travaillé un an
à la mission locale donc c'était bien
s'est bien passé ils m'ont dit même
qu'ils vont renouveler mon contrat donc
je suis très content donc voilà comment
vous êtes arrivé comment vous êtes
arrivé là comment vous êtes arrivé
oh oui
absolument comment vous êtes arrivé
dans cette école de la deuxième chance
en fait j'ai été orienté par la mission
locale parce que j'étais inscrits à la
mission locale et il ma conseillère
madame helena papa il m'a orientée à
l'école de la deuxième chance mais vous
étiez vous étiez au lycée avant vous
étiez non pas du tout c'est rien donc je
vous avez un jour donné les codes arrêté
l'école m'a dit tout en fait moi je
viens de l'italie
j'avais un diplôme d'opticien j'ai
cherché dans l'opticien mais j'ai pas
trouvé donc voila et j'ai vraiment avec
l'école de la deuxième chance grâce à ça
j'ai eu l'opportunité de changer
vraiment de projet et je savais pas qui
c'était la première fois que je
travaille dans l'administratif donc
c'est bien passé d'accord oui vous des
d'italie donc des tarifs et toi tu peux
faire l'interview en
italien dernièrement
[Rires]
c'est formidable et donc vous est
adressée à la mission locale c'est comme
ça et qu'est ce qu'on apprend à l'école
c'est quoi les cols de deuxième chance
bah en fait c'est un accompagnement
renforcé
chacun est là vraiment accompagnant
forcé parce que moi avant je savais pas
mais compétentes donc je savais même pas
qui ça peut m'intéresser l'administratif
donc si avec eux qui doucement ils vont
vraiment aidé mais pour le français
donc parce que je parlais pas et voilà
c'est vraiment pour m'aider pour savoir
mes compétences pour pour vraiment le
projet professionnel de le chercher on a
fait plusieurs tests pour voir donc
voilà et je pense c'est très très bien
très bien fait ça vous a mis dans le
seul chemin de l'emploi déjà oui c'est
ça ouais c'est formidable on parle un
peu avec adèle tour est
alors vous êtes
étudiante en première année de bts alors
là ces négociations digitalisation resto
nancy clients ça
se comprend pas tout
servir
là vous vous avez bénéficié de la
spartine diversité ah ça oui c'est ça
mais alors avant qu'il était votre
parcours et au lycée vous avez passé le
bac oui j'étais au lycée j'ai obtenu mon
bac en 2019 un bac pro vente et après
j'ai voulu chercher du travail donc j'ai
travaillé pendant une année et j'ai
voulu reprendre mes études mais
malheureusement j'ai pas trouvé et c'est
une année après que grâce à la mission
locale j'ai trouvé la smart universités
et que j'ai pu m'inscrire pour reprendre
mes études et c'était quoi les freins
quand vous avez voulu reprendre les
études qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce qui a
fait que vous n'avez pas trouvé là
j'étais pas déjà pris prioritaire sur
parcours sup donc forcément sur ça j'ai
pas mes voeux n'ont pas été acceptées
après j'ai sauté quoi vos voeux j'ai
essayé de lui en communication en
assurant son immobilier en tout ce qui
concernait mon bts un peu en ndrc en muc
et aucun des deux n'a été acceptée du
coup vous grâce à admission le cas j'ai
pu trouver cette formation est alors la
tienne 6 on en a un petit peu parlé avec
beaucoup parlé avec ma maman je connais
deux parties de la cités mais
concrètement ça se passe comment
pour moi personnellement ça serait
plutôt bien ça me permet de travailler à
côté justement il cherchait vu ça veut
dire que vous si vous vous avez opté des
cours par correspondance et à ses à
distance mais on est dans des locaux on
a des ordinateurs on peut travailler à
distance
et vous êtes et iliad est d'aider des
gens des coachs enfin
avec nous qui nous aide qui nous fait
une fois par semaine nous voit et nous
fait un point pour savoir un peu ce
qu'on a fait ce qu'on n'a pas fait si on
a du mal à nous aide est toujours là
pour nous et si on a besoin d'elle on va
l'avoir et le monde discute avec elle
lui a dit qu on est à la fois on a les
cours de de diversité comme comme c'est
un studio et on est quand même et des
suivis par
c'est votre choix est elle toujours
disponible pour nous donc ça c'est super
on est à distance mais on a quand même
quelqu'un pour nous accompagner à tout
appel à qui est ce un dock est je pense
que
ça va mieux et vous disiez vous vous
travaillez votre avion c'est en
alternance et en contrat d'alternance
sénat en page en c1 s'est dit que j'ai
eu à pau après mon bac 6 à trouver un
travail et fut là bas je suis devenue
formatrice d'ailleurs vingt deux recrues
là bas et ils ça me tenait vraiment à
coeur de trouver une formation dans
laquelle je pouvais également travailler
à côté et grâce à asma j'arrivais à
faire les deux oui justement j'arrive à
faire les deux je travaille le soir et
j'y cours à la smart la journée et à
terme quelles sont vos perspectives pour
vos objectifs qu'est ce que vous voyez
faire là après
après cette formation mais j'espère déjà
obtenu mon bts et ensuite continuer mes
études dans une licence en marketing
oui oui donc ça vous a permis voilà de
reprendre des études de travailler 20
ans d'être suivi donc voilà c'est un
parcours formidable raphaël lips bonjour
alors vous vous êtes deuxième année vous
devez sa de bts et commerce
international
vous étiez parti en australie 16 ans
alors oui j'ai un parcours un peu
atypique parce que quand j'ai eu mon bac
j'ai voulu faire une formation normale
en licence est en fait sur parcours
subjectif mais mes premiers choix et jeu
mais j'étais dans une forme à ce degré
voulais faire c'était éco-gestion donc
voilà et ces dons c'est un peu loin
c'était
j'en appelle plus c'était plus d'une
heure trente de transport allait 1h30
retour et en plus c'était des cours
magistraux qui plaisait pas trop et du
coup j'ai décidé d'arrêter fin de
quitter lavenac et je me suis mis en
idée de partir en australie donc voilà
j'ai connu une fin j'ai que j'ai
travaillé pendant une année à peu près
j'ai économisé de l'argent et je suis
parti une année complète en en australie
par exemple trouve du boulot facilement
en australie alors à l'époque oui il ya
dix ans c'était très facile maintenant
il y avait quand même beaucoup de gens
comme moi qui tentent leur chance en
australie il ya du travail mais souvent
c'est du travail et un peu de jus etc
mais oui on peut traduire grave ou pas
j'ai fait plein de femmes boulot ggg
fait la plonge et fait du service j'ai
travaillé dans des dans les champs de la
distribution prospectus donc ouais j'ai
fait plein de trucs différents voilà et
quand vous revenez évidemment difficile
de s'inscrire quelques pas bah oui parce
que déjà
le système français après deux ans sans
travail et inuh concert comme
déscolarisés et trouver une école qu'on
est déscolarisé c'est pas top c'est plus
facile quoi et surtout que j'étais pas
j'étais revenu trop tarder australie
j'étais revenu en juin et que toutes les
procédures de parcours super tweet est
déjà finie et que depuis australie
c'était dur pour moi de postuler de
faire les toutes les idées entre tous
les entretiens et hop aux écoles et du
coup bah j'ai pas pu inscrire un école
voilà d'où la smart et immersive à la
saison donc celle à la mission locale de
mantes la jolie à côté de là où j'habite
et ils ont redirigé vers la mi fin la
smart universités donc voilà après juin
un entretien on a vu ensemble ce qu'on
pouvait faire et j'ai été accepté et
aujourd'hui vous en est où là du coup
donc là du coup 102e année j'ai réussi à
passer ma première année
ici tout s'est bien passé
on a en fait on est bien encadrée comme
des lieux a précisé on a une coach qui
va sur notre avancement et où on a aussi
de temps en temps des intervenants qui
viennent on a notamment prof d'anglais
michel qui vient tous les mercredis
bénévolement et on avait aussi un prof
de maths qui est venu plusieurs fois et
donc en fait voilà on est on est bien
accompagné on avance à notre rythme vu
que c'est les cours en ligne
quand on est en cours magistral souvent
il ya un truc qu'on n'a pas bien compris
et on est déjà passé à autre chose il ya
dire voilà leur classe s'il ya quelque
chose qu'on a du mal à comprendre de
prendre notre temps pour bien travailler
dessus et comme ça on est sûr d'avoir
bien tout compris et voilà donc j'ai
passé un premier années maintenant
changer et menait alors vous êtes assez
courageux parce que vous avez fait cette
deuxième année de bts vous travaillez en
même temps oui c'est ça la semaine et le
week-end c'est donc la semaine deux fois
par semaine le jeudi le mardi je suis
tuteur dans le projet de soutien
scolaire justement dont vous aviez parlé
je crois
comme j'ai vécu un en australie
mais voilà en anglais donc je peux me
permettre d'aider des lycéens en anglais
même sur la méthodologie vu que j'ai eu
un bac s sur l'économie une histoire et
cetera et il voit là ça se passe super
bien et le week-end de juges hard signé
j'ai pris mon expérience on ne traduit
un prix en australie rivage a pris avant
en france je travaillais pour le club de
paris en mai c'est extraordinaire parce
que c'est d'ailleurs je pense qu'on
devrait à la fin du cursus classique
envoyer les jeunes à l'étranger
déjà ça ouvre sur le monde c'est celui
où alors c'est à dire des italiens
oui mais après faut les former à voler
c'est bien vous êtes heureux d'avoir
trouvé au fond ce cursus
vous permet de trouver un emploi vous
permis de reprendre des études
c'est quand même un s comme dacquois
mais c'est sûr parce que
de deux potes de copines de copains qui
on les appelait même cursus que vous
ben moi personnellement j'ai des amis
qui sont en pro en course
professionnelle jeu notre ami qui a un
master qui enquille le finir là et donc
way to me met plus ou moins peu des
parcours différents donc
c'est
la même la plupart de mes amis ont
réussi à trouver des formations dans des
écoles est actuellement y travaillent et
font leur formation aussi d'accord
d'accord moi non j'ai pas des amis qui
est vraiment aux anges en fait moi je
les pousse un petit peu quand même donc
je le dis il faut faire il faut il faut
aller à l'école il faut travailler il
faut pas rester à la maison donc quand
ils me voient un petit peu il regarde
que j'ai fait quand même je viens
d'arriver j'ai fait un parcours je suis
en contrat et je travaille donc un petit
peu je te pousse pour lui dire voilà il
faut que oui il faut dire que voilà
c'est très bien c'est ce que vous avez
fait mais vous avez voulu aussi le faire
faut vouloir bosser un faut bosser un
bruit c'est sa chanson y'a pas de secret
on sait s'il n'ya pas la volonté de la
personne elle même personne peut rien
faire pour elle a
en tout cas bravo et merci de vos
témoignages cités été intéressant
d'avoir voilà comment ça se passait
concrètement merci merci beaucoup à tous
les toits merci et puis plein de
réussite pour le projet
[Musique]
bon va ouvrir maintenant dossiers
essentiels caisses de l'entreprise des
associations et de l'insertion si
j'étais des potirons team dit quoi tu
bouges pas je pense ou
à la soupe je me dirige vers pas
tiendrait non non non en fait j'ai papa
je te parlais d'une association qui est
et qualys qui des jardins partagés dans
lesquels on il emploie des gens qui sont
un peu exclus de l'emploi et puis des
boutiques dans laquelle ils vendent
ensuite qu'ils écoutent et danser dans
ses jardins et ses boutiques ça
s'appelle des potirons les potes iront
rouler pire on peut la craie soir comme
on veut et on est allé on est allé les
voir quelques élus leur travail c'est un
reportage de céline charles
[Musique]
et potirons c'est justement
pour proposer des légumes qu'on produit
à travers des jardins de cocagne que
nous avons et qu'on met en vente avec
des boutiques avec un camion et aussi
des sensibilisations et de la formation
sur de la permaculture en milieu urbain
comme ici
on fait des plantations en fait c'est
pour montrer aux gens qu'on peut planter
sur des petites parcelles qu'on peut
faire des choses même si on n'a pas des
ha mais sur des petites parcelles et ben
on fait des plantations de fleurs de
légumes notamment des cours
[Musique]
alors c'est pas forcément pour faire des
futurs jardiniers ou des techniciens en
espaces verts pour les collectivités
mais c'est surtout un support qui leur
permet de se redynamiser de sortir de un
peu de leur quotidien et d'être
accompagnés vers un véritable projet
professionnel
l'idée c'est vraiment de leur redonner d
un cadre au niveau du professionnel
savoir arriver à l'heure le savoir-être
être présents ne pas être absents écouté
les consignes comme dans n'importe
quelle entreprise
mais professionnellement ça m'apporte
beaucoup non seulement le savoir être et
le savoir faire que j'avais déjà et j'y
suis depuis quatre mois maintenant et ça
se passe super bien j'apprends plein
plein de choses et voilà je suis dans
une équipe avec des gens formidables
il encadre aussi et puis le suivi aussi
les tops
les adore les adore et j'adore aussi
leur travail avec eux parce que c'est
vraiment un échange chacun
son sens son savoir donc tous les
savoirs son partage on a vraiment cet
esprit d'équipé tous les matins je suis
heureux de venir au travail parce que je
sais que deux je vais apprendre bien
plus que je leur apprends franchement je
suis bien de vous
comme à l'habitude c'est magnifique
[Musique]
alors ici vous êtes dans la boutique les
potirons une boutique qui a été créé il
ya trois ans ça fera trois ans à noël
qu'on ait ouvert ici il ya plusieurs
objectifs c'était de répondre à un
besoin de commerces de proximité offrir
voilà aux habitants des produits locaux
et des fruits et légumes bio 2 c'était
de créer de l'emploi et permettre à des
personnes éloignées de l'emploi donc
sans emploi de retrouver du travail et
de venir travailler dans ce dispositif
qu'est la boutique et 3 c'était de le
troisième objectif c'était de travailler
avec les agriculteurs locaux et de
valoriser la production locale
[Musique]
j'étais recherché d'emploi et un concert
du rsa ma part les 17 de cette
association du coup bah voila j'ai fait
en sorte de postuler ici ça me
permettait d'intégrer doucement le monde
du travail parce que c'est pas très
simple par exemple de commencer avec un
mi temps
ensuite sur 35 heures voilà donc petit à
petit mais aures va augmenter
aujourd'hui à 30 circuit
[Musique]
ce sont des personnes qui sont à la base
à la recherche d'un emploi donc sans
emploi qui ont besoin de retrouver un le
chemin vers l'emploi durable et donc
nous on est un tremplin pour eux pour
les aider à retrouver un emploi plus
perrin derrière
[Musique]
depuis le début je dire ça m'a apporté
de la confiance ça c'est important ça
permet de renouer avec le monde du
travail aussi le regard des autres on ne
peut pas se cacher derrière
et voilà surtout ça la confiance et du
dynamisme parce que quand on est
longtemps arrêté
ça remet la machine en route
on s'habitue à nouveau heures
[Musique]
je sais que la première chose qu'on va
regarder c'est sur mon cv ceci j'ai de
l'expérience dans ce domaine et là
c'est le cas j'apprends et
j'apprends petit à petit et jacquire des
compétences et surtout c'est très
enrichissant pour les produits et donc
ses légumes bio sont valorisés en
circuit court dans notre boutique et on
retrouve tous les légumes de saison et
bio toute l'année on a beaucoup de
produits du 78 pour tout ce qui est
produits carnés produits laitiers et
fromages aussi des produits d'épicerie
pour ainsi de la truite fumée du 78
pourquoi on s'est vraiment travailler en
local
[Musique]
c'est bien c'est formidable c'est ce
qu'ils font c'est extraordinaire ça
permet justement de remettre le pied
dans le couloir dans le voilà exactement
et c'est ce que vous aussi de deux
invités vers / ni virginie visé bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le tetris général de
sténo formations hostiles aux formations
c'est une association
de formation comme son nom l'indiqué
dans les métiers de l'hôtellerie et de
la restauration
alors vous faites de la formation et
vous faites aussi de l'insertion ça
absolument alors en fait on fait de
l'insertion par la formation à
l'information tout à fait et
jean-françois lutins bonjour vous êtes
le directeur général de val de seine
alors val de seine se sont d'aider des
entreprises qui collectent et qui crient
et qui trie des textiles c'est ça oui
non
excusez moi bonjour je suis jean
françois lucquin donc
oui je représente le relais val de seine
donc on collecte et au tri des vêtements
et c'est une structure d'insertion aussi
chantent ouvèze qui emploie 150
personnes dont la moitié en insertion
dont la moitié en natation étaient tous
les deux vont voir parler de jacob de
vos associations et de votre entreprise
vous adresser aussi à des gens qui sont
assez éloignées de du domaine de
l'emploi très éloignées même
raisonnement tout à fait à la fois des
gens qui sont déjà en emploi mais aussi
des gens qui sont très éloignées de
l'emploi alors on va commencer par val
de seine s'ils voulaient bien c'est une
entreprise qui a été créée il ya ya
quelques années quand même sous
l'impulsion
de la fondation de l'abbé pierre fin de
2006 mais
l'entreprise et a été créée en 1994
c'est un l'issue d'un reportage séné
dans le nord de la france d'une
communauté emmaüs donc d'une communauté
emmaüs les gens sont c'est l'accueil
inconditionnel un papier sans papiers on
accueille des gens qui sont éloignés de
l'emploi pas qu'ils sont à la rue plus
tôt et puis vivre dans un système
associatif vous leur donnez ce que vous
voulez ils revendent les gens sont logés
nourris blanchis au sein de cette
communauté dans les années 80 il y avait
de plus en plus de jeunes de 20 25 ans
qui arrivait et la communauté de
l'époque s'est dit c'est quand même pas
possible de garder des jeunes de 20 25
ans toute leur vie logé nourri blanchi à
vivre de cette façon là donc ils se sont
dit qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire mais il
faut l'arrivée à leur redonner un
salaire comme on fait pour donner un
salaire mais il faut créer des richesses
comment on fait pour créer des richesses
boeuf offert des entreprises donc on a
fait des entreprises par accident avec
l'unique but non pas de rémunérer un
capital mais de permettre à des gens
éloignés de l'emploi de retrouver le
chemin du travail c'est comme ça qu'on
est né il ya un petit reportage
télévisuel et puis pierre cardo un soir
devait s'ennuyer l'été devant sa télé il
a vu le truc ici dit tiens il ya 35 % de
chômage il embauche des gens éloignés de
l'emploi moi je sais pas quoi faire il
est en train d'essayer de développer la
zone industrielle à l'époque mais le
souci c'est que les entreprises elles
recrutent et assez peu de chantelouve et
donc il s'est dit ben on va aller les
voir est-ce qu'ils sont d'accord et puis
c'est comme ça qu'on est arrivé là mais
parce qu'avant ça parce qu'avant ça vous
aviez déjà dirigé d'autres structures
vous je crois alors moi je travaillais
déjà dans d'autres endroits ailleurs en
france et sur chantelauze chanteloup
jute la savoie la suite à sa cp de suite
à ça sur chanteloup on a créé une autre
structure qui s'appelle espérance qui
fait de l'insertion aussi par l'activité
économique
donc à chaque fois les les entreprises
qui sont décodés coopérative elles elles
ont pour but unique de remettre des gens
éloignés de l'emploi au travail de leur
redonner désorientés peut-être vert
et qualys s'ils ont envie de faire une
formation qualifiante dans les métiers
de l'hôtellerie ou de la restauration ou
que sais-je nous notre objectif c'est de
le redonner de l'employabilité de léran
briller sur leur pas courte sur le rêve
de leur vie quelque part de leur faire
aimer émerger ça et puis de les renvoyer
donc différentes structures il ya le
relais où on collecte on trie on revend
du textile des ménages vous pouvez nous
donner 6 voiles avec des vêtements je
repars avec tout de suite là pas de
problème donc une meilleure qualité si
beau si même dans la salle ainsi
on a la tête ratée donc voilà et
sinon êtes vendeur
sur espérances on fait du
conditionnement à façon donc cela veut
dire par exemple les shampoings les gels
douche voulait vendre vous pouvez les
acheter par deux avec une gaine
plastique on va les monter et on va
aller on va les préparer pour les
envoyer dans la grande distribution fait
aussi pas mal de préparation de vente
e-commerce est sûre chanteloup il ya
aussi une association qui s'appelle défi
services plus ou là on va former des
gens éloignés de l'emploi aux métiers du
service à la personne sont des métiers
qui en ce moment sont très demandés on
cherche énormément de persister ce don
conforme à peu près il ya en permanence
il ya 150 personnes vraiment qu'ils sont
formés qu'on envoie chez les
particuliers ou dans les entreprises
alors vous a rendu visite à chaud tout
dans cette opération de tri de
réutilisation des textiles je propose de
regarder un reportage de justin brasier
vous avez sans doute déjà vu ces bornes
dans votre ville peut-être même les avez
vous déjà utilisé pour donner des habits
des sacs des chaussures mais savez vous
comment les vêtements sont ensuite triés
et réutilisées par la suite partons
ensemble à la découverte des coulisses
du relais val-de-seine de chanteloup les
vignes
[Musique]
oh
chaque matin les chauffeurs du relais
parts à 6h30 et sillonne les yvelines
pour récolter les sacs de vêtements dans
les bornes ils reviennent vers 13 heures
14 heures pour décharger les vêtements
et les chaussures qu'ils ont collecté
après avoir été déchargés les vêtements
sont disposés sur un tapis roulant pour
être triées entre différentes catégories
donc là sur le tapis les deux premiers
postes de tristes d'époque sont les
derniers à la qualité boutiques cafés
clientèle vont avoir pour mission de
prélever des vêtements que l'on va
ensuite revendre en eau propre triple
bond à 8 passes comment donc deux à
paris et puis le reste dans les yvelines
une dent val d'oise à pontoise pour
trouver une nouvelle vie à chaque
vêtement il existe une cinquantaine de
catégories différentes équipes de chasse
gauche et c'est une claque théorie du
raffinage dans l'est particulièrement
fier sans l'être ce sont des vieux jeans
qui vont être envoyés dans le nord de la
france dans une usine du réseau relais
pour fabriquer un job s'appelle le métis
ça permet de donner aux vêtements une
seconde vie qui est assez longue en
isolant ça peut durer quinze vingt ans
c'est en isolant écologique puisqu'il
est fait à partir de
d'une matière première
ne pouvait plus être utilisé en tant que
vêtements
donc là on a le sel et le bm c'est ce
qu'on appelle un coup de chiffon
lacouchie tons couleur la confiture
blanc donc ses vêtements ils vont être
découpées en suivant d'essuyage à
destination de l'industrie automobile et
à la fin de la chaîne de tri les
vêtements arrivent sur l'île aux
boutiques où une dizaine de personnes
tri de nouveau les habits en fonction
des saisons pour ensuite les revendre à
petit prix dans l'es8 friperie du relais
val de seine sur l'ensemble de vêtements
et chaussures qu'on collecte il y en a 5
à 6 % c'est en parfaite état pour avoir
revendre dans notre pays donc ça fait un
vêtement sur l'as tu vas être vendue en
france est elle de 3,14 à
la ron grabe été sélection alors elle se
dit toujours ses cartons que je préfère
parce que forcément c'est avec futenma
numérique y revient techer ya des eaux
ya la femme alors la flamme qu'on
appelle la finlande est tous les hommes
et on a que le bât pantalons jupes et
quelques ça permet à bt et là on a le
carton un mâle envoyé on en a qu'un seul
carton jaune parce que les hommes ils
dépensent pas beaucoup dans leurs
vêtements le centre de collecte propose
également certains vêtements à des
créateurs de mode ou des grossistes ils
sont environ une dizaine à venir
s'approvisionner directement sur le site
les jeunes créateurs qui souhaitent
proposer des défilés que avec des
vêtements de seconde main qui vont
retravailler donc ça aussi c'est fait
notre fierté outre la collecte et le tri
des vêtements le rené val de seine est
avant tout une entreprise à but
socio-économique
c'est à dire qu'elle ne recherche pas la
performance économique pour le profit
mais pour atteindre des objectifs
sociaux
chaque centime généré est réinvesti à
des fins de lutte contre l'exclusion de
relais val de seine c'est une
coopérative du mouvement emmaüs donc
elles collectent trient elle revalorise
des vêtements et cette activité
économique elle sert de support à une
mission sociale on est une entreprise
d'insertion dire qu'on accueille des
personnes pour des contrats qui dure
deux ans maximum pendant lesquelles ils
sont accompagnés formé vers un retour à
l'emploi pérenne aujourd'hui il ya plus
de la moitié des emplois qui sont des
emplois donc pour l'insertion ça veut
dire que ça permet des personnes
éloignées de l'emploi
de surprofits siona liseuse
professionnaliser tout court est de
retrouver de l'emploi par la suite donc
certains restent aussi initié et la
plupart vont retrouver de l'emploi à
l'extérieur donc ça c'est une autre
grande grande joie et c'est le but de
notre activité parmi les 140 personnes
qui travaillent au relais val-de-seine
90 sont en insertion
depuis 2007 les plus grands perdants
après n'est pas de partir et enfin je
craque euse alors le métier trackers
c'est simple c'est quand les chauffeurs
ils ramènent les sacs plastiques des
vêtements je dois les cracks est ok en
triant de maisons pour les blousons les
chaussures et les jouets d'enfants et le
reste servant sur le tapis ces défis qui
trie ses traits physiques c'est ben
c'est pour ça que je fais la première
femme à le faire ici parce que il ya a
poussé les bacs qui sont très lourds
après il ya des garçons qui m'aident
aussi parce que bon la chine qui après
mon chez une personne qui est assez
dynamique donc c'est pas que j'aime
lorsque deux boys était sur le tapis
donc c'est moi qui ai un peu poussé pour
venir ici et en plus de ça on a un
tonnage affaires de 88 cents par jour
bon bah c'est physique mais c'est bien
l'année dernière le relais val-de-seine
de chanteloup-les-vignes récolté 6200
tonnes de vêtements ce qui équivaut à
environ 20 tonnes de vêtements par jour
on sait qu'aujourd'hui une grande partie
du vêtement c'est de la fast fashion
donc cédé souvent des vêtements de basse
qualité en france chaque année 80 % des
vêtements finissent leur vie aux ordures
ménagères le relais val-de-seine de
chanteloup les vignes a pour objectif en
2023 de s'agrandir et de trier 8000
tonnes de vêtements par an on
n'encourage pas la sueur à la
surproduction on préférait que les
quantités baisse que la qualité des
vêtements s'améliore que
les personnes traîne encore plus en
leurs vêtements
plutôt que de collecter toujours plus
faiblement en plus de la collecte du
réemploi du recyclage de vêtements et du
développement de boutiques le relais val
de seine vient également de créer sa
propre marque l'objectif recréer des
vêtements qui ne peuvent plus être
portée ont lâché de lancer notre propre
marque de cinq livres en décembre
avec 150 places pour un premier test le
principe de lifting c'est de prendre des
vêtements comment elle pas pu reloger en
tant que traitement on conseille par
exemple une belle chemise mais dont le
bail troué
et on va retravailler des pièces
ensemble pour vos fabrique un vêtement
baptisé air up cycling la marque propose
des pièces autour des 30 à 60 euros
quand vous avez par exemple de suite
qu'on a
[Musique]
cousu ensemble pour en faire à nouveau à
partir de deux fuites qui était complet
plus reporté en l'état et enfin un
nouveau vêtement
tendance en donnant vos vêtements vos
chaussures votre linge de maison ou
encore de la petite maroquinerie vous
faites ainsi un geste écologique mais
aussi solidaire en trente ans le relais
à créer plus de 2200 emplois et
intervient sur l'ensemble du territoire
français pionnier de l'économie
circulaire et de l'insertion il démontre
que professionnalisme et solidarité sont
compatibles voila voila c'est donc ce
que vous faites à chanteloup même
jean-françois lutins
ça veut dire un jour moi je voulais je
voulais travailler être au service du
plus grand nombre et pas celui des
actionnaires
ça a pesé un peu ça votre votre
profession de foi si je peux dire en
fait ma profession de foi si j'avais
envie de me sentir utile et disons que
je me sens plus utile à faire ce que je
fais aujourd'hui que faire autre chose
après chacun trouve son utilité là où il
a envie pas de jugement particulier mais
moi j'avais envie de me sentir utile
pour la collectivité c'est là je les
trouvais est sûre vous avez des chiffres
alors surtout il ya combien à peu près
de deux personnes qui y sont employés
par val de seine la remise dans l'emploi
donc sur leur level de scène on et 150 à
chanteloup et on a une une autre
entreprise à bordeaux où il ya 110
salariés il ya donc ça c'est sur
l'activité de recyclage textile sur le
conditionnement il ya 50 à 60 personnes
en permanence et à défi service il ya
peu près 150 fiches de paye par mois
donc ça doit faire si on additionne
150,50 350 dont 60% sont déjà en
insertion qui
entrent et qui sortent de façon
permanente et un moment où vous dites
justement que ce que vous faites est
très important parce que vous faites de
la formation de l'insertion mais parce
que ce que vous faites et bien
je sais pas si c'est bien disons que
c'est ce que j'ai envie de faire et
c'est ce qu'on fait avec les équipes je
suis pas ça tout seul on est toute une
équipe nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est
de tendre la main à quelqu'un qui veut
s'en sortir et dans la mesure où la
personne elle a envie de faire quelque
chose juste elle nous tend la main nous
on veut dire ben ok viens on va te faire
monter puis après tu seras autonome donc
voilà l'idée c'est de faire grandir les
gens et de les rendre autonomes parce
qu'ils ont eu un parcours de vie avec
une cassure avec une difficulté
quelconque donc quelqu'un qui veut se
relever dans l'aide à se relever puis
après il est reparti donc c'est ça qu'on
a envie de faire cette séquence opel
insertion emploi du travail pour tout le
monde il peut y avoir du travail pour
tout le monde et il n'y a pas des gens
qui sont exclus du travail on peut on
peut arriver allez allez allez récupérer
si je peux au présupposé pas très jolies
verrines alors oui moi je pense qu'on
peut tout à fait eric raffin récupérer
j'aime pas ce sommet va bien
les entraîner leur donner du travail
tout à fait c'est ce qu'on fait nous
puisqu'on fait pas du tout de tri par
exemple à l'entrée en formation on prend
tout le monde et ont créé des parcours
qui vont dépendre de la situation ils
sont en entrant pour qu'ils aillent à
l'emploi et les ce qui passe par votre
association ou votre entreprise
parfois ils sont risque reste pas
forcément c'est vous il trouve
facilement l'emploi ce qui est important
c'est quoi se donner un cadre aussi
cadre de voile à respecter des horaires
respectés ddd des choses à faire enfin
des désordres si on en reçoit le travail
ensemble aussi c'est ça chez nous c'est
apprendre à apprendre ou réapprendre les
codes d'une entreprise donc avec tous
les codes d'une entreprise que vous
pouvez imaginer
et essayer de les replacer nous on
arrive là c'était un peu compliqué avec
le co vide mais aura un écho vide on
replace 80% des gens qui viennent chez
nous soit dans les entreprises locales
qui sont très demandeuses de main
d'oeuvre et qui ont du mal à en trouver
soit sur des parcours de formation
qualifiante parce que les gens s'y rêver
ce que dit tout à l'heure enfin si la
personne rêve de devenir boulanger mais
qui là qu'il faut absolument un c'est un
pays bas on va trouver la structure qui
va le former aussi carré pour les voilà
il ya un suivi des gens après moi ce que
je voudrais attirer l'attention c'est
que on a trop souvent le lait l'habitude
de regarder les gens par leur problème
c'est à dire que les gens en insertion
ils sont bourrés de qualité
ici sur chanteloup il ya 60 ou 70
nationalités ou ethnies on en a 25 dans
les entreprises j'imagine que c'est
pareil à et qualys dire ils ont tort
c'est bon pour les installations oui et
c'était l'information mais pardon
certaines informations il se spécialise
sans doute mais ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'on dort sur un tas de pépites
est juste il faut prendre le temps
d'aller les chercher de les révéler et
les gens après ils sont repartis nous on
fait juste ça coince et tout mais alors
on est à une période où on est qu'il ya
quand même pas mal de métier qu'ils sont
qui sont en tension
est-ce que vos formations vous les
adaptez à la demande du marché ou alors
vous former les gens en fonction de
leurs envies tout simplement nous on les
forme en fonction de leurs envies c'est
à dire que l'on part du principe que si
vous avez envie d'être joaillier on va
pas vous demander d'être faire du btp
par contre ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on
va faire découvrir des métiers à nos
salariés c'est à dire qu'on va organiser
des rencontres avec des entreprises en
interne de l'entreprise c'est à dire ce
qu'on va chercher à détecter ces les
capacités et les habilités que les gens
ont de façon innée ou ont développé dans
nos structures et dans quel type de
métier ils peuvent aller les exercer et
donc il ya peut-être des métiers
auxquels il pensait pas du tout et donc
si on voit des gens qui sont minutieux
qui sont précis ben on va aller chercher
des métiers en tension avec pôle emploi
on va dire dans ce domaine là il ya des
tensions donc qu'est ce qu'une
entreprise recrute donc on va venir
demander à l'entreprise de venir se
présenter elle va être bien contents de
souvent parce qu'elle a du mal à trouver
et puis peut-être et puis on va envoyer
les gens une semaine dans l'entreprise
ils vont découvrir ils vont voir comment
ça se passe et si ça leur plaît et va on
va monter soit un parcours qualifiant
avec l'entreprise ou avec pôle emploi de
façon à ce qu'ils aient un emploi
derrière est ce que vous dites aussi et
ça c'est très très important de le
souligner par exemple vous avez vous
beaucoup de deux grandes entreprises qui
sont vos clients pour pour les intruses
de paquetages enfers de nad le
conditionnement 10 seulement et vous
dites il se bat il s'adresse pas à tous
parce qu'on fait de l'insertion et ses
vassaux nous parce qu'on fait du bon du
beau boulot c'est ça c'est important de
le dire eh oui s'ils viennent nous
chercher nos clientes conditionnement à
façon ou les particuliers chez lesquels
on va envoyer des gens pour faire du
ménage si vous on vous envoie une femme
de ménage je n'ai pas envie que le
ménage soit fait à moitié sénile ce soit
bien fait donc nous on va apprendre
cette exigence à nos salariés aux
personnes en insertion parce que de
toute façon ce serait pas entre
guillemets 106 nos clients il venait par
charité chrétienne ou charité je sais
pas laquelle donc l'objectif c'est
d'offrir une même prestation de service
qu'à n'importe que n'importe quelle
entreprise mais avec des gens en
insertion c'est ça le challenge
c'est quoi le juste pour la différence
du fait de la formation et de
l'insertion c'est quoi la différence
entre la formation et l'insertion
justement alors nous on fait surtout de
la forme alors on fait de la cession par
la forme et à la formation puisque et
ont fait la différence entre formation
et l'insertion c2 alors que nos
différents je pense qu'il ça cette
insertion
comprend deux volets un premier volet
qui est vraiment la réadaptation ou
l'adaptation au monde du travail de
l'entreprise ou ou autre ne sait pas
toujours des entreprises en soit ça peut
être du travail eux justement chez les
gens et c'est à domicile et puis la
partie véritablement formation qui est
acquisition de compétences pour occuper
un emploi justement donc ces deux choses
qui sont obligatoires voilà qui se
rejoignent obligatoire mort est
d'ailleurs on est allé voir ce qui
commence à se passer ici à son tour
stello formation pour la formation donc
deux de personnes dans le domaine de
l'hôtellerie la restauration
et c'est un reportage de mathilde de
franck ou
créés par des restaurateurs stello
formation existe depuis 1967 ici à
chanteloup-les-vignes le centre s'est
implanté en 2018 un établissement pour
dispenser les formations en hôtellerie
et en restauration des formations à
destination de salariés mais aussi pour
l'insertion professionnelle avec une
douzaine de formation par an pour les
jeunes et les adultes on a beaucoup de
ces apps et qui par leurs difficultés ne
n'ont pas la possibilité de s'inscrire à
eragny dans une école hôtelière parce
que justement il y à cette lacune en
français qui fait qu' aucune école
va les prendre sauf que mme hanoune le
prend on leur apprend le métier ils ont
une entreprise et on a un taux de
réussite de 80% à l'examen des personnes
éloignées de l'emploi qui souhaitent
intégrer la restauration collective
d'antiques manger à la maison xi élever
mes enfants donc après ils sont tous
rentrés à l'école donc je voudrais
reprendre un travail donc je voulais pas
un travail trop compliqué par rapport
aux horaires par rapport à mes enfants
donc la fondation assez collective
rentrer dans mes dans mes critères moi
je travaille dans l'optique de permettre
à ce public
d'obtenir des savoir faire des
compétences et pour pouvoir trouver
travail après ça ma satisfaction c'est
de savoir que j'ai des gens qui viennent
jeunes ou moins jeunes ont fait
apprentis on fait aussi des adultes
donc de différents horizons et leur
permette d'accéder à un diplôme voilà
donc d'obtenir les nouvelles compétences
et surtout derrière un travail ici les
apprentis se forment en conditions semi
réel l'établissement dispose d'un
restaurant d'application pouvant
accueillir 20 couverts il permet
d'intégrer les premiers gestes en
restauration ce jour là deux groupes en
pratique un groupe en cuisine et un
autre en salle ce restaurant permet aux
apprenants de faire les premiers gestes
en restauration de faire la mise en
place du restaurant il faut savoir que
ce restaurant est ouvert deux jours par
semaine à la clientèle extérieure donc
cette jeune personne justement elle est
en train de préparer l'eau chaude elle
va mettre un peu de vinaigre et elle va
policiers tout ce qui est vert et
couverts on a préparé les couverts pas
ce que voulait nettoyer avant ses skis
couverts assiettes et verres donc on
nettoie avant et ensuite on prépare la
mise en place nous allons passer par la
cuisine
donc ici nous avoue ces messieurs qui
sont rapprochés policiers les assiettes
et là nous rentrons dans la cuisine ici
nous avons un groupe aussi se fait par
la production de ce midi donc là le
jeune homme est en train de préparer des
crèmes caramel d'autres sont en train de
préparer des fonds d'état et là bas nous
avons des apprenantes ils sont en train
de préparer les lego pour selon vous ce
groupe par exemple se forment en
linguistique et techniques culinaires en
plus des savoir faire en cuisine des
cours de français sont dispensés pour
les aider à s'insérer
professionnellement principaux critères
pour candidater avoir des notions
d'anglais et surtout être motivé c'est
le cas de cet apprenti pour fins de la
langue française est rasé et aussi pour
faire la cuisine à pain la cuisine des
bases fausses et la restauration cuisine
première des choses est la motivation
nous avons pu rencontrer des personnes
ce matin s'ils sont en formation
linguistique et techniques culinaires
ces personnes ne parle pas correctement
france et n'écrivent pas correctement
français mais parce qu'ils sont motivés
par ce métier ils vont justement
acquérir plus facilement
les compétences pour pouvoir travailler
par la suite dans la restauration
collective pendant leur apprentissage
les groupes sont accompagnés par
différents formateurs au programme une
partie pratique pour acquérir les
techniques et une partie théorique pour
transmettre les connaissances de base
nécessaires au métier puisque les
produits parce que des fois il ya des
produits qui connaissent pas
qui ne connaissent pas dans leur pays
d'origine
après ça va être beaucoup la technique
et de farine
doit faire un temps pour tout
à moitié par
[Musique]
mais là
on va partir
je vous laisse chercher cinq étant
fériée en place pesée
le matériel foule aujourd'hui on crée
une sauce principalement avec des
produits de la mer voilà eux
c'est des choses qu'ils n'ont pas
l'habitude de faire du coup
je leur apprend les bases
[Musique]
luc bien les choses pour comprendre
comment ça se passe ici on comprend pas
du coup une re re sic flics pour que
commence à se faire
en gros c'est quand même assez technique
donc c'est vrai qu' on est en guerre on
a un magazine beaucoup donc après ils
sont là aussi va premier rassurer si on
fait une petite erreur ou quoi que ce
soit pour nous dire si on fait bien ou
pas bien on leur montre une fois après
c'est à eux de faire est bon pour pour
que ça rentre vraiment bien on est là
que j'ai quand ça va pas de troupes qui
s'en sortent très bien c'est des gens
qui sont souvent un peu éloigné du
parcours scolaire traditionnel donc il
faut arriver à les motiver sur le cours
théorique en faisant peut-être une
participation un peu plus active au sein
du court ce c'est pas leur truc alors
par contre ils s'épanouissent beaucoup
sur les savoir faire et c'est l'objectif
de toute façon monsieur on les forme
pour des métiers pour l'heure le centre
stylo formation de chanteloup-les-vignes
dispose d'une capacité d'accueil de 70 à
90 personnes des travaux devrait
s'opérer cette année pour doubler la
capacité d'accueil
et donc on l'a on a bien compris qu'il y
avait là formation il est aussi
l'insertion mais à quel public vous
adresser directement vous alors non
s'adresse un peu à tous les publics
puisque on forme aussi bien des gens qui
sont déjà salariés qui travaillent dans
des entreprises et qui veulent grandir
dans cette entreprise mais aussi à des
gens qui sont demandeurs d'emploi vous
voir très très éloignées de l'emploi et
pas forcément au stade où ils demandent
un emploi mais plutôt au stade précédent
où il cherche quelque chose à faire et
puis et à se remettre dans une vie
peut-être plus normal par rapport aux
aux codes qu'on a nous notre vocation
c'est pas tellement de faire de
l'insertion même si finalement on y
arrive notre vocation c'est de ces
d'apporter aux entreprises d'hôtellerie
de restauration voire de touristes mais
c'est vrai qu'ici c'est un peu moins
d'apporter la manoeuvre dont ils ont
besoin du coup forcément eh bien on va
chercher tout le monde et il n'y a pas
de frein il n'y a pas il n'y a pas des
gens qui peuvent et des gens qui peuvent
pas il ya des gens qui ont envie et
d'autres qui en ont pas envie en tout
cas pas de ces métiers là est ce que
c'est vous qui allez les chercher où ce
serait de qui viennent vous voir j'ai
envie de dire les deux alors on va les
chercher beaucoup quand même à meilhan
et on a des demandes spontanées mais on
a beaucoup de partenariat avec tous les
acteurs justement de l'emploi de
l'insertion
et puis on fait de l'apprentissage donc
on a des jeunes aussi
co2 plutôt d'aider des femmes ou des
hommes vous s'est réparti à peu près on
s'est réparti à partir dans les métiers
de sa débandade des métiers mais
peut-être de fable jean-françois non
nous paradoxalement on a la chance
d'avoir des métiers parce que
l'insertion par l'activité économique
sous lens et des métiers pour les hommes
1 et là on a la chance sur les activités
économiques qu'on porte sur le
conditionnement où la collecte et le tri
des vêtements ou la revente des
vêtements d'occasion ce 60 à 70% des
emplois sont des emplois féminins il est
des choses qui sont souvent assez rare
en termes de service avertit vite et
économique donc c'est d'autant plus
riches d'avoir ses activités ici
virginie viger parmi les personnes qui
sont passées pas parce que vous qu'il ya
des parcours comme ça que vous riez
évoqué pour nous raconter un peu ce que
deviennent des eaux ah oui et les y
aider enfin il ya de très belles
réussites moi je dis que tout est une
réussite mais il ya des très belles
réussites on ad on a des des anciens qui
ont qui ont obtenu à la suite de
formation chez nous et de parcours donc
d'insertion qui ont obtenu des cdi dans
des très belles entreprises on a un un
serveur je crois au marriott
champs-elysées par exemple qui a obtenu
un cdi on était très clair
on a on en a un autre qui est un cdi au
train bleu donc au restaurant du train
bleu gare de lyon qui a encore une belle
maison comme on dit dans notre métier
dans les métiers de l'hôtellerie et de
la restauration
un cuisinier par exemple
à l'hôtel renaissance à la défense donc
ouais on ad on a des belles réussites
dont on est très fiers vous les suivez
vous les suivez sur le long terme
alors on les suit oui on va évidemment
on prend des nouvelles et puis c'est
vrai que comme on existe depuis très
longtemps puisqu'on était si on est
installé que depuis 98 à chanteloup on
est une association qui existe depuis
1967 donc on a on voit revenir
les anciens qui viennent faire la
formation suivante voilà pour devenir
chef de cuisine pour devenir parce que
vous avez des retours de gens qui
justement qui eux sont passés par là et
qui reviennent chez vous pour pouvoir
former les autres oui absolument on en a
on en a on a beaucoup de formateurs qui
sont des anciens de chez nous qui ont
été les chéneaux
quelquefois en apprentissage mais
quelquefois en formation adulte
jean-françois l'utah si vous osiez val
de seine saint louis alors chez nous
nous ce qui nous plaît ce qu'on cherche
à créer c'est qu'on replace les gens
l'extérieur c'est faire en sorte que les
gens se
enfin après je veux dire c'est un peu
idyllique il ya toujours des choses
difficiles mais ce qu'on aime bien c'est
les sa et qui reviennent
presque mandatés par leur patron en
disant vas voir au relais où va voir la
différence soit déficit a pas quelqu'un
parce qu'on a besoin de recruter à
sabine et ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose qu'on aime bien en particulier on
aime bien dans les compagnies de bus
local ou dans les entreprises du coin ça
on en aime bien faire ça et après c'est
pareil l'encadrement chez nous les
trois-quarts de l'encadrement sont des
gens qui étaient en insertion qui sont
restés par philosophie parce qu'il
voulait mettre leur pierre à l'édifice
de l'entreprise et donc ils sont montés
pour devenir responsable et on les a
formés on lan les accompagner au tour de
st voilà après il ya des cas aussi un
peu rigolo il ya une fille comme cité
des exemples
une jeune femme qui est arrivé chez nous
de l'étranger sans rien et en liant
l'avait aidée à obtenir des papiers pour
le coup quelquefois ça arrive qu'on
fasse ça avec les communautés emmaüs
locales l est de l a vendu des vêtements
en magasin elle est partie sur un
parcours de formation qualifiante parce
qu'elle voulait être infirmière
et puis finalement on l'a perdue du new
après c'est fini la partie et puis dix
ans après là nous appelait il ya trois
mois aujourd'hui elle est devenue nos
thérapeutes et donc à la div si vous
voulez je sais ce que l'hypnose peut
apporter pour la confiance en soi des
gens donc je vous propose de venir faire
des heures pour les salariés en
insertion pour dire merci de ce que
j'avais reçues donc ça c'est en trouvé
ça super chouette quoi parce qu'on n'y
est pour rien et ça revient tout seul
quand c'est
presque des cadeaux ou quoi oui c'est un
cadeau c'est quand je vivais ça a dit
ben voilà c'est pour ça qu'on fait ce
truc là même si on n'avait rien demandé
quoi puissent bénéficier au genre
d'insertion serait super et puis il ya
des il ya des emplois dans l'hôtellerie
la restauration évidemment c'est un même
s'est même dit on un secteur on n'arrive
pas à fournir les besoins et la demande
mais alors cela pour le coup c'est vrai
que la crise sanitaire a fait du mal et
que le secteur a perdu beaucoup beaucoup
de d'employés et qui font des gros
efforts maintenant pour pour en gagner
de nouveaux mais oui alors là pour le
coup on est sur des on est sur des
secteurs où il ya de l'emploi enfin on
peut vraiment y aller
on a beaucoup de demandes est sûr de
trouver dont on est sûr de trouver et
puis nous reçoit beaucoup beaucoup de
demandes de fadettes offres d'emploi de
d'entreprise un mot il ya beaucoup de
gens qui viennent de l'étranger
il ya parfois des problèmes de langues
une barrière de la langue ah ben oui il
ya souvent une barrière de la langue
et on forme à chanteloup par exemple sur
un parcours qui est extrêmement
intéressant qui est linguistique et
techniques professionnelles alors à
chanteloup ce qu'on fait c'est sur les
techniques professionnelles c'est des
techniques culinaires ils ont sur la
moitié du temps de la linguistique donc
du français et sur l'autre moitié du
temps des techniques les premières
techniques qui vont leur permettre
d'être utile et opérationnels
directement dans une cuisine
parcours qui leur permet essentiel
absolument c'est vital pour pour
travailler il faut qu'on parle la langue
de son patron jean françois parent c'est
une vraie difficulté d'un défi servir
plus là on va démarrer au mois d'avril
des séances de formation de français
parce que quand vous allez chez les
particuliers que le particulier laisse
des consignes sur un peu sur un carnet
vous me l'avez ça vous nettoyer sans
premier vingt faut être capable de lire
de comprendre de retranscrire un minimum
et dans les structures d'activités enfin
son relais aux espérances c'est pareil
quand nous on est très participatif dans
le mode de fonctionnement donc en fait
c'est important que les gens puissent
comprendre apporté leur pierre et on
considère que quand on fait une réunion
il ya dix cerveaux c'est plus malin que
le seul cerveau du responsable donc on
essaye de mobiliser sa et du coup le
français c'est une vraie difficulté est
donc on donne des cours de français et à
côté pour les gens qui souhaitent en
prendre et c'est bien à cette baptisé
parce qu'on est voilà des gens qui sort
dans l'investissement pour les autres
c'est formidable bravo hein
c'est vrai mais c'est surtout merci de
faire connaître parce que c'est pas très
connu qui est qu'ils aient fait wind
absolue grand moi ce que vraiment c'est
en leaders chose c'est que
juste apprendre à regarder les gens et
l'autre parce qu'il sait faire et par
ses qualités pas par ces problèmes et je
pense que si on regardait les gens qui
arrivent là en ce moment il y en a
partout qui arrive mais il y en avait
déjà d'autres avant et 1 aura d'autres
demain si on les regarde juste parce
qu'ils s'affairent et plutôt parce que
plutôt que les regarder par le problème
qu'on nous mais on a zéro pourrait poser
je pense que sl faudrait la changer
c'est ce que disait pierre cardo
d'ailleurs il parlait de resituer l'être
humain ensemble du débat à chaque fois
et on est en plein dedans l'implant
véritablement prendre en compte ce dont
ils ont envie et tout à l'heure mais le
métier dont ils ont envie ce qu'ils ont
envie de faire de leur vie et ça c'est
très important merci merci beaucoup à
tous les deux un autre moyen de retour
vers l'emploi ce sont les clauses
d'insertion les clauses d'insertion ça
joue sur les marchés avec des appels
d'offres et on va en parler avec teresa
machado qui et facilitatrice g activity
et qui explique ce que se sont justement
ces clauses d'insertion
[Musique]
c'est un dispositif juridique
donc il faut faire à la commande
publique
dès lors que vous avez un marché public
ou privé les maîtres double des maîtres
d'ouvragé pardon peuvent inclure de la
clause d'insertion
c'est à dire que vous avez une partie
des heures travaillées qui vont être
réservés aux publics éloignés de
l'emploi et ce sont les entreprises
attributaires de ces marchés qui vont
recruter ces personnes là
pour de la montée en compétence pour
qu'ils aient accès à de la formation à
de la qualification et au delà donc à un
emploi pérenne
[Musique]
je vais vous donner un exemple concret
inquiets qui est assez récent donc sur
un de mes marché une entreprises
attributaires
avait pour volonté de de trouver des
personnes via la clause d'insertion
faire du recrutement mais pérenne
donc elle souhaité
elle cherchait des profils d'être
offreurs c'est un métier qui est très
attention
du coup l'idée s'est posée
la question s'est posée de pourquoi pas
faire une formation et avec l'aide d'une
structure d'insertion locale nous avons
fait un contrat de professionnalisation
durant un an pour cette personne est au
bout de ses douze mois c'est cinq
personnes sur sept ont obtenu un cd via
l'entreprise et la clause d'insertion
donc là c'est un parcours d'insertion
qui fonctionne des personnes qui sont
éloignés de l'emploi qui sont formés
pendant un an sur des métiers en tension
et qui aujourd'hui sont en cdi sur des
chantiers soit avec la clause
d'insertion soit hors pose d'insertion
ça leur permet d'avoir ce recrutement
qu'elle ne trouve pas obligatoirement et
que et nous nous sommes en contact avec
tous ses partenaires locaux que ce soit
le pôle emploi la mission locale les
pôle insertion du département toutes les
structures d'insertion locale du
territoire donc ce qui leur permet
justement d'obtenir le recrutement qu'il
ne trouve pas ailleurs
[Musique]
on
retrouve à ouvrir une nouvelle séquence
témoignages absolument avec deux invités
qu'on est ravie de recevoir dans leurs
dames bonjour
j'ai deux invités ses dosettes deux
enfants si je peux dire de chanteloup et
vous allez parler justement de cette
offense passé on change tout ce qui a
changé dans ce paysage dans vos vies
d'al wahda vous êtes vous êtes étudiante
en dut de techniques de
commercialisation à cergy pontoise c'est
ça et finale at il dit bonjour bonjour
vous êtes vous êtes adjointe à catherine
arnould merde de chanteloup les vignes
en charge de la jeunesse tout afin et
puis vous travaillez aussi par ailleurs
je suis pas vous travaillez vous pouvez
le fait je travaille chez un géant de la
tech
voilà un gars femmes enfin
merci donc se disait vous avez vous aidé
les deux vécu ici grandi ici toutes les
deux dans la de la cité de la noé oui
absolument ouais alors raconté
ya pas si longtemps
je vais bien commencé donc en fait je
suis arrivé à chanteloup en 1991 donc je
suis né à paris mes parents résidaient
au coeur de la cité donc à la place du
parc donc pas très très loin d'ici et
j'ai fait toute ma scolarité sur sur la
ville maternelle mon élémentaire le
collège j'ai eu la chance d'aller dans
les mains sur les deux collèges de
fréquenter les deux collèges et par la
suite j'ai été au lycée à conflans
sainte honorine donc en lycée général en
seconde générale et suite à cela je me
suis enfin en études supérieures je suis
partie un petit peu plus loin parce que
j'avais envie de voir autre chose j'ai
été jusqu'à sarcelles et j'ai suivi des
études en commerce international
en bas alors moi chine et en 2003 donc
ça fait pas très longtemps effectivement
je suis à chanteloup depuis toujours
donc moi j'habite aussi dans le quartier
de la noé juste derrière la crèche et
j'ai aussi fait ma scolarité ici donc
l'école maternelle
élémentaire à arthur rimbaud et j'ai
fait le collège rené cassin et suite à
cela je suis allé au lycée à poissy moi
pas à conflans au corbusier où j'ai fait
un bac général aussi et là maintenant je
suis à l'université de cergy alors cet
enfant c'est dans ce quartier dans ce
quartier raconter d'où qu'est ce qui
vous a marqué par exemple alors masse
qui va marquer c'est vrai que c'est la
diversité en tout cas des des
populations qui sont représentés mois il
faut savoir que mes parents sont enfin
mon père est arrivé dans les années 60
en france
on a été élevé
par le haut par nos deux parents en tout
cas au contact de populations diverses
et variées ce qui a je pense aussi forgé
notre notre identité donc c'est vrai que
c'est très important en tout cas de ne
pas oublier toutes ces choses là on a
fréquenté l'école publique on a vu
évoluer le quartier donc évoluer avec la
rénovation urbaine donc c'est vrai que
ce sont différentes failles parce que
quand nous arrivons dans les années 80
on est assez pas la même année 80 90 a
été lésé d un peu plus difficile
peut-être pour chanteloup à titre perso
moi je n'ai pas senti comme ça parce que
vraiment il y avait vraiment si vous
voulez cette solidarité quand même entre
entre les uns et les autres donc ça
c'est quand même quelque chose qui était
qui était assez remarquable et moi j'ai
des amis d'enfance que j'ai encore
aujourd'hui que je garde et c'est vrai
qu'il ya une relation de proximité en
tout cas qui se lit entre les uns et les
autres qui n'est pas négligeable donc et
comment vous viviez vous à l'époque le
votre environnement comment quel regard
vous aviez sûr sûr sûr votre
environnement à ce moment là le regard
que j'avais je pense que c'est celui
d'une enfant qui qui évoluent dans un
environnement qui est assez qui est
assez vaste et varié après c'est vrai
que je trouvais qu'ils avaient des
choses qui manquaient quand même au
niveau des équipements mais bon ça c'est
dû à la halle haas à la conception et à
la taille de la ville j'imagine et c'est
bien pour ça que pour faire les études
supérieures par exemple moi j'ai fait le
choix en tout cas de m'éloigner un petit
peu même si j'adore j'avais pu j'aurais
pu partir a par exemple saint germain en
laye pour faire mon bts commerce
international mais j'avais envie de voir
autre chose en fait est ce qui explique
le fait que je me suis permise de marc
de barrières si vous voulez et au même
titre que quand j'ai dû faire mon bts en
commerce international j'étais
consciente qu'il fallait deux langues
donc l'anglais et l'espagnol ce sont des
gens que j'aimais beaucoup et j'avais
l'obligation en tout cas de faire un
stage à l'étranger donc ce stage à
l'étranger c'est vrai que je vous cache
pas que c'était une période commun qui
était assez difficile parce que j'avais
pas de réseau et en fait ça on arrive là
vous n'avez pas de réseau et en fait
c'est une rencontre fortuite moment par
pur hasard dans le rer b qui a fait que
j'ai trouvé un stage en fait à
l'étranger d'accord voilà et j'ai pu
aller au met à new york donc de
chanteloup à new york moi je trouve que
c'est quand même un grand pas mal donc
pas mal mais j'ai une question justement
parce que beaucoup de joueurs il ya
l'image des quartiers qui pèse souvent
on retrouve à ma part yves qui pèse
moins quand on voit new york parce que
new york qui savent pas ce que c'est
chaud cloud donc non ils savent pas ce
que c'est mais je veux dire il ya autre
chose aussi jeudi à new york et à ces
ghettos il ya aussi des ghettos à new
york il ya aussi des guides qui a pas
que time square donc l'envers du décor
on le voit on le voit très vite quand on
va dans certains quartiers comme le
bronx où comme le queens et moi en
l'occurrence j'étais dans le bronx
ggt je me suffis de fait un climat t'es
peut-être parce que j'ai peut-être
trouver des similitudes mais finalement
je me dis qu'en france on n'est
peut-être pas c'est pas plus mal parce
que le le rêve américain en fait c'est
bien dans les films c'est bien pour les
vacances mais pour y vivre il ya une
contrainte en fait il ya des choses
qu'il ya des avantages qu'on a ici et
qu'on n'a pas là bas si on regarde ne
serait-ce qu'au niveau de la santé je
pense que le problème de santé il est il
est très important et la couverture la
couverture globale à ma main
plus intéressante et plus facile en tout
cas ici est accessible surtout en tant
que jeune femme est ce que
sur la question de la sécurité ce que
vous êtes toujours sentais en sécurité
ici est-ce que parfois aidé des choses
un peu plus difficiles à vivre
personnellement si je dois me prononcer
par rapport à ça c'est vrai que sur
chanteloup je me sens quand même plutôt
en sécurité parce que il faut pas se
mentir c'est un garde c'est un quartier
assez petit donc en fait la plupart des
gens se connaissent et on a en fait ce
sentiment de solidarité et on se dit
qu'on se connaît tous on est un peu
comme une grande famille en fait donc
forcément ce sont en sécurité on sait
que juste en regardant à droite à gauche
on va avoir quelques personnes qu'on
connaît donc ça devrait aller et c'est
parce qu'on a en dehors de chanteloup
quoi quand on sort au combat sur paris
on sent que c'est complètement différent
c'est marrant d'ailleurs parce que plein
peu plus plus en plus inquiète à paris
qu'avec ici quoi oui largement alors
justement c'est parce que souvent les
gens ont un regard sur les quartiers en
disant que c'est archi dangereux moi je
veux pas habiter là-bas et en fait quand
vous habitez un quartier où vous êtes
beaucoup plus en sécurité dans ces
quartiers là que quand vous allez dans
le 16e arrondissement parce que mais
même ici c'était assez on râle quand
est-ce parce que c'est temps quelqu'un
même si quelqu'un vous agresse ici il y
aura toujours quelqu'un pour vous
défendre alors que quand vous êtes
ailleurs c'est encore autre chose donc
il ya tout quand on parle de l'image des
quartiers c'est aussi ça c'est ce
fantasme qui est véhiculée par certains
et c'est bien que vous en témoigner et
puis je pense que au delà de ça c'est
peut-être aussi de stéréotypes et de
c'est la perception en fait oui le jeu
de bons parce qu'il ya peut-être
justement ces questions que se posent
les gens gèrent qui peut être qui vient
de l'externe et c'est sûr qu'on va pas
avoir le même regard qu'une personne qui
a grandi en fête au coeur de ce quartier
qui se dit finalement il ya des choses
qui se font il ya des choses qui se font
bien on a un tissu associatif qui est
indéniable qui qui a joué un rôle majeur
en tout cas pendant toute cette bande
est et au delà de ça je pense que la
solidarité s est vraiment fait avec tous
les acteurs c'est pas ça c'est pas fait
de chacun de son côté il ya des gens qui
étaient confrontés je pense aussi à la
fracture numérique qui ont pu être aidés
donc ça c'est quand même important aussi
de le souligner doc des rixes et des
quartiers dans lequel viennent se fasse
en tout il y un radiateur rencontrer
d'autres gens qui venaient d'autres
communautés d'ailleurs pas
aussi à huy totalement totalement parce
que si ça parce qu'il ya dix ans enfin
il ya un petit écart on trouvait de tout
ça aurait pu changer il ya 20 ans
ce que je voudrais souligner c'est ce
qu'il faut pas oublier en tout cas c'est
que il ya aussi l'idée de la précarité
donc oui à des ja de la précarité donc
ça c'est des choses qu'il faut pas
oublier il ya des gens invisibles les
personnes qu'on voit pas et aujourd'hui
en tout cas notre action sociale allez
allez allez
elle est beaucoup aller très dirigé en
tout cas sur la solidarité très axé
là-dessus et je pense qu'on était voilà
on a su montrer qu'on savait faire même
si on n'a pas beaucoup de moyens donc
voilà ça c'est des choses à mettre en
évidence en question le regard justement
que que les autres peuvent avoir peux
vous poser sur les gens qui sont qui
sont qui viennent de ces quartiers ou
qui viennent de champclos par exemple
pour vous est-ce que vous avez été
confronté
lors de recherches de stages ou de
grandes entreprises gaffe à ce que vous
venez de chanteloup à lausanne de parler
ou pas ou peut-être que dans les
entreprises comme ça qu'ils sont plus
modernes on s'en fout complètement ce
qui n'est pas le cas forcément des
reprises plus classique là écoutez moi
j'ai pas commencé chez un gars femme en
fait j'ai commencé dans le milieu
bancaire donc c'est vrai que c'est aussi
un milieu qui est très comment dire
pardon auditionnait additionnel mais
j'étais pas dans une banque
traditionnelle j'étais dans une banque
privée libanaise donc c'est aussi ses
autres c'est notre culture d'entreprise
on va dire mais
c'est vrai qu'on a on a ce sentiment
peut-être de ne pas être comme les
autres mais je m'en suis jamais servi je
m'en suis plus servi comme une force on
va dire que qu'autre chose donc moi j'ai
pas j'ai jamais eu à si vous voulez à
modifier peut-être mon adresse sur mon
cv alors je sais que ça peut arriver
quand on vient d'une dune but il
certaines villes ça pour ça
le nom aussi peut porter préjudice mais
voilà j'ai toujours en tout cas eu coeur
à aller au delà de ça et de me dire que
oui bah écoutez si la paire 6 estiment
que je que je ne leur convient pas du
fait de ma personnalité de mon identité
j'irai voir ailleurs en tout cas je vais
vous avez une personnalité vous
au delà des clivages mais voilà je dis
ça aujourd'hui parce que moi en fait mon
père c'est une personne qui a qui était
éboueur en fait à la ville de paris donc
je viens d'un milieu modeste et même
s'il était pas lecteur enfin mais c'est
même si mes parents n'étaient pas
lecteurs en tout cas nous ont toujours
donné cette envie de voilà de faire ce
qu'on a envie de faire et de deux voiles
à deux pas avoir à subir en fait vous
êtes resté vosgien dans une famille unie
c'est ça absolument et ne l'ont doit
aussi moi au départ oui après mes
parents se sont séparés mais j'ai
toujours continué à avoir mon père est
pas tout comme cnao franchement ma mère
m a vraiment toujours donné en fait
cette force en fait de toujours aller
plus loin et de dépasser le fait d'être
juste une enfant de banlieue en fait
donc ça m'a beaucoup aidé et ça m'aide
toujours et ça me motive en fait pour la
suite mais est-ce que j'ai pour la
question que pose et brosse total est ce
que vous vous la fait remarquer parfois
vous étiez une enfant de banlieue on ne
l'a pas vraiment fait remarquer je pense
que le nom change où il réside toujours
dans certains esprits donc forcément
ceux qui lisent mon cv je suis pas avec
eux je sais pas vraiment ce qu'ils
pensent on a peut-être certains qui ont
ce qu'ils se sont dit que ça en valait
pas la peine mais moi ça me freine pas
en tout cas
quelle énergie
finale après
donc vous êtes engagé
politiquement puisque je disais vous
êtes adjointe au maire en charge de la
jeunesse
c'était quoi pour vous êtes cette forme
d'engagement et goûter mois déjà avant
d'être engagé politiquement j'étais
parents d'élèves
j'ai en fait ce que j'ai oublié de dire
que j'ai trois enfants en fait voilà
j'ai trois garçons et g dames 14 on non
donc j'en ai on dit ces gens nés en
collège et j'en ai en maternelle et si
vous voulez être déjà engagé en tant que
parent je trouve que c'est important
parce que ça permet en tout cas de voilà
de voir comment on peut suivre la
scolarité de nos enfants voir je veux
dire ce qu'on peut apporter en tant que
contribution enfin voilà ça peut être
des choses simples mais en tout cas la
relation avec l'école je trouve que
c'est quelque chose de voilà
d'indispensable donc moi j'ai été déjà
engagée en tant que parent donc pendant
plus d'une dizaine d'années après j'ai
eu la chance en fait d'être conseil
citoyen de la ville de chanteloup qu'il
ya un conseil citoyen le conseil citoyen
ses conseils à voilà qui s'était mis en
place en 2015 dans le cadre du contrat
de ville et c'est vrai que moi j'étais
déjà assez porter en tout cas sur les
sujets qui étaient relatifs à la
jeunesse à la scolarité et voilà en tout
cas l'égalité des chances parce que je
trouve que aujourd'hui avoir des enfants
qui sont pas lecteur ou qui ont des
lacunes voilà cc c'est juste pas
possible en tout cas faut voir en tout
cas ce qui peut être mis en oeuvre pour
pouvoir les aider les accompagner et je
sais que sur la commune en tout cas il
ya pas mal de choses qui sont mises en
oeuvre par le biais de la réussite
éducative et parlent parlent tissu aussi
associatif donc voilà je trouve que
c'est la combinaison de tous ces
éléments en tout cas qui fait que ça
peut ça peut contribuer même s'il ya des
enfants qu'on n'arrive pas à toucher
mais en tout cas le but c'est de voilà
de voir de toucher le maximum est de
renverser la tendance pour que l'égalité
des chances justement elles soient tous
les niveaux et papa que réserve est
incertain alors il ya quand même un mal
souvent dans
dick est pointée du doigt dans les
quartiers c'est le fait que les gens ne
s'intéressent pas à la politique et ne
votent pas par exemple or on sait que
les politiques qui comprennent qu'une
chose c'est le racket électorale
est ce qu'il ya des initiatives qui sont
mises en place ici justement pour que
les jeunes s'impliquent
pas qui d'ailleurs qu'il soit que
simples électeurs parce que c'est bien
d'aller voter de temps en temps pour des
gens mais mais pour qu'ils s'impliquent
aussi en politique et qui comprennent
les enjeux est-ce que vous avez désigné
at il des initiatives en fait on a hâte
de le faire peut-être trois ans ou
quatre ans on a le cme donc le conseil
municipal des enfants qui existent donc
c'est à dire qu'on sensibilise les
jeunes de cm2 cm1 et cm2 voilà au fait
de mener des projets qui peuvent être
sûrs différend porté sur différents
thèmes en fait la solidarité la culture
les seniors est en fait voilà il ya un
groupe d'enfants qui est élu par qui
sont élus par leurs camarades
par par école en fait et c'est axé sur
la parité c'est à dire qu'il faut qu'ils
aient une fille et un garçon pour leur
montrer que voilà un moment donné il ya
il ya toute une procédure en tout cas
qui se fait comme dans le cadre
d'élections anormal et c'est une façon
je pense aussi de sensibiliser dès le
plus jeune âge en tout cas à ce sens à
cette citoyenneté et voir comment en
tout cas ils peuvent ils peuvent après
évolué dans le temps là dans la sphère
après sont ils sont obligés de continuer
en fait mais en tout cas ça leur donne
une première impression est là je sais
qu'on ambitionne aussi de mettre en
place et au clj donc un conseil
municipal des jeunes est pareil qui
seront qui sera qui s'adressera à une
tranche un peu plus âgé après pour le
problème de dudu du vote enfin de
l'absence de l'absentéisme je pense que
il ya pas mal de gens qui sont peut-être
qu'ils comprennent peut-être pas pas
toujours les messages en tout cas de nos
politiques et il ya peut-être en tout
cas quelque chose à faire là dessus pour
réinstaurer en tout cas le débat le
débat autour des certaines valeurs où
certaines notions de l'endroit vous
sentez vous un tiré par justement cette
avoir des déchets par un rôle dans la
vie de la cité
et bien moi je pense que ça pourrait
être vraiment une bonne idée le conseil
municipal des jeunes parce que c'est
vrai que les jeunes de notre âge enfin
moi j'ai 18 ans on n'est pas on se sent
vraiment pas pas impliqué dans tout ce
qui est politique etc et c'est vrai
c'est pas qu'on comprend pas vraiment le
message mais en fait on cherche en fait
cette appartenance en fait un parti ou à
une personne politique tout simplement
en fait quelqu'un qui nous prend en
compte en fait dans son discours parce
que le oui parce que le vrai défi il est
là ce sont ceux qui sont éloignés de la
chose publique en tant que tel c'est
parce c'est vrai qu'il faut faire un
vrai travail ou à l'école pour pour qu'
il y ait des le plus jeune à cette
culture surtout que souvent dans les
familles d'ailleurs y'a pas cette
culture politique elle y est d'ailleurs
elle est souvent présente mais elle est
présente à travers les émissions les
parents souvent ils parlent de ça mais
pas en tant qu'électeur et du coup c'est
pas un geste naturel et l'école joue un
rôle mais ce public est un peu éloigné
est ce que vous pensez pas qu'il ya
quelque chose à faire justement et quels
sont les quels sont les éléments
qu'elles sont qu'est-ce qu'on peut
mettre en oeuvre pour aller chercher
justement ces jeunes d'après vous vous
qui avez 18 ans par exemple les gens qui
ne s'intéressent pas grand chose comment
on va les chercher comment on peut aller
leur parler
moi je pense qu'ils aient déjà faudrait
commencer ça au collège enfin à l'école
l'école élémentaire et au collège
surtout parce que là on est un ajout
voilà on est capable de raisonner seul
et d'avoir un esprit critique je pense
au collège
on a des cours d'éducation morale et
civique donc ça c'est déjà bien on est
français en fait se rapprocher en fait
de deux le futur citoyen en fait qu'on
va être plus tard et je pense qu'il
devrait être un peu plus approfondie
quand même parce qu'on on n'y est pas
encore finie at il justement vous êtes
adjointe à la jeunesse c'est quoi les
les demandes au fond d'eux des jeunes
de chanteloup justement à ce niveau là
bon là ça fait que deux ans on va dire
mandat j'ai pas encore enfin il ya des
défis en tout cas que je veux que j'ai
encore et que j'aimerai bien relevé
c'est justement voir quelles pourraient
être les choses en tout cas qui ont du
sens pour pour pour cette jeunesse et et
voir les en tout cas les directions vers
lesquels on pourrait évoluer pour que ça
pour qu'il ya des choses qui leur parle
parce que c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on
met pas mal de choses en place peut-être
pour les fins pour les plus jeunes pour
ceux qui sont au niveau des ados mais au
niveau des plus âgés on a toute la
partie emploi et insertion ou ont fait
de l'accompagnement effectivement sur
leur haut niveau de l'orientation ou au
niveau de l'insertion professionnelle
pour ceux qui sont aussi en décrochage
scolaire ou des choses comme ça mais
après pour ce qui est des projets autant
tout cas moi je compte sur les personnes
comme d'aaland a pour pour être source
de proposition et propositions pour voir
justement pour qu'on fasse des choses
qui leur plaisent et pas qu'ils
subissent en fait parce que sinon ça
passe a pas d'intérêt on a l'impression
que j'ai comme on appelle les habitants
de chanteloup et chanteloup mais je suis
ouvert oui vous êtes des chanteuses
heureuse 1
on va dire oui on va dire oui on est on
est encore là je pense que sinon
seraient déjà partis sinon vous seriez
déjà partie absolument rien et vous il
ya un an par les salles avec pierre
cardo avec
il ya parfois aussi une fierté
d'autres dissidents il ya un attachement
aussi après je pense avec les gens et du
fait de la taille de la de la ville
aussi c'est ce qui fait ça je veux dire
tout le monde a enfin tout le monde se
connaît pratiquement et c'est vrai que
nous on avait cette facilité à passer
d'un d'une place à l'autre quand on
était enfant parent quand j'étais plus
petit parce qu'il n'y avait pas de y
avait pas de route traversant tout
dangereuse et c'est vrai que forcément
en tout cas il y avait ce sentiment de
sécurité de ma part et après je veux
dire c'est comme partout il ya forcément
des
ddd problème mais bon ça c'est pas du
fait de notre de notre commune c'est
voilà c'est la conjoncture
est est ce que vous n'avez pas lu l'envi
à un moment donné de partir d'ici oui
pour vos enfants par exemple
non parce qu'en fait moi si vous voulez
je suis très attaché à ma famille moi
j'ai mes parents qui habitent pas très
loin qui sont à proximité et
et au delà de s'allonger voilà j'ai
souhaité en tout cas privilégier ma
famille que de partir ailleurs et je
veux dire moi j'ai fréquenté comme je le
disais les enfin les l'école publique
enfin de toute ma scolarité et mes
enfants continuent à le faire j'ai pas
j'ai pas
envie d'arriver à ce que j'aurais pu
faire aussi mais avant je pense que en
tout cas quand on fréquente des enfants
issus de divers de divers horizons on
apprend on apprend de l'autre et ça
c'est vrai c'est une vraie richesse
c'est beau c'est bien
formidable magnifique mais elle se voit
là monsieur que voilà c'est ce que
certains d'entre nous on essaie de
défendre depuis un pic des années dans
les médias et ben c'est bien que qui est
des gens qui vivent les choses qui
disent aussi aux autres donc merci
beaucoup pour ces beaux témoignages ont
traversé vos copines abate dit tu
emploies se retrouver avec avec
catherine arnaud absolument peut-être
[Rires]
[Musique]
la légende urbaine dit que jean-louis
borloo prend conscience de l'urgence
lorsqu'il vient ici lorsqu'il rencontre
pierre cardo et découlera de cette
rencontre ce qu'on appelait le plan
borloo
je suis arrivé un
soir de novembre
2012 je crois
j'adore cardo et chez elle va on a fait
le quartier
disais mais je n'ai jamais j'en peux
plus que j'ai l'impression de rêver
c'est que ça se dégrade que ça s'aggrave
puis on va à sa mairie et au moment de
monter jeudi mais comme commenté il dit
mais j'ai pas de moyens jean louis puis
avait deux ampoules une des mines est
allumée et l'autre pas lu mes limites je
n'ai pas les moyens de changer une
ampoule
bonjour catherine r2 est la mère de deux
jours 12 avec vice-présidente socialiste
du conseil départemental
elle marche léopold là maintenant
on est toujours ville pauvre mais les
ampoules marche les six mois tout les
habitants vous diront pas tout et là
c'est une légende urbaine ou pas que au
fond l'idée de la politique de la ville
et le plan borloo cdh ou alors oui jean
louis borloo et ça va il ya toujours dit
attaché au territoire de champclos oui
c'est sans doute les nés ici pour une
première raison c'est que on était quand
même à la fois un symbole et un exemple
de cette de cet urbanisme gigantesque
pas du tout implanté sur le territoire
qui était arrivé comme ça comme un
champignon et mais par contre la ville
était resté à l'échelle humaine et c'est
ce qui d'ailleurs danser dans
l'évolution de cette ville a fait ses
difficultés au départ mes fesses sans
doute une partie de ses réussites ses
l'échelle humaine c'est une ville de
2000 habitants qui est passé de 8000 à
11000 de 11000 à 8000 voilà qui revient
vers 11000 met donc c'est une échelle
qui est une échelle grand village on
c'est vrai que c'est un peu différent
des autres éléments ville de la
politique de la ville 1 et je pense que
jean louis borloo a d'autant plus
facilement même s'ils y étaient
spontanément très près a plus facilement
vu ce qu'on pouvait faire ici c'est
qu'en fait la taille de la ville
permettent si on y met des moyens
importants et si on se si tout le monde
se met en même temps il ya des choses
qui peuvent durablement changer de
territoire c'est beaucoup moins vrai
dans des villes de 50 mille cent mille
habitants effectivement vous où les eaux
libres mais les problèmes sont beaucoup
plus enkystés le problème est prêt je ne
sais pas
c'est que tout est concentré on nous
sommes dans le quartier de la noé un ici
et toute la politique de la ville elle
est concentrée dans ce quartier assez
c'est assez c'est un seul quartier qui
est un quartier dé de logement social
exclusif comme tous les comme tous ces
quartiers de la grande vallée de la
seine dont on vous a raconté toute
l'histoire c'est aussi des quartiers du
logement social avec les populations les
plus fragiles puisque vous avez dans le
logement social on a on a quelques
niveaux et nous on a dans tous les sens
combien la ville de la vallée de la
seine alors donc on a on a eu alors on a
eu jusqu'à 82 % de logement social quand
quand ce bien cardo était maire
et puis après on est passé on est resté
très longtemps entre 82 et 75 et
actuellement on est à 44
vous avez des convictions axa assez
forte sur la question de la politique de
la ville justement vous avez fait partie
de la commission borloo et vous parliez
de ces mesures qui sont éparpillés et
alors que vous dites justement que il
faut à la fois la question de
l'éducation la formation la rénovation
urbaine etc c'est aujourd'hui quand vous
voyez la manière dont ce plan est
utilisée qu est-ce que vous qu'est ce
que vous en dites alors vous avez vu que
ce plan avait été rejeté dans un premier
temps mais quelques me jeter bas oui
effectivement on la vit ensemble
quelques mesures et pas des moindres ont
d'ailleurs ont été reprises mais ont été
reprises les unes derrière les autres
sans vision globale il s'en va là sans
cohésion dans la dans la volonté
politique alors des mesures très
important de la cité éducative
heureusement qu'elles sont sorties et
tous ceux qui n'avaient pas travaillé
dans le club renommé qui ont bénéficié
de ces sites éducatifs disent bien que
celle pratiquement l'alpha et l'oméga de
la nouvelle façon d'orienter et de
travail et l'éducation dans nos
quartiers à la limite je me demande si
ça voudrait pas pour toute la france
mais en attendant sur nos territoires le
principe de dire on nous sommes tous
acteurs de l'éducation c'est à dire que
nous avons tous une part quelle que soit
notre rôle dans une ville nous avons
tous une part il faut que nous fassions
en partenariat en bonne symbiose et
surtout qu'on est comme seul objectif la
réussite de l'enfant quel que soit et
sans qu on est prêts
prédéterminé sa réussite parce que là
réussissent à s'appuie sur ses propres
compétences et donc l'enfant la réussite
qu'on lui permettra d'avoir mais sa
réussite ne sera pas celle du voisin il
sera pas celle qu'on a mis en tant
qu'adulte en temps avec et qu'on après
des prêts décidés à c'est ça le
principal et je trouve qu'ici en plus
tous les acteurs se sont vraiment
mobilisés pour dire on travaillait
ensemble pour la réussite de l'enfant
chacun avec son savoir faire mais on pas
s'appuyant sur d'abord la compétence de
l'enfant et vous avez mêler les deux
puisque il ya le côté scolaire avec la
cité éducative mais le côté urbain
puisque tout tout tout tout est
construit ensemble tous ensemble ouais
alors ça c'est assez exceptionnel
exceptionnel c
oui mais ça c'est super important
d'abord parce que ce territoire cette
école et tous avaient besoin
effectivement qu'on ait un nouveau
regard sur elle et le nouveau regard ça
se fait aussi sur un nouvel urbanisme
avec un nouvel urbanisme et c'est
d'autant plus important qu'en fait on
construit les lieux qui sont une cité
éducative qui inclura maternelles
primaires centres de loisirs une
médiathèque la maison des parents la
maison des familles le collège
la restauration pour tous ont il a été
construit par les propres acteurs
c'est-à-dire que ils ont travaillé
pendant accompagné pendant deux ans
environ pour petit à petit posé les
pions pour que ce qu'est ce qu'on
définit comme lieu de travail en commun
soit vraiment ce qu'ils ont voulu est ce
qui correspond à ce qu'ils ont fabriqué
ensemble comme histoire donc c'est
comment comment on travaille ensemble
père et éducatif et et moi enseignante
dans un même lieu en étant chacun à la
fois chez soi chez l'autre mais toujours
l'enfant chez lui et donc en fait ils
ont fabriqué ils ont mis deux ans à
fabriquer ce cahier des charges pour
fabriquer le lieu à lieu qui est quand
même assez énorme et qui correspondra en
fait à leur action quotidien à leur
fonctionnement quotidien et l'architecte
plié abbas ait de la difficulté était
toute la difficulté lors la difficulté
ça a été d'abord d'accompagner toutes
ces bonnes volontés pour vraiment
travailler pour faire le travail en
commun et que et qu'on soit tous
d'accord après que ce travail est
vraiment en commun qui en a pas une
institution ce qu'on est quand même
entre entre institutions qu'une
institution il ya voilà s'installe plus
que l'autre conçois mais c'est aussi
c'est aussi l'avantagé de ces d'avoir
fait un concours d'architecte ou l'aude
l'architecte savait déjà que sa première
sa proposition qui serait retenu serait
une proposition évolutive donc il a été
retenu en début 2020 et depuis 2020 il
continue à élaborer son projet à faire
avancer son projet en fonction du
travail qui est fait par les différentes
équipes
et voilà on est en train de le poser le
projet là et maintenant on a commencé ce
travail là début 2019 et on le pose me
2022 et avec avec une petite
particularité à chanteloup alors ça on
l'avait on a sauté sur l'occasion parce
qu'on n'avait pas prévu on s'était dit
qu'est ce qu'on fait ce qu'on fait un
travail en un endroit où les enfants
sont encore présents on l'avait déjà
vécu ça c'est super compliqué pour les
enseignants pour les enfants c'est quand
même beaucoup de bouleversements de
démolir à droite reconstruire à gauche
et sur sign on s'est dit on fait table
rase et on trouve un lieu et on fabrique
a lieu un lieu intermédiaire qui va
durer deux à trois ans où ça sera à la
fois le lieu de ce que j'appelle le
brouillon mais équipe en or de ça mais
le brouillon c'est pas c'est pas un
mauvais terme c'est de dire eh bien tout
ce qu'on a pensé depuis deux ans et demi
on va là on va le mettre en application
la ce qu'on appelle la cité champeau qui
est pas très loin qu'on a construit
spécialement pour ça et pendant ce temps
là on va élaborer complètement ce qu'on
remettra dans la cité éducative
justement pour rester en dedans sur la
question de l' architecture justement
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous tirer
comme leçon de ce qui a été fait du
passé et les erreurs à ne plus
reproduire en matière de l'architecturé
alors si on pouvait ne plus revenir
d'erreur sera d'ailleurs jamais je suis
jamais elle complètement convaincu non
c'est vrai que ici les erreurs sont
flagrantes 1
ne pas penser enfin penser une ville
sans penser la vie de l'habitant parce
que c'était ça ça a été ça a été une
ville une ville idéale selon
selon un architecte mildiou mais cette
ville idéale a été idée a été idéale
pour le moment où il a construit or on
est obligé de se projeter dans 10 ans 20
ans 30 ans c'est à dire comment évolue
une population que données économiques
restent peu stable à et
aimeriez clic en plus une ville sa vie
et donc comment penser l'urbanisme de
demain en pensant que ça va vivre ça
doit s'inclure alors moi demande par
exemple à à tout ce qu'on a fait on a
beaucoup construit ce que les habitants
en fait il ya quinze ans ils voulaient
tous partir de champion voie de la cité
et demande de logements étaient en
dehors de chanteloup maintenant il y en
a que deux ou trois qui veulent partir
ils veulent tous rester c'est dans des
endroits différents soit dans le hlm et
dans un appartement plus grand soin
devenir propriétaire soit donc en fait
ils sont ils sont demandeurs de rester
dans ce qui a fait leur vie parce qu'ils
y ont pris leur part mais il faut se il
faut à mon avis construire c'est pas le
seul élément mais il faut à mon avis
construire comme si ça s'était fait au
fil du temps et n'ont pas amené un geste
architectural un a priori
la priory architectural l'architecte il
a oui mais nous on doit avoir on doit
avoir le son on doit avoir lieu en fin
le sentiment qu'il faut que ça vive pour
les habitants d'aujourd'hui les
habitants de demain les habitants
d'après de masse dire que quand la
population évolue comment évolue le lieu
est donc tout ce qu'on a fait construire
là depuis quinze ans et il faut que ça
soit ça s'intègre dans avec les nouveaux
usages avec les nouveaux palais nouveau
public avec alors on gagne jamais
complètement mai et puis surtout et
surtout c'est fini à mon avis ce temps
dieu on impose une densité énorme dans
un territoire qui va devoir l'absorber
avec difficulté on fait toujours quelque
chose a encore à l'échelle humaine
jamais plus de 50 60 logements de façon
à ce que les habitants ne soient pas
considérés comme des étrangers dans un
territoire mais s'intègre très vite et
prennent leur part dans l'évolution de
ce territoire
il ya beaucoup
d'expérience d'expérimentation qui sont
faites dans cette partie des quartiers
de la ville par les maires et vous avez
lancé avec d'autres mères d'ailleurs le
conseil national des solutions où on sûr
qu'il ya quelque chose qui est en train
de changer c'est à dire que pendant
longtemps les maires d'aidé il y avait
des quartiers de la politique de la
ville était un peu considérée par l'état
comme des ans werder qui venait demander
qui venait quémander
l'impression qu'ils étaient en train de
changer et qu'on est en train de
s'apercevoir qu'ils ont fait des choses
qu'ils ont fait des expérimentations des
choses qui ont marché au groupe a marché
mais on peut choisir et que ce sont les
maires qui influence aujourd'hui la la
politique de l'état ça serait beau
on aimerait que ça c'est comme ça oui on
est un certain nombre de maires qui nous
connaissons depuis longtemps qui
viennent de la france entière de tout
parti politique et qui ont en commun
voilà d'avoir des quartiers et d'avoir
eu des politiques de proximité d'avoir
d'avoir porté les politiques des
habitants plus que plus que imposer des
politiques
institutionnels et on s'est aperçu et on
en parle très souvent on s'est aperçu
qu'en fait si nos quartiers elle est
plutôt un peu mieux ou s'il y avait des
choses formidables qui se faisaient
c'était le fait de l'énergie du
territoire de l'énergie des habitants et
qui avait plein de solutions locales qui
avaient comme qui avait comme à venir
d'être déclinée nationalement alors on
l'a vu petit à petit mais mais en fait
on est tellement le nez sur le guidon
qu' il faut se retourner 20 ans en
arrière pour s'apercevoir qu'en fait
c'est dans les quartiers que telle chose
a commencé telle chose a commencé donc
on est parti de ce principe là en disant
des solutions des problèmes locaux tout
le monde et connaît des solutions lequel
nous les avons souvent elles sont elles
sont ignorés ou elles ne sont connus que
du tir et du territoire qu'il fait est
alors qu'elles ont la possibilité d'être
d'être pansées d'une façon plus
nationale et puis surtout elles ont la
possibilité de ne plus être cette
politique ascendante descendante d'un an
qui dit il faut faire ça et en fait ça
ne s'applique pas aux quartiers nous
l'idée c'est vraiment il ya des
solutions locales ces solutions locales
on les évalue localement on s'aperçoit
qu'elles ont une elles ont une vraie une
vraie portée positive et donc on se pose
la question de savoir si elles peuvent
pas décliner ailleurs ça c'est d'abord
ça rend les gens extrêmement fiers de
porter des solutions locales extrêmement
mobilisé puis en plus qui est un truc
qu'on sait très bien faire ce qu'on nous
l'a appris depuis 30 ans est évaluée on
nous demande toujours de nous évaluer
nous ou le fait comme si les maires de
la politique de la ville était et est
moins sérieux que les maires comme une
merde vie normale donc nous on est
autour de nous évaluer mais ok non
s'évalue tout le temps parce qu'en fait
à chaque fois qu'on fait des petits pas
il faut surtout pas en avoir fait 3 et
s'apercevoir que ça va pas il faut
s'arrêter au 1er faut évaluer fort faut
il faut revoir le parcours et donc on a
cette politique d'évaluation permanente
elle est dans nos gènes il ya comme ça
que ça peut marcher d'ailleurs
non mais vous d'ailleurs vous vous dites
quelque chose de fondamental là dessus
ou dit que les territoires ne sont pas
un poids pour le pays mais les
opportunités
et je dois d'abord parce qu'on veut tous
que ça qu'on sorte de cette description
de nos quartiers qui n'est qu'une
description des problématiques
alors qu'en fait nous avons des
quartiers jaune nous avons des quartiers
qui sont extrêmement qui ont une énergie
d'enfer alors c'est un peu normal
l'énergie un l'énergie c'est quand on
doit encore rien n'est simple et qu'on
doit trouver seul mais généralement à
plusieurs une façon de sortir d'une
problématique donc ça donne une énergie
l'enfer et ça se voit sur nos quartiers
c'est le nombre de jeunes qui veulent me
créer leur entreprise
le nombre d'associations qui créent des
dispositifs nouveaux voilà le nombre le
nombre d'habitants qui qui viennent se
mobiliser pour des causes alors que l'or
leurs vies ne l'oeil prédestinait pas à
ça mais il ya une énergie dans feria
nous sommes des quartiers jeunes une
énergie d'en faire des savoir-faire des
micros savoir faire locaux qui est on
arrive à décliner et donc en fait si on
met tout ça bout à bout mais on
s'aperçoit que c'est quoi la france de
demain c'est la france de sa jeunesse et
la france de l'énergie c'est la france
du savoir-faire bas nous avons tous
assurent nos quartiers dire ce que dit
un peu jalouse c'est par ces quartiers
qu'on va arriver à faire une nation un
c'est ça qui c'est ça qui est pas ce
qu'est ce qui se passe de bien dans cet
article c'est sympa mais oui parce qu'en
plus ces quartiers avec les habitantes
et les habitants de ses créations mais
aussi une particularité c'est qu'il ne
regarde et regarde très peu en arrière
il regarde toujours en avant ils pensent
leur avenir plus que penser leur passé
c'est aussi le fait que le passé cours
sur nos quartiers le passé a été
compliqué sur nos casiers donc en fait
il se projette vers l'avenir mais c'est
peut-être un peu ça qu'on demande à la
nation s'est projeté vers l'avenir tout
simplement d'être réaliste je crois
qu'ils sont pragmatiques un moment donné
je crois que les quartiers aujourd'hui
sont devenus pragmatiques donc quand on
peut pas on fait
il ya rafal sonik était le préfet à
l'égalité des chances donc on a
interviewé au début de cette émission
disait la politique de la ville ça
marche ça m'a notamment l'éducation ça
marche bien la cité éducative il ya
peut-être encore un problème concernant
l'emploi et l'insertion vous partagez ce
wee a largement ya un problème oui parce
que ce qu'on fait dans le domaine de
l'éducation n'a pas encore porté ses
fruits ce sont des saisons des
dispositifs et des avancées trop raide
il faut il faut au moins 15 ans pour
voir si ça va apporter c'est vrai ça les
portera mais oui on a des vrais
problèmes de formation
chez les jeunes on a des vrais problèmes
dans vie collectifs en fait ce qu'on
monte à depuis quelques années dans
beaucoup de nos territoires c'est donner
aux jeunes
la possibilité d'arrêter de s'interdire
parce qu'en fait il ya eu pendant très
très longtemps vous le disiez tout à
l'heure il ya eu pendant très très
longtemps des interdictions programmé
quoi l'avenir est l avenir était
programmé sur ces jeunes sur certains
métiers sur certaines formations le
plafond nouvel an et le plafond de verre
or en fait on a honte je crois que
d'abord leur redonner leur liberté leur
liberté doser leur liberté d'arrêter de
s'interdire et puis après c'est à la
société d accompagner quand ils ont le
courage d'arrêter s'interdire et ça
c'est ça aussi donc la formation elle
est basée là-dessus ici on a par exemple
j'ai pas si vous en parlerez mais depuis
trail depuis pas mal de temps un
dispositif avec l'essec qui s'appelle
une grande école pourquoi pas moi mais
c'est vraiment le dispositif phare qui
est vraiment vous vous êtes vous ne vous
interdisez pas et pas parce que vous
avez le courage et l'envié nous on se
doit de vous accompagner mais alors
justement est ce que vous n'avez pas
l'impression qu'on fait un pas en avant
on en fait disent en arrière parce que
cette discussion on l'a vu sur
moi qui suis pas mal engagées sur ces
sujets depuis une vingtaine d'années en
2006-2007 après la révolte des banlieues
il ya eu tout un mouvement qui est qui
qui est née de sa et avec à la
conclusion la fameuse filière égalité
des chances qui visait à gt parrain de
la chaire égalité des chances de dos
film par exemple où justement l'objectif
c'était de casser cette 7e place ce
plafond de verre est d'emmener des
jeunes qui jamais n'aurait pensé aller
dans ses grandes écoles y aller mais
j'ai l'impression qu'on fait on va faire
un pas quand il ya un autre gouvernement
qui arrive derrière on recule quand il
ya d'autres qui prennent le pouvoir on
reprend peut-être un tout petit peu
parfois et mais c'est pas une question
de politique générale et après ça au
niveau de la formation vous parle quand
vous parlez de la formation est ce que
on n'a pas de dévaloriser justement la
formation contrairement à des pays comme
l'allemagne qui ont toujours valoriser
la formation et qui met en avant parce
qu'on a l'impression que ce sont des
filières de garage
lorsqu'on va en formation qu'est ce
qu'il faudrait faire pour celle à qui
elle d'encore plus absolument à la
baisse et là justement que le fait d'
inverser la tendance et d'arrêter de
lutter contre l'échec scolaire cas quand
même été les programmes réguliers depuis
20 ans on arrêtait de on essayait
d'arrêter l'échec scolaire je pense
qu'il faut complètement inversé et on
est en accompagnement de la réussite et
quand on accompagne la réussite en
fonction de la compétence de l'enfant on
a plus de problème de savoir si une
formation qualifiante pas qualifiante et
tout ça on accompagne on accompagne
l'enfant en fonction de sa propre
compétence et nous on a pas à dire ce
que sera son avenir son avenir on doit
le porter on doit l'accompagner et et
dans ces cas là on a plus dire archi
dans les formations la pharmacie a fallu
aller dans une formation pour passer
ainsi ap ou aller dans une grande école
c'est la même qualité de réussite c'est
simplement ça que ça accompagne la
volonté et l'envié de l'enfant c'est
complètement différent mais il ya quand
même un changement de paradigme c'est
dire que
jusque jusqu'à n'y a pas très longtemps
les écoles dans ces quartiers s'étaient
pas forcément les meilleurs les
établissements scolaires un petit même
si des signaux sodebo coup là c'est
l'excellence qui vient dans ces
quartiers avec la cité éducative notre
sélection c'est katia mais l'excellence
en fait elle s'appuie sur les enfants
qui sont là elles ne créent pas une
excellence
sorti de nulle part elle s'appuie sur
les compétences des enfants qui sont là
elle s'appuie sur la volonté des parents
d'accompagner moi je suis stupéfaite
depuis c'est fini le temps enfin et en
tout cas ici c'est fini la période de
l'enfant du parent qui abandonne c'est
fini vous demander aux enseignants
demandé au principal de collège vous
verrez la qualité du suivi et le
volontarisme des parents maintenant
pourquoi pas parce que ils ont quand
même été exclu très longtemps et ils ont
été exclus pour plein de raisons parce
qu'il y avait leur parcours avait été
chaotique mais pour eux mêmes et puis
parce que spontanément on ne considérait
pas comme un co et éducateurs du
bâtiment ils sont qu un éducateur banon
et qu'ils existent dans cette danse est
dans cette éducation fait par tous ben
en fait ils jouent complètement le rôle
et je peux vous assurer qu'ils sont
sacrément présent 1 mais est en même
temps on a on a on a quand même un
déficit souvent dans ces quartiers et
justement c'est peut-être là où les les
structures comme les mairies ou les
associations peuvent faire un un vrai
boulot c'est sur la question de la
culture générale souvent dans ces
quartiers les gens qui sont issus de ces
quartiers quand il arrive par exemple
dans les grandes écoles la première
année par exemple elle va consister à
avoir des des mentors qui vont les
accompagner sur la question de la
culture générale comment peut remédier à
ça aujourd'hui parce que c'est le
fondement de 2,2 de cet échec entre
guillemets 1
là dessus d'abord parce que la culture
générale c'est l'ouverture des yeux
surtout sur la vie sur sur l'art sur la
géographie sur la musique voilà la
culture générale c'est ça hein c'est
ouvrir c'est juste donc d'abord leur
apprendre à ouvrir les yeux sur autre
chose que ce qui est ce qui a été lent
ce qui est leur quotidien
effectivement faut aller chercher
ailleurs bon allez je vais chercher
ailleurs des partenariats et faut qu'il
faut que ces partenariats là tu sois sûr
que ici aussi il ya une richesse qui
sera la culture de demain parce que
c'est ça aussi c'est à la fois leur
ouvrir les yeux mais il faut qu'il
participe à la culture de demain c'est à
dire tu participes à l'art de mag on a
par exemple un partenariat avec le
théâtre montansier on a un partenariat
avec l'opéra comique et mais c'est eux
qui viennent pour accompagner les des
tranches d'âge voilà enfin en faisant en
fait de la culture en faisant une de la
culture qui est à la fois la culture un
peu ancestrale mais cultures adaptées à
ce que à ce qu'est la france en 2022 ce
qui la fonde le quartier aussi en 2022
et en fait ce partenariat est
extrêmement riche vous verriez les
gamins au théâtre montansier alors
évidemment nos loulous convoyés en visio
hills est c'est vers ça ici
parce qu'ils n'oublient pas ce qui la
prive du dal télévision avait de la
lumière mais bien sûr il y avait la
foule mais c'est génial combien en plus
seul et les gens du théâtre montansier
était super fier de l'attention des
gamins et combien les gamins étaient
très était super fier de l'attention
qu'on leur portait enfin j'y vois moi
c'est un truc gagnant gagnant ça donc
effectivement la culture donc dans une
dans la politique de la ville culture et
sport ça fait le sport aussi absolument
partie le sport comme facteur
d'intégration
capacité d'évoluer de grandir de vivre
comme les autres français il ya une
question du tout parlé tout à l'heure
avec romain c'est bien c'est celle de
l'image quand même des quartiers elle
reste très très présente en fait c'est
ça le plus compliqué et je pense que
c'est de ça aussi qu'on veut qu'on
souffre encore et compassion dont on va
s'ouvrir longtemps et il faut vraiment
alors là on est tous responsables de
l'image de nos quartiers et on est tous
responsables que l'image que l'image
change et ça aussi ça c'est un message
qu'il faut pas c'est qu'il faut qu on
porte tous habitants d'une ville comme
ça c'est qu'il faut qu'on contribue à
changer l'image de quartier et surtout
pas à rester dans cette espèce de
ambiance misérabilisme cas quand même
été cette ambiance-là de la politique
david oui on est fiers d'habiter ici oui
on est fiers de grandir ici on est fier
de réussir ici mais faut que s'il n'y a
pas de fierté sur la territoire l'image
ne changera pas elle est pas que le fait
des médias elle est aussi le fait de
cette façon d'aborder notre propre
avenir mais ce que vous pensez que c'est
pas plus profond que ça parce que entre
la perception qu'on peut en avoir soi
de ces quartiers je peux vous dire que
la plupart d'ailleurs
contrairement ce que les gens pensent
ils sont très fiers de leur quartier il
le revendique
je vois moi qui suis rappeur je vois la
plupart des directs cesser leur maman en
fait leur quartier c'est quand ils
auront ils le revendiquent avec une
telle force et d'ailleurs ça crée même
des conflits avec d'autres quartiers
parfois tellement ils sont ils
revendiquent leur quartier mais c'est le
plus tôt plutôt le regard d d d d autres
et ça qu'elle comment on peut faire pour
que ça change là dessus alors moi j'ai
un peu simpliste le regard le regard des
autres change si ce regard est
accompagné d'une envie
il faut qu'en fait on nous en donne
envie il faut qu'on nous envie notre
réussite là où rien n'était programmé
pour la réussite il faut qu'on nous
envie quand j'ai commencé la cité
éducative il ya un directeur
départemental de l'éducation nationale
de l'époque qui m'a dit attendez madame
are no 6 a réussi mais tout le monde va
vouloir venir chez vous vous rendez
compte vous n'arrivez pas supporté j'ai
dit mais le jour où ça m'arrive au mieux
un jour j'arrive à chanteloup ma femme
tenait là y aura plus de l'image des
quartiers abbas et ça je pense qu'il
faut donner envie il faut que cette
réussite à un moment donné elles
apparaissent au grand jour il faut
donner envie un petit beau quand même
sur votre métier on était avec pierre
cardo au début d'émission qui était
votre prédécesseur avec vous pour
conclure cette émission sur ce métier de
maire qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui vous
fait vous lever tous les jours à
10 ans parce que y'a assez pâle ce n'est
pas le métier le plus simple parmi les
maires je suppose d'être maire d'une
ville comme chante look mais alors c'est
un peu compliqué moi je veux
je crois en fait je suis pas sûr que
j'étais fait pour être mère mais je suis
sûr que j'étais fait pour être maire de
chanteloup
et c'est pas pareil et c'est pas parce
que dieu pierre cardo d'ailleurs c'est
un territoire qui prend aux tripes
sadr et or qui prend aux tripes d'abord
parce qu'il y avait il y avait une
discrimination et une inégalité
entre territoires et comportait un tout
qui était insupportable vraiment
insupportable et moi lutter contre
contre les inégalités c'est pratiquement
cg ça dans les tripes mais c'est aussi
parce que les habitants sont sont vives
dans l'affectif vivent dans la relation
affective dans l' envie de ferran sens
vide alors la relation affective c'est
je t'aime je t'aime pas on est bien
d'accord un c'est pas toujours je t'aime
mais au moins c'est on a enfin moi j'ai
vraiment le sentiment là que c'est pas
la ville c'est une succession de
personnes cette ville et quand on arrive
à chanteuse s'est laissée comme le nord
on pleure en arrivant et un pleur en
repartant dayan par papa mais justement
il ya un film qui s'appelle les
promesses de thomas krutov avec isabelle
huppert et reda kateb et qui s'est un
peu inspiré de vous et de votre
directeur de cabinet rémy en gros que je
remercie parce que ces cdt veut le
véritable rédacteur en chef de sept et
visio et justement j'ai rencontré thomas
chritophe qui parle un peu de la façon
dont s'est inspiré de votre couple si je
peux dire beaucoup d'eau pour les rôle
d'isabelle huppert et dirt et à kateb
[Musique]
j'ai rencontré catherine
comme un peu au milieu du développent du
développement du du scénario et et et
j'avais déjà suivi je l'avais déjà un
peu vu dans diverses interventions
médiatiques et donc voilà j'avais envie
de la rencontrer j'avais envie aussi de
rencontrer lé ce duo puisque donne dans
le film raconte un duo entre isabelle
huppert et son directeur de cabinet reda
kateb j'ai envie aussi de rencontrer son
directeur de cabinet rémy en grand mais
voilà elle avait elle avait il y avait
chez catherine certaines des choses que
j'imaginais un peu chez le personnage et
qui ont participé un peu à l'enrichir
mais oui c'était c'était une rencontre
assez inspirante cas catherine arnould
probablement bon pour pas mal de raisons
quelque chose de singulier chez elle que
je serai pas complètement expliquer mais
il met quelque chose aussi d'une énergie
et une détermination
une franchise
quand je vais demander ce qu'elle avait
fait comme métier avant d'être d'être
mère avec elle m'a dit qu'elle a été
médecin
j'ai d'ailleurs ça m'a fait changer le
background des personnages du film et je
me suis dit oui dans le personnage comme
comme katrina était médecin avant mais
j'imaginais catherine médecin
j'imaginais la manière dont elle
pourrait s'adresser à un patient comme
elle pourrait s'adresser à un citoyen
c'est à dire d'une manière d'une manière
claire d'une manière
pratique active
[Musique]
moi j'étais toujours être étonné dans
des villes de la taille de chant tout
même dans des villes plus grandes à quel
point en fait un maire est exposé aux
habitants en permanence quoi il ya des
permanences ont enfin quand je dis il ya
des permanences et à dire qu'ils
allaient il ya des créneaux dans son
emploi du temps pour recevoir des
habitants un parent étudier leurs
problèmes etc puis en plus c'est aussi
un métier qu'on arrête jamais dès qu'on
marche surtout quand on habite dans sa
ville voilà on est tout le temps exposé
un petit peu au problème paraît parfois
des choses très chaleureux des choses
très très très positif mais cette espèce
de mélange permanent de voilà de vie qui
nous qui nous assaillent quand quand on
fait ce métier là voilà et à celle est
assez frappant est effectivement pour le
film catherine a été une des figures
vraiment vraiment inspirante pour compte
pour construire le personnage
[Musique]
c'est pas mal on parlait de l'image fait
une image de la berd de de chantoux qui
devient isabelle huppert c'est quand
même bien pour
nom pour isabelle huppert oui il ya pour
l'ascension patrie
et pour reda kateb qui devient répondre
en
voilà mais alors alors c'est une folie
quand même d'être maire d'une ville
pour avoir fait plusieurs campagnes avec
des candidats qui va les demandes et les
accompagner à des périodes quand vous
marchez dans la rue enfin je me demande
comment on fait pour garder son calme en
permanence pour avoir toujours l'énergie
de continuer à faire ça et et vous quels
seraient les prochaines étapes pour vous
au niveau national par exemple su
répondre à la question de la vente la
préfère la question d'après dans le film
isabelle huppert lui proposa un moment
de devenir ministre d'ailleurs mais
alors et moi je pense que
j'avais jamais rien programmé dans ma
vie et c'est ça m'a sauvé puisque du
coup on n'a pas peur de l'avenir parce
qu'on n'a pas programmé c'est un peu
pierre cardo et quand je dis c'est un
peu c'est complètement pierre cardo qui
est venu me chercher et insister 1,6 et
insister lourdement il pourra compter
que ça dure et quelques années parce que
j'avais pas tout compris de ceux que je
vous laisse faire rager dire comment je
pourrais servir une fois que vous une
fois qu'on a compris après il ya eu
tellement de sujets alors comment garder
son calme d'aucuns diront que je ne
garde pas tout le temps
et en plus je me revendique avec mes
colères mais voilà mes foucades j'ai le
droit je trouve que ça fait partie du
personnage
j'essaye de le retenir parce qu'on doit
toujours essayer de se retenir c'est un
principe mais on a le droit aussi de
temps en temps trop c'est trop on a le
droit de temps en temps de dire ça va
passer vite c'est plutôt ça qu'ils
entendent de noms mais on a le droit
enfin on a le droit d'être entier moi je
considère les les habitants c'est pareil
à l'est mes interlocuteurs certains
adultes ils ont leurs qualités leurs
défauts c'est en tout cas et donc il
faut prendre les gens avec dans l'ordre
dans leur totalité mais vous n'êtes pas
posé la question mais il ya une chose
aussi dans un territoire comme ça on est
porté poussé par les équipes on est
poussé par les associations on est
poussé par les habitants j'avoue dire
vous allez le voir tout au long de ces
interviews on est poussé par des équipes
qui croient terriblement qui savent à
quoi ils servent qu'il soit fort courant
elle se lève le matin et des équipes qui
se qui se projette dans l'avenir et ça
je vais vous dire déjà ne jamais ne
jamais les décevoir et puis surtout
avoir toujours ce rôle de toujours les
entraîner c'est un espèce de c'est une
vie ensemble que nous avons il faut pas
qu'il y ait des éléments qui s'est donc
en fait on est on est une espèce de
grandes familles qui partent qui avons
une énergie d'enfer pour faire évoluer
ce territoire et en plus cette mère
c'est c'est être concret c'est de voir
comment la la comment il peut y avoir
une amélioration dans un problématique
individuelle mais dans une problématique
collective aussi de voir comment le
territoire peut évoluer alors
l'urbanisme c'est pas tout mais
l'urbanisme il ya des choses qui se voit
de voir que de suivre les gamins et
devoirs à 15 ans qui sont venus alors
qu'il ya sept ans on était très inquiet
pour eux c'est ça le voir au quotidien
l'évolution des gens des habitants d'une
ville
ça c'est comme ça être médecin c'est la
même chose et pour être concret c'est
quoi la prochaine étape alors j'ai pas
de prochaine étape parce que je pense
que
je pense qu'être mais alors je vis une
période formidable aussi parce que je
travaille je suis au département des
yvelines et je suis au département des
yvelines sur les actions politiques de
la ville renouvellement urbain et
insertion lui dit aussi donc activity
insertion et donc cesser complètement
complémentaire je m'enrichis de ce que
j'ai j'apprends ici pour faire pour pour
avoir une politique plus globale qui la
politique départementale mais qui est
halak est juste l'échelon au dessus et
je pense que c'est les échelons qui me
vont bien
merci merci beaucoup qui a trait nardou
rost merci je crois qu'on a essayé se
dévoila et
de ce qui se faisait en réalité dans
cette dans cette ville de chanteloup
j'espère qu'on aura donné une une bonne
image je crois en tout cas nous on a été
assez par le développement
l'investissement de tout ce qui c'était
très enrichissant c'est on a
l'impression que l'on re situe l'être
humain au centre du débat et c'est ça le
plus important quand on considère
l'humain je pense qu'on fait les choses
autrement et on les fait certainement
mieux va très vite pour un nouveau
numéro c'était le premier numéro de
tribunes merci encore à rémy en grand
grâce à qui cette émission a pu avoir
voir le jour chez merci beaucoup et 90
c'était le numéro deux tribunes
[Musique]